Start with the Pledge of Allegiance of the flag.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
All right.
First, we will have the report of the superintendent and then I will make the usual announcements and then we will take up item 19 for the election of officers of the board.
So, superintendent.
Board members, public, Happy New Year.
We have an action packed year in front of us.
We've accomplished a lot last year and we'll get more done in 2018.
So welcome to the first state board meeting of the year.
I want to give a quick update on a number of fronts.
First, let me introduce two new division directors.
We have Lisa Constancio.
She will be heading up our charter schools division.
He is responsible for more than, in that position, more than 600,000 students in our 1,200 public charter schools.
So Lisa's here, just wanted to have her stand up and be recognized and thank her for taking on that task.
She previously served as a consultant with the School Facilities and Transportation Services Division, and we welcome her to Charter Schools.
And then Lisa Mistretti is Director of the Fiscal and Administrative Services Division, where she previously oversaw the Budget Management Unit.
She was also an Associate Director of the Department of Corrections and Rehabilitation, and so she's joining our team, and would she please stand up and be recognized?
Lisa.
That's two leases.
Easy to remember.
So next state budget.
Just a couple of quick comments and highlights.
The governor last week, of course, released a budget is full of good news.
The budget provides a big boost to our public schools.
It shows how far we've come in the past seven years and increasing investments in education.
So our students can succeed in college and the fiercely competitive 21st century economy.
We have to thank the voters of the state for voting for Prop 55 and Prop 30 before that and believing in our public schools and wanting to invest in our public schools.
And I recall back in early 2011, do you remember when we had a call, emergency call?
And we said, I declared a state of fiscal emergency for the state of California.
Well, thank goodness.
We had already lost about 20,000 teachers to layoffs, and we're facing another 10,000 teachers to be laid off if the voters hadn't supported us.
So all the good work that we've done, the districts have done, has worked.
I want to mention that the proposal from the Governor includes $3.8 billion to the annual Proposition 98 guarantees, which will raise per-pupil spending 66% above the 2011-2012 levels.
Total Prop 98 funding in the same period has gone from $47 billion at that time in 2011-12 to more than $78 billion.
That's a $31 billion increase over these few years.
The budget also fully funds the local control funding formula two years ahead of schedule.
In addition, the governor's proposed $100 million
to the commission on teacher credentialing for new programs to help train and retain teachers.
And I'm pleased he plans also to release 640 million in bond funds to pay for critically needed school facilities.
We also thank the governor for maintaining the three-year commitment to increased access and funding for early childhood education.
We have been beset with more disasters, unfortunately.
I reported last board meeting on the fight in Northern California with the wildfires in that area.
At that time, we were having about 300,000 students out of school.
652 schools were closed for one or more days and many for weeks because of the fire disaster in Northern California.
The December fires at peak, 532 schools affected, closed, and 300,000 students out of the classroom.
Again, I want to thank Glenn Price and Brianna Mullen and the whole team, OES.
We work closely with OES.
And they asked us, CDE, and Glenn headed that effort up to coordinate the reopening issues, certifying that hazardous materials were cleared from school sites before students returned.
So they did a terrific job working with the National Guard and Cal Fire, Cal EPA, and Cal Recycle.
We learned a lot from these disasters on what we can do even better to be prepared in the future.
Unfortunately, of course, the fires destabilized.
Without the trees, the slopes were destabilized and we had the mudslides.
And so far, 18 confirmed deaths and many more possible to be confirmed yet.
So our prayers go out and our hearts go out to the families that have been affected by a loss of life or child and just by the full disruption that's gone on.
We have to praise the teachers and school officials for working very closely.
Santa Barbara, Susan Salcedo is doing a great job as county superintendent there.
And we've been providing everything from portables to counselors to help with the shock, the trauma, the post-traumatic syndrome, as it were.
chronic absenteeism.
On a very positive note, this board has worked very focused on this issue.
We've worked in CDE very focused on this issue.
In December, I announced the availability of statewide chronic absenteeism data for the first time in California.
This will provide a new understanding of absenteeism rates and enable schools to see at a comprehensive level which students are missing school and in danger of falling behind.
A big thanks goes to Kerrick Ashley, the state board staff, Cindy Kazanas, and all the other staff who spent so much time getting this effort together, getting this data available.
This data helps us determine which schools
Districts and student groups have the largest concentration of chronic absences.
We are helping educators and community members focus attention and resources and take actions to keep those students in class and back on the path to academic success.
When California enacted LCFF, we were one of only two states in the country to build an indicator around chronic absence.
School districts must now track and address chronic absence as part of their LCAPs.
We are focusing on preventing attendance problems by promoting a positive school climate, ensuring early interventions and addressing barriers to school attendance.
The other big news announced in December was the dashboard.
Again, kudos to the state board staff and members and to Kerrick Ashley, Cindy Kazanas and Jenny Singh for their outstanding work bringing the dashboard to us.
It comes at the same time, and we did that purposely, as we launched the new statewide system of support, which this board has been reviewing and giving input to and helping focus on that system of support.
This is a critical moment in our education reform efforts because we are now turning data
into direct action.
We are identifying districts that face challenges in certain areas and providing them with help rather than sanctions.
This system, as we've developed, has a keen and special focus on equity.
It is designed to shine a light on the students who need this help the most.
And finally, I'll mention that we had a trip to Tijuana to meet with Secretary Mendoza of Baja.
And we learned a lot about our students who were caught in the deportation, caught in the migration issues.
We learned that in visiting several schools that about 50,000 students are going to school in Baja.
who are U.S.
born.
And it turned out as we sat, we met with high school students, we met with elementary school students.
In one roundtable at one of the schools, we asked what city did they come from in California?
and what's it like adjusting to life in Mexico, in Baja.
One girl, Cindy Mateas, Clara Mateas, said, I went to Pittsburgh.
I came from Pittsburgh, California, and I went to Los Maldonados Elementary School.
I said,
That school is one mile from my house where I live.
And she went for three years.
And these 50,000 students don't speak Spanish.
They're coming back to Mexico having been brought up speaking English.
So a large portion of that 50,000 are struggling and taking on the challenge of learning the Spanish language as well as the English language.
So I just thought I'd give that anecdote that I'm writing her a letter and I told her we'll be pen pals and we'll keep in touch.
So we know that this will be a very busy year.
I predict a productive year.
Much progress we made last year, as I said before.
And we know yet there's so much work to be done.
Working together, we'll make it happen.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So I will open with the announcements that were typically made at the beginning.
And we also have on the State Board of Education staff a new person to announce, Sarah Petrowski.
Please stand up.
OK, there she is.
And she's a graduate of both undergraduate and master's in public policy analysis degrees from the University of Southern California.
And she has worked in the Sacramento City District on a lot of our topics, assessment, research, and evaluation, accountability, LCAP, strategic planning, and knows how to work with parents and stakeholders in this work.
So she will be working at the State Board of Education staff office on accountability work, including CPAG, school climate, and community engagement.
Please join us in welcoming Sarah.
Changes in the agenda.
We will begin today's open session with item 19, SVE priorities to take up officer elections only before opening item 1, item 8, and item
22 have been pulled from our agenda and are not going to be heard at this meeting.
We have four public hearings tomorrow, item 21, 23, 24, and 25.
calendar and waiver consent items are the following.
The regular consent items are item 9 through item 17.
And then we also have the items for waiver consent, which are W1 through W19.
And there's a handout on the table where you can sign up to speak on those items as well.
Then another set of announcements on the usual things for our procedure.
Letters from the public on matters before the board were aggregated and filed in the members' electronic folders sent out before the meeting.
We have a fully electronic agenda and a print copy in the lobby.
Speakers, you should sign up at the table outside the room.
Please identify the item number in which you want to speak.
We have item 20 at the end of the meeting tomorrow for general public comment.
If you wish to give the board something, please provide 25 copies to Amy Bubico at the front desk here on my right.
If you speak before the board, please introduce yourself and identify the organization you represent prior to speaking.
And then we have additional seating with TV monitors if needed in room 1801.
So now I'm going to turn the meeting over to open the eye of the bill, formal items with item 19.
And the state superintendent will conduct this part of the meeting.
Oh, okay.
We found the gavel.
So, thank you, Mr. President.
So, in keeping, I want to just preface our action for nominating and electing the President of the Board for this year.
In keeping with Article 4 of the State Board's bylaws, I would like to call for nominations for the Office of President.
Six votes are necessary to elect an officer and each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
So I will now open the floor for nominations for the Office of President.
Are there nominations?
So I would like to nominate Michael Kirst as President of the State Board of Education.
Is there a second to that?
It's my pleasure to second that motion.
Excellent.
Now we will have the vote but before that ask is there any public comment?
The motion is to elect Michael Kirst as president of this board for this year.
Having the motion made and seconded, all in favor, raise their hands.
Any opposed?
That is unanimous.
Congratulations, Mr. President Michael Kirst.
OK, right.
Thank you.
Appreciate this vote of confidence.
This will be my 15th year on the California State Board of Education.
I'd like to know if there's, you know, in history, anybody that served longer.
And of course, the first and fourth terms were separated by 40 years.
So quite a time.
So at this point, I will then run the election for the vice president.
And keeping with article four of the state board's bylaws, I would like to call for the nominations for the office of vice president.
Six votes are necessary to elect this officer.
Board member Sandoval.
I nominate Dr. Eileen Strauss for the position of vice president.
OK.
Motion has been made and seconded.
So is there any comment before we proceed?
Public comment?
Hearing none, then all members in favor, please raise your hands.
You can.
OK.
It is unanimous.
And it is my pleasure to announce that your vice president for 2018 has been elected, Dr. Eileen Strauss.
Okay, now we're ready for item one, which is the developing an integrated local, state and federal accountability system.
We're going to be focusing on the dashboard with some presenters who are going to help us understand how they really use it and feature examples of the dashboard being in use locally.
So Cindy Kazanis will present the opening item in terms of the overview and then we'll hear from our guests.
Good morning and Happy New Year members of the board and Superintendent Torlakson.
Thank you for the kind remarks about the release of the chronic absenteeism data as well as the dashboard.
It has been quite an amazing couple of months and it's a privilege to be in this role and helping the state release a new accountability system.
Today, we're going to, as President Kirsch said, we have some guest speakers.
I'm very excited to introduce those to you in a couple of slides.
You will not be taking action on this item.
There is no recommended action.
It's more of an update about the release and where we're headed.
Are you guys getting a little bit of an echo?
OK.
It always happens to me.
Okay, maybe they'll fix it as I'm speaking, if not, they're rock stars.
I don't know about that.
Okay, that's better.
So today, as I mentioned, you're gonna hear an update and then a couple of other.
about the dashboard as well.
So you'll be hearing about the dashboard probably for the bulk of the morning.
Just as a way of background, to get to this place, you all, as I've said on numerous occasions, put in a lot of hard work.
But just to give you a brief overview, it's been over a year since the evaluation rubrics were approved and, of course, rebranded as the dashboard.
in a later meeting.
We had a great deal of stakeholder input leading up to the private preview of the dashboard in February of 2017, and so I want to make sure that I spend a little bit of time talking about stakeholder input today, and also you're going to hear from some stakeholders, our clients, local educational agencies.
The dashboard and the field test that was released to the public in March went through some additional changes in April and continues to evolve as we released it in December.
I think what was critical to the success, not only in the pilot but also in the operational version of the dashboard, was we had an extended period for an LEA preview.
So there was five weeks for both, not only the release in spring, but also in the fall.
And what that allowed us to do was to provide some targeted assistance through a webinar series, as well as field phone calls, take emails on questions that LEAs had around the dashboard.
So as we got ready for the release on December 7th, they knew what was in the dashboard as far as the data.
no surprises in terms of the numbers that were there and we had fully to the extent possible vetted any questions that they had.
So as you saw in your board item there are some things just to highlight that are new to the dashboard as of December and that is the list of schools report, the college career indicator status information.
We do have some new college career indicator reports that we were able to demo at a meeting last month with
with member Rucker and member Ortiz-Lacon, and then we also were able to add in the chronic absenteeism links to DataQuest.
We still have some work to do, so we are still working on making sure that we can provide
these in a printable version through a PDF functionality that our contractor, Sam Joaquin, will be adding shortly.
We are going to be working with Google on helping them to improve the Spanish translation.
And then the governor, in his budget that was released last week, is proposing $300,000 to improve user interface.
And as part of that funding, if it were to be successful in the budgetary process, it would also allow for
some additional stakeholder, some targeted input for that purpose as well.
So we did have one attachment to this item.
We outlined the extensive outreach activities we had done over the last 60 to 75 days, but I wanted to spend a little bit of time on maybe my favorites, and also it will lead into the discussion
for those that are going to be presenting right after me.
So the first, and these are in chronological order, but there also seems to be, we're starting at the bottom of the state and we made our way up to Southern California, I noticed.
The first is the Alternative Accountability Policy Forum.
This is my first time attending, but I know my colleague Jenny Singh has attended in the past.
This is a very targeted forum.
conference for alternative schools, looking at accountability issues.
There is an abundance of charter schools there I have to say which is always good in this space because we want to make sure that we are not only serving our traditional schools but our charter schools that are serving in unique situations.
And we were asked to provide a pre-conference session and the room held about, had about 30 chairs in it.
And they had to bring in another round of chairs and another round of chairs.
And I think there ended up being close to 75 people.
And we had folks from Colorado.
There were a couple other states that were represented that decided to come to our session to learn about what California was doing.
We weren't part of the official conference.
Again, we were a pre-conference highlight.
But it was very interesting to be in a situation where you're hearing from other states as well.
throughout the conference and they had a lot of good feedback for where we were headed with our alternative schools metrics.
We also were offered as part of this conference to do a post-session with our Alternative Schools Task Force members who were able to attend.
And that was a very robust discussion.
And we actually just had a full day session with that task force the first week of January.
So we are on track to start being able to share out some of the things that they're, well, we've been sharing out what they're considering, but we've done some simulations and they've asked us to go back to the drawing board on a couple of things.
But we are on track to implement something this fall.
Moving on to our sort of our bread and butter, which is the California Education and Research Association.
This is what my peers and myself attend on an annual basis.
It was held in Anaheim, and I didn't realize, but they're almost at their 100th anniversary.
96 years and running, and I know President Curtis has participated in this conference in the past.
We always have an abundance of sessions there, but we did have three sessions, and I know Member Burr was recognized at the event as well, and she was able to come to our session talking about DataQuest, and specifically our public reporting with student-level data.
But we had a really dynamic session earlier in the conference with the dashboard, and in fact, my colleagues from Riverside County who will be presenting
in just a bit.
We're part of that presentation with us along with Alameda County Office of Education.
So we start to pick up friends as we go to these conferences and colleagues who want to participate and I think share out what they are doing and so that was a really powerful session and I think the participants got a lot out of it.
And then the final conference that was held, and it's always right after that first long week after Thanksgiving, is the Accountability Leadership Institute.
And that's, of course, hosted by the California Department of Education.
It's focused on Title III leads and our migrant student program representatives.
And we had two sessions related to accountability.
And in fact, the dashboard was repeated.
It was two sessions itself.
And large room, we were given the largest room for that particular session.
And so what I found about that conference that was interesting is these are LEA representatives, but they were super informed.
And so it was a very good, robust discussion of peers asking, if anything, tough questions, which we always appreciate.
But again, I just wanted to make sure that I highlighted in our long attachment on the various meetings we go to on a regular basis what we've been doing.
So next I want to turn it over again to Riverside County Office of Education under the leadership of Cynthia Glover-Woods.
I'll have her introduce her team.
We're so grateful they made the trip today and have been really true partners in helping us get the word out about the dashboard.
Yes.
You don't have anything on your screen in front of you?
It went blank.
Perhaps the gentleman in the room can help with this large screen that the board members look at.
What do you see there?
OK, so let's make one more change.
Black?
Oh, great.
Hang on a second here.
Whoops.
I can't see yours.
How's it look out there now?
Yeah.
Yes, it's just not a great view.
Give me a second here.
It should extend.
Yeah.
It should extend it.
There.
There you go.
OK, that's it.
A little massaging.
Whoops.
No, wait a minute.
OK, we're going to be OK.
Don't leave yet.
We had Riverside County up.
It was up the right way.
OK, so PDF doesn't work the same way PowerPoint does on dual displays.
So when you're doing a PDF, then you need to make sure that you're running in that mode.
When you're doing PowerPoint, it should work here too, but.
OK, thank you.
This is Cynthia Glover-Woods from Riverside County Office of Education.
Good morning, good morning everyone.
Good morning President Kurz, Superintendent Torlakson and members of the board.
My name is Cynthia Glover-Woods and I am honored and pleased to serve as the Chief Academic Officer for Riverside County Office of Education and on behalf of the Riverside County Superintendent of Schools,
Dr. Judy D. White, I'd like to express that we are extremely humbled to have the opportunity to share with you this morning and are honored to share how the California School Dashboard is helping us in Riverside County increase student performance for all students.
In Riverside County, we are committed to every student graduating from high school well prepared for college in the workforce.
And I'm excited to share that the California School Dashboard, the LCAP, and other components of our state's continuous improvement and accountability system have been very instrumental and really serve as the foundation for the ongoing support that we provide to our districts.
We are quite happy that we are able to collaborate with districts in Riverside County to help them in the implementation of actions they have for targeted student support as well as the collaboration that we have with other county offices, with state agencies and CDE staff to continue making sure that every student has every opportunity to be successful in this world.
I'm quite excited to again share that we have
three esteemed members of our Accountability Assessment and Continuous Improvement Unit that will be sharing with you some information this morning.
We have Dr. Melissa Bezanos, the Executive Director of that unit, as well as Steve Ion, Administrator, and Joanne Lauer, Director.
So at this time, I'll ask Dr. Bezanos to come forward and share with you how we are using the California School Dashboard to increase student performance in Riverside County.
Thank you, Cynthia.
Good morning, President Kurst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
As Cynthia shared, we are extremely delighted to be able to present today, and I did bring the rest of my team as well, just so that we're all in the room together.
You can put some faces to some of the work that we're doing, and we're just gonna share with you some of the highlights, knowing that we wanted to limit the amount of information shared today, but again, connecting the dashboard to, or turning data into action.
So first of all, we wanted to capitalize on some of the existing structures that were part of what we do in Riverside County Office of Education.
So again, we have a variety of different networks that were already in existence as it relates to providing services and support to all the districts in Riverside County.
So our initial goal was to utilize some of those existing structures in order to continue to build capacity with all of the district leaders and district staff related to the new California Accountability and Continuous Improvement System.
So again, we started when the indicators were being approved and the architecture was being approved, when there were discussions about status and change, the five by five grids.
What we wanted to do was go through, provide consistent messages across all of these networks so that they were kept up to speed with all of the developments that were occurring.
So when the dashboard was published, it wasn't a surprise that these are the methodologies, that these are some of the student groups of
that were being included within the accountability system.
So again, we have everything from our district superintendents and our instructional leaders network, which is attended by district assistant superintendents and chief academic officers and curriculum directors.
We have LCAP development teams, which are cross sections of districts.
So again, representative of both educational services and business services.
We have our state and federal program directors as well as our English learning directors.
And as you can see on the list that's displayed, it does take a variety of forms in different audiences across districts so that there was, again, a level of consistency from each different tier of a district down to school levels when we're working with principals.
families, our family engagement network.
We have also extended this across into our special education division with our student programs and services and our Riverside County SELPA and we also host a professional learning network with CCEE as well as participate in the Core Data Collaborative.
So again, as you can see by this list, we have a variety of different opportunities to engage with our districts so that we can ensure consistency of message and then also ensure that there is a level of understanding through a variety of different settings.
Internally, we also share this information within our county office staff so that they are kept up to speed with all the developments.
and across regions in the state.
I serve as the Region 10 lead for the RISDIS, Regional System of District and School Support.
My colleague Joanne Lauer is the Region 10 lead for Title III, and then Dr. Chun-Wu Lee is a RAND representative.
So again, state-level networks, we have an opportunity to share a lot of the developments across different county offices in different regions of the state.
So, when we, I'm just going to show a few examples.
I'm not going to go into detail of all of these, but one of the blessings that we were able to engage with is the convenings that were conducted by CCESA and the Curriculum Instruction Steering Committee.
They were able to put together a variety of resources that were then utilized by county offices across the state.
Again, keeping with that consistent message through all the different, the counties in the state and then down to the district level.
And we were able to utilize a lot of those resources in the presentations that we conducted, so that way we were, again, consistent across the state, but then also enabled us to utilize some of the learning that was taking place across the state in what we were doing to support our districts.
This is an example of Padlet, which is a digital kind of a post-it note tool.
And so we wanted to use additional resources that then our school districts could take back and use in their districts.
So for example, this was a conversation we had related to the spring dashboard and the mathematics academic indicator.
And we asked them to do surface level explorations of their data.
The second column, develop inquiry questions.
We looked at performance gaps, and then we looked at site variation.
So again, there were a variety of different methods that we utilized in order to engage with our districts.
This is an example from our family engagement network.
We wanted to focus on some of the why behind the development of this system.
So, for example, we looked at the student group report and we had conversations with them about the importance of publicly displaying
data for all of the different student groups that are accounted for in this system, as well as data for all of these different indicators.
And it was interesting to hear from them how important they felt it was to show the whole child, to be able to see the picture of a whole school.
Although there are different performance levels for different indicators and we are still in the evolution of this system, it was really refreshing to hear the conversation that they were,
understanding the need to really show more than just an academic or an academic performance index or place a label on a school.
And one big piece of emphasis in the variety of networks that we host is that we really need to get this down to the classroom level.
If what we talk about stays at the district level or stays in a plan that sits on a shelf, we don't get to turn data into action.
And so this is an image of showing the LCAP goal, state priorities, indicators, metrics, all the way down through student groups and into the individual students.
And our conversations relate to what are our leading indicators and formative measures that we're utilizing in order to measure progress throughout the year, not just when the dashboard is published.
The dashboard shouldn't be a surprise.
We also talk about the performance gaps and how do we ensure that there is impact for the different groups and we can accelerate learning for student groups that may not be performing at the expected level.
And we've offered opportunities for our districts to share what it is that they're doing.
So for example, Trevor Payton from Romoland School District, he's an assistant superintendent.
He shared a slide deck that he creates with leading indicators that is shared with his principals monthly so they can engage in conversations with their school staff about their progress in all of these different areas using local formative data.
Esperanza Arce, who's a principal in Val Verde Unified, she shared with a variety of our networks about how she took the dashboard data, the 5 by 5 tables, and each of her departments set targets for progress throughout the year that they can share within their data teams when they're working as a professional learning community.
They can have conversations about progress of individual student groups.
So, again, our goal is really to penetrate all the way down to the classroom level because the impact of all of this data really is where the students sit in the desks.
This is just another example.
I won't go through into too much detail here, but we did develop a tool for districts that need additional resources to facilitate dialogue internally with their staff.
So, actually tomorrow we have an LCAP network meeting that we're hosting and we're going to go through different sections of the dashboard with district leaders and LCAP teams.
And it starts with screenshots of each different page of the dashboard and just poses inquiry questions for them to dialogue around and determine, you know, what might be some next steps as they want to dig deeper into their data.
And lastly, again, as I mentioned, one of the most profound benefits of the variety of networks that we host is that districts get to share with one another, that we don't purport to have all of the answers or all of the solutions.
It's really about them being able to share their practices.
So, this is an example from our CalPADS network.
Catalina who is our executive director from our college and career unit, she was sharing with the CalPADS network about the impact of CalPADS data on all the indicators and talking about graduation rate and the college career indicators specifically.
So, again, really just trying to capitalize on those structures to be able to continue to share information.
Two examples from districts, I know this is very tiny, but Glenn Alegre from the Marino Valley Unified School District, he used Excel to be able to capture a lot of dashboard information in one screen, in one page.
And so he provided this to our county with all of our county districts included.
But he does this site by site, and so a principal can see for each student group, the performance on the indicator, they have the image of the performance level color, but then it also has their status and change, it has their end size, the number of students that are included, so that a principal will have a one-page kind of summary.
And then we invited Glenn to come to our office to then share with all the other districts how he was able to accomplish this and teach them the process so that other districts would be able to do this as well.
And then the last example comes from Palm Springs Unified School District, Dr. Jim Pfeffer.
He was able to take, again, very tiny font, I apologize for that, but for each of the metrics that are part of their LCAP, he took the baseline data and then they set growth targets for each of the different student groups, so each different colored column is related to a different student group.
And there are tabs across the bottom representative of all the sites in the district.
And again, it was about the conversation of how does this translate at the site level.
If this is only about the LCAP and at the district level, then we're not really touching the students.
So it really is about getting this down to the site level and having conversations about that.
And the one thing I'll add to this is that he mentioned that this is supplemented by a publication that's included within their local newspaper, the Desert Sun, which also explains all of the different indicators.
And they do annual, biannual inserts in local newspapers to explain to the public.
about the indicators in the dashboard.
So again, it really is an honor to work with the gifted educators in Riverside County that are able to come up with a variety of different methods in order to get this information down to the classroom level and really impact the students.
So I'm going to turn it over to my colleague, Steve Ion, and he's going to share a little bit about a tool that we're utilizing in order to visualize dashboard data as well.
Thank you, Melissa.
My name is Steve Ayon.
I am the Data and Analytics Administrator at Riverside County Office of Education.
One of the things that we are doing at Riverside County is I'm taking a lot of the data files that CDE provides and we're developing additional reports and visualizations to make that data usable in a variety of different ways.
Here we have an example of what I've done with the files taken from the California School Dashboard.
and we've put it together to produce some different visualizations.
This is our version of it, and in this page that we see here in the screen, we see that we have graduation rates for Riverside County.
as we can see that each bar corresponds to each LEA, and from here we can see that it does five things.
We see that each bar represents the performance level color, same as the California School Dashboard.
We also see an arrow indicating the direction of change.
To the right is increasing, to the left is decreasing.
Also, the length of the bar indicates the magnitude of that change, and of course we see the current status and the previous status.
The current status is the one where the arrowhead is pointing towards.
The visualization allows us to make comparisons between LEAs, sites, and student groups.
Users can select the combination of
county indicator or student groups on the right hand side so they can look at the different indicators, student groups, and this has the entire state data files loaded into there so anybody in the state can view this data including charters.
In this slide we see the district by priority tab and this tab we can see it's a view that allows us to see all the different indicators by priority as well as the student groups across the top.
What this allows us to do is to select the different click on the different arrows and by clicking on them
we get to see a little bit more information about each one.
We get to see how many, all the information about the student group, indicator name, performance level, status and change, and end size.
And as we click on it, we also get to see a little bit more information about how each district is performing and how each school is contributing to the whole of the district.
So, this allows us to get a quick view of an entire district and get to see school level detail as well.
We also have some additional reports that give us different views of the data.
The district schools report displays schools within a district grouped by grade span.
The district student groups shown here displays all student groups within a district.
And the school student groups report displays all student groups within a site or a charter.
And this allows us to do comparisons within the different student groups so that we can get a different view of the dashboard data.
So in addition, we also have a protocol that Dr. Lozano's put together so that we can analyze this data and follow along with the different screens so that districts can help identify which student groups, which sites need more assistance based on the data that is displayed on the dashboard.
And in the spirit of continuous improvement, we will be adding chronic absenteeism data, the CCI college and career indicator data, as well as adding a little bit more English learner performance indicator information in the future.
So with that, I'd like to hand it over to Joanne Lauer.
Thank you.
Hi, Joanne Lauer, Director for Research and Implementation for Riverside County Office of Education.
And I'd like to speak to the fact that although we love the dashboard, another key message is how the dashboard connects the statewide system of support.
And we want to wrap up briefly by sharing how we are utilizing the dashboard in our local context and supporting our districts and converting data into action.
So we've all seen the connecting the system of support multiple times in our conversations around this.
What we wanted to ensure is that we continue to provide extraordinary service and support to our districts in our level one
In addition to understanding that we have differentiated assistance for our eligible school districts based on the LCAP Fall 2017 dashboard.
So we started this by an educational services creating a matrix of our level one supports that you can see here.
Across the top, this is by unit, and within this context, it not only connects to the job-alikes, networks, and collaboratives that Dr. Bozzano just spoke of, but it also includes additional information as to the level of services and support that are available to all districts and schools across our county.
In addition to this, our student program and services division also drafted a version specific to students with disabilities.
So across the top, they have, in addition to the support shown and all the headers across the top, they're also refining their supports by working with their staff
in organizing and supporting specific services around student with disabilities, disability codes.
So they're further developing support, whether it is for students who are autistic, orthopedically handicapped, deaf, hard of hearing, et cetera.
So across the gamut.
But what's very important as we continue this level of support is that we as educators understand the connections between the dashboard and the LCAP annual update.
And so this is where we start to bring these systems together.
So through our networks and especially our LCAP development workshops, we continue to communicate about how these pieces fit and work together.
Not only are we connecting these elements statewide system, we are also connecting them internally as well.
So in our LCAP workshops, we are developing in partnership with our fiscal services team, the presentations that we make with our districts, as well as we co-present in order to really demonstrate the elimination of siloed decision making.
Now for level two support, we've also been working internally on a variety of analyses for our districts that are eligible for differentiated assistance.
For example, as you can see here, we have dashboard and metrics analyses that we've done.
One example of that is we disaggregated our data by student with disability or for students with disabilities by disability group.
And so our districts are then able to use that to really get down and dig into that data around what are the root causes for this data and how can we support that to convert our data into action.
In addition to that, we conducted an analysis of all of the LCAPs in our districts.
And within that LCAP review, you can see here that we were able to visually understand if the dashboard data was connected to the actions and services within the LCAP.
And then this helps our districts to be able to identify where some areas of opportunity may be for them to have a collaborative conversation with their district and respond.
It's also targeted specific student groups, and so they can be very specific in that response.
We also have worked in collaboration with our special education leaders in our county around the PIR status and reviewed the PIR status.
This is extremely important as we know that our districts are going through the PIR process and although the data years are one year different, there is a great deal of overlap into the areas that are identified in our district.
So how can we collaboratively work together and support that?
We also did a participation review of where are our districts also participating in other areas and networks.
So for instance, we have three districts that are participating in the SUMS grant for MTSS.
We have six districts that are in a PLN hosted by RCOE, facilitated by WestEd in educational resource strategies, and four of these are eligible for differentiated assistance.
Three other districts are also participating in other California Collaborative PLNs.
Two districts are in a network facilitated by CORE, and five districts are part of the Riverside County Educational Collaborative, and two of those are eligible for differentiated assistance.
So we have a lot of opportunity, as Dr. Bozanos was describing, to be able to connect to our districts.
And finally, we memorialized our prior services that we have provided to our districts by various educational services units so that we could have a historical context of the type of support that's been provided.
So you may be wondering, well, how are we wrapping all of this up and what is the platform to be able to have these types of conversations and organize ourselves around that?
So as Dr. Bozano mentioned, we wanna also continue our appreciation for CCE and the development of the facilitation guide that enabled us as a county office to have common tools that we could use in our conversations for differentiated assistance in our districts.
Also through CCESA and CISC, the work around improvement science.
And so we have been engaging in the improvement science trainings.
In addition to engaging as a team from Riverside County Educational Services Division, we've also brought the training back to our entire division so that our team is engaged in that process.
So all levels of work understand how to apply the concepts of improvement science.
We also used improvement science to structure our division around this, so it took some adjustment or refinement of our structures to be able to be aligned to this work.
Additionally, we continue to connect the LCAP to the dashboard in every opportunity through networks, trainings, PD opportunities, workshops, et cetera.
And then finally, internally, not only in educational
services division and the reorganization or not reorganization but the restructuring of our supports also being very intentional in collaboration and coordination with other divisions such as student program services for special education as well as fiscal services so that we can continue to work interdependently towards the goal of connecting the dashboard to actions and services.
Thank you.
We're going to go to our next guest speaker, and then we would bring them all back for questions, if you have questions.
We have Dr. Chun-Wu Lee, who's also a member of RAN, and Naomi Purcell, who is an administrator, too, in our unit and was the lead on the LCAP analysis.
Thank you, Joanne.
That was excellent.
Thank you.
It's happening.
Okay, we're going to skip or move forward rather to a smaller school district, Weaver Union Elementary out of Merced County.
And I had the opportunity to speak to, Merced brings together their school board members on an annual basis.
And in doing that presentation last fall, I had the opportunity to meet Superintendent Curry and was very impressed by his enthusiasm over the local indicators and I wanted to share
have him share with you his story of his district and how they're getting the word out about the local indicators.
So I will turn that over to him, and I wanted to make sure before I leave the podium that you can see this screen.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Thanks for having me.
So I'm very excited to share this with you.
First of all, I'll let you know I'm John Kerr.
I'm the superintendent at Weaver Union School District.
We are a small school district in the southern tip of Merced, 2,800 kids, three schools.
I'm also a member of the California League of Schools.
Many of you are familiar with that, with our Schools to Watch taking center stage.
And so proud to be a representative of the elementary branch of that.
I'm the president of California League of Elementary Schools.
Excited about that.
So I'm here today to talk a little bit about the accountability system and local measures.
So as you can see by my website, I've got, we've developed a nice link to something that you may be familiar with.
I'm sure you've seen this before.
And I'm going to direct our attention to the local indicators.
And what I want to say to you is we have determined that this is a perfect opportunity for us to further define the word MET.
We believe that this is how you capture your stakeholders and those folks who are interested in taking a look at your schools and wanting to know a little bit more about local climate and what does MET really mean.
So we've decided that we're going to work on that.
together with the work of education research consultants out of Fresno.
I had an idea, you know how you have an idea and it becomes a concept and then it comes to life.
So I'm very excited about this.
So if you look at what we've done here in the narrative piece, which I appreciate the narrative piece so much, our district has created a local dashboard that you can see.
So then what we have done is we have created this local dashboard.
And that kind of looks familiar to you, doesn't it?
We've seen the wedgies before.
I call them wedgies.
I know Trivial Pursuit has a patent on that, but we all call them wedgies, don't we?
They're wedgies.
So as you can see, we go to our detailed view of this, which I'll explain a little bit later.
And now I have graphic indicators for someone who
isn't necessarily interested in all the academic pieces, but maybe is interested in those local measures.
sharing a little bit about what we measure locally.
And as you can see, we have created a little indications on the top there.
We have three schools, 28, 15.
There's our SCD percentage.
There's our English learner percentage.
And then we go to, this mouse is fast.
Priority one, we use the fitness inspection toolkit and we are status and change.
I love that status and change.
In fact, I really appreciate the new dashboard and what it's doing for many of our districts.
Many of our districts that were never close to 800 just really didn't have hope.
And with status and change now, you have given hope to many districts.
So I wanna thank you for that.
I really applaud that work.
It's very encouraging for many.
So as you can see, status and change over a few years, we can actually show our community, our stakeholders, where we were and where we are.
And this is a little bit more of a definition than MET, as you can see.
So in priority one, we've got the facility inspection toolkit, we've got appropriately assigned teachers, and we have equal access to core curriculum graphically displayed.
Priority two, we utilized option two that the CDE provided for us, the metrics.
And we have now given ourselves the grades on how we are doing in regards to implementation of academic standards.
And there you can see.
Next year, we'll have two years of data on that so that you can see status and change.
Parent engagement piece, rather than show the entire California Healthy Kids survey on a slideshow that people can dig into, what we decided to do was, what do we think that parents and community members are gonna be the most interested in regards to the parent survey?
So we selected these two, parent satisfaction with school communication and their satisfaction with academic program.
We take the survey and every year now we're providing the information.
Local Climate Survey, this is where the Healthy Kids Survey comes in for us every two years.
And we actually pulled the two that we felt were the most important in regards to what our neighbors and our stakeholders would want to know.
Do our students feel safe on the campus?
Do our students feel connected?
And we have two years of data to indicate that.
And as you can see, we've got a little bit of a skip because we do the California Healthy Kids Survey every two years.
So we've got 2014 data and then 2016 data.
We have also thrown a couple of extra ones up there because we're proud of the fact that our ADA rate has gone up and we're proud of the fact that we've only had two students drop out last year and three students the year before.
Now I'll tell you that this is a document, this is a website actually that we are expanding this because
Again, the local measures are to be reported as a district only, but what we have done is we have decided to allow folks to take a look at their school.
I want to know how my kids at Farmdale Elementary are doing.
And so we've desegregated that data.
I had to say desegregated so I could get points.
So we've desegregated our data.
And as you can see, you only have the fifth grade scores.
You don't have the seventh grade scores.
Somebody will be proud of me at home because I said that.
And if you want to take a look at the middle school, you'll see that there is no fifth grade data for the middle school.
And again, these are specific to those school sites.
And you will see that there are a few measures that are district wide, but many of these measures we have desegregated by school site.
One of the other tools that we're going to be utilizing in the future
is we're going to be utilizing what we call a school comparison tool where you can go on and you can see if your elementary school did better than the elementary school down the street because we know those rivalries.
And those rivalries can create some initiative for schools to kind of pay attention and do some things.
We can't be down the street.
Pioneer Elementary versus Farmdale Elementary in our district, they're gonna wanna see if they could beat each other in ADA for sure.
And so this can spur them on to do that.
We're excited about this because it's another way to engage stakeholders.
And I'm talking about stakeholders, including your realtors that want to brag about location, location, location.
And we want you to move to these schools because take a look at this school in this district.
It can expand to that level.
We believe that this is wonderful for board members as well, that we ask board members to study numerous documents.
This is at a glance showing the priorities in a district in a local measure that will allow them to understand more than the word met.
We're excited to share this with you.
And again, I appreciate the partnership that we have with the California League of Schools and ERC.
And happy to share this with any other district if they would be interested in taking a look at it and interested in your thoughts and feedback on this as well.
So thank you for allowing me to do this.
Great.
So I just have two slides to close out the presentation and we can turn it back to President Kruse for questions.
Excuse me.
Just to give you a preview of what to expect over the next 60 days or so.
We will be providing you two information memoranda in February.
The first one is talking about the ongoing development of the college career indicator.
That is something that I know
member Rucker and member Ortiz-Larcon had concerns about at another meeting that took place last month so we will talk a bit about that in a memo, and we also will start to explore yet again we can pick back up the student growth model options and we will actually be hosting with our partners from ETS a public session on the growth models at the end of February so I'm pleased to announce that today.
We will let folks know of the meeting date and location
in a stakeholder session soon.
And then for the March meeting, this is of course our annual work plan.
So we will be coming to you, giving you an update on all the things that we will be working on over the next six months as we prepare for your action on items for input in the dashboard for fall of 2018.
So those are the pieces, especially in March.
We know that you need to take action on the chronic absenteeism indicator.
That's something we've talked about now for two meetings.
And then we will also provide you in that work plan an update on the development, of course, of our Dashpoint alternative school status and the modified methods that will apply to alternative schools.
So I wanted to close out with just a quote from actually my home county, from Ventura County Office of Education.
And Antonio Castro's been, just like Riverside County, very engaged in the process, asking a lot of questions.
And so I thought it was nice to hear not only from an LA that wasn't able to be here through this quote that was in the local paper in Ventura.
So with that, President Christ, I'll turn it back to you.
Thank you for the informative presentations.
Board member questions.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you and I want to thank the presenters.
I was very impressed by both presentations and really hope that this becomes a standard for practice for LEAs and county offices.
I want to start with the Riverside County Office of Riverside County Office of Education, their presentation and I really love the way that they describe their model which is really braiding
the LCAP template, the annual update, the data dashboard, and the data that they are now previewed to, as well as support.
So, I
was under the impression that the LCAP update, the annual update, would be updated based on the new data that was released.
And it seems like there may be folks who don't think that that's not necessarily the case, that you don't update your data.
And I'm seeing it in this presentation and I love that it's clearly stated here that the purpose of having new data is to then go back to your LCAP and say, is this data, are goals still relevant, right?
Specifically, if we look at the data that we released and when we changed the methodology, new groups were identified.
So ELs are now identified more in red and orange because they moved a little bit down from the yellow.
So are we expecting districts and county offices to go back to the LCAP annual update and update it according to that data?
And I know it sounds so simple, but apparently that is something that is not clear.
Good morning, Jeff Breshears, Director of the Local Agency Systems Support Office.
And certainly the dashboard is supposed to help inform the annual update.
There are specific prompts in the template, in the LCAP template, that ask that the LEAs to go back and look at data within their dashboard and then respond to that.
And certainly that is part of the needs assessment that would go on to the development or the
any modification of goals, actions, and services.
There are prompts within the plan summary that also refer back to the dashboard and say, based on the data that you have in the dashboard, what are you going to do with this and moving forward?
So absolutely, the LCAP is intended to be informed by data from the dashboard.
So they are updating it according to the most recent data that they receive.
Yes.
Okay.
Then the second question and I was asking board member Burr, does the annual update also get approved by the county office or is that just by the LEA board?
It's also approved by the county office.
It is part of on the annual basis and statute says the LCAP and the annual update
is developed at the local level, adopted at the local governing board, and then submitted to the county office, school districts, to the county offices for review and approval, yes.
So the annual update also is now subject to review and they will be looking to make sure that there is new updated data in that annual update.
That is correct, yeah.
Perfect, thank you.
The second compliment is to the LEA that presented.
Thank you.
I absolutely love that there is a narrative that justifies and substantiates your MET.
When I was looking, I started randomly, you know, I have two kids and I, of course, the first thing I did is I looked up their school.
And I looked at the school that they previously attended last year, just to make some comparisons to make sure that I made the right decision in moving them.
So one of the things that I started randomly putting in districts to see how they had rated themselves under the local indicators, and to date I have not found one that says not met.
And I have to say that I was like, really?
Because we get a lot of your parents coming to our board meetings who are complaining about parent engagement, who have concerns about school climate.
And so I was having a really hard time with the indicator and the way that we were, is absolute, not met or met.
And nothing was substantiating that until this presentation.
And I really hope that that becomes a trend, because I don't know how many districts right now have said, no, we do not meet that criteria.
And there's nothing to substantiate their met affirmation.
But I'm sure that we will have parents and other stakeholders that will ask us to look deeper into what's happening at their particular districts.
So I want to congratulate you for taking the dashboard and understanding that we need to expand a little bit and get more information and then really taking that optional step to put in a narrative.
Thank you.
I just have to add that we did feature Weaver Union and Superintendent Curry on one of our dashboard series, actually the first one in the dashboard series.
And then in that six-part series, the last session was focused all on how to use the dashboard in the new LCAP.
So Jeff and his team had an excellent presentation and it is posted to our website on the accountability webpages.
for other districts to know about.
Superintendent Curry got a lot of questions while we were on that webinar asking how he created it.
He's been already sharing best practices across the state because of that series.
I want to add my comments and echo what board member Ortiz-Lacon just said.
As you know, this has been my greatest concern and the greatest criticisms that I've often had when districts come to make a presentation.
to the board about what they're doing and what county offices are doing to support their work of implementing not only the LCFF but understanding how to use the dashboard.
What gives me great hope about today's presentation is I continue to ask what are we learning and how is the conversation evolving?
So first, let me commend the staff at Riverside County.
I walked up to them before the meeting started today to tell them I was really looking forward to hearing what they had to say, and I was really anticipating what they were going to present, not just because it's Riverside County, but I have family, cousins who have kids in those schools in Riverside County,
And they talk to me every single week and they send me their school documents and tell me, tell me what does this say?
So it's really heartening to hear the conversation from Riverside County for a couple of reasons.
What I appreciated most about what you did today was you really did set the table on the conversation about what it means to drill down and push out the type of county-level analysis about the dashboard and about the LCAPs that districts should be engaging in, and you have created not only the model, but clear guidance on the process on how to do that.
I also appreciate the way that you've given expectations to districts about what the drill down from the district in operating and implementing the LCAP down to the sites and even into the classrooms.
So I truly do appreciate that.
I also appreciate you did not use a lot of mega terms, and if I sit up here and play bureaucrat bingo, I did not hear you check off all those words that everybody uses in having conversations about implementing the LCAP.
You actually talked about true, organic, and real conversations that you're actually having with districts and the ways that you're actually getting your hands dirty to do this work.
I just realized I mixed the metaphor.
Nobody wants to set a table with dirty hands, but you understand where I'm going, so just keep up with me on this.
But the other part about setting this table is you identified real tools and real ways to use those tools with a clear expectation that in giving them these tools, you expect them to use them in both inappropriate and innovative ways.
And this is coming from a woman who uses her heels to aerate her lawn.
So I understand and uses a knife to hammer a nail into the wall to hang a picture.
I understand all of that.
The final piece on setting the table, you also gave some projections about what the next steps ought to be in a way that it informs how districts who should now be in this LCAP review and monitoring cycle
looking at how the new data they received in the fall 2017 dashboard should inform the conversations they are having with stakeholders to update and make changes in the LCAP, not only for this year, but in the process of developing the LCAP that they will be reviewing and revising for submission to you this summer.
What I truly appreciated in what you said and what you presented
is that the LCAP process and the LCAP cycle doesn't just become a checklist of activities that have to be done on a time frame.
it actually becomes real actionable work that is observable and that's quantifiable.
And I really wanna thank the superintendent from Weaver.
In a previous life, I was a consultant for the region two areas of the California Teachers Association.
I spent a lot of time driving up and down 99 and working with teachers in those districts.
As we implemented the local indicators, my question was yours.
What does MET mean?
I personally was never really clear that there was clear guidance and a clear understanding on what districts should do because as my colleague previously said,
Most districts, when you look up this dashboard, they're all giving themselves A's.
When you get to self-evaluate yourself, nobody wants to advertise the bad news.
You want to focus on what you're doing well.
But what I really appreciate is that you all also are doing a deeper dive on those local indicators
and you're working toward consensus among your stakeholders.
So you've also created and crafted a real model for how stakeholders can actually look at the data that you're considering and the evidence that's being developed in your local indicators so that when you say we've met it,
There's clear and compelling evidence that all can agree upon in a review of that data.
So this was really helpful, not only to see something from Southern California, from a very large and very successful county office, but from Northern California to see a small LEA where this work is being done.
So the question I have is, first of all, how is this replicated, or how do we know that these are not just, you know,
hit and miss opportunities of successes that are happening?
How do we know that this is going on as well in other places?
How are county offices holding themselves accountable for doing this same kind of good work?
How are county offices, as we go forward now that we're in this phase two of implementing this accountability system, how are county offices holding districts truly accountable in doing the LCAP reviews
to make sure that what they are submitting in their updates and the work that they are doing, particularly Jeff, for schools that have already been identified for intervention and support, how are county offices giving real guidance to those districts to make sure that they really are using this new data, using data that's been added to the dashboard that wasn't there when they created their their three-year plan,
to make sure that going forward the data doesn't just sit there and collect dust, and they understand that there are consequences for not paying attention to that data.
So these are questions we can live with, but this is a conversation that, as it continues to evolve, it seems like the answers are going in the correct direction and the pathway
by the models that were presented today are actually very hopeful and very, very wonderful.
So thank you very much.
And Ms.
Sheppy, today, in the past I said, well, I was kind of disappointed because this is what I expected to hear.
Thank you so much for, I know you worked very hard with the presenters today to put this together.
So I really want to make sure I give kudos to you as well.
A board member Burr is next.
Thank you.
So I just will echo what my colleagues have said about how wonderful it is to hear this information.
And I'll just say from my perspective, this is what local control looks like.
And it's so fantastic to see how you've embraced it, how you have made it work in your local communities.
I was really struck, and I'm sorry I didn't get everybody's name, but by the comment about
What this ultimately is is leading to the impact it has on students who are sitting in desks in individual classrooms and seeing how at the system level this gets put together is very revealing to us and very gratifying I will say for somebody who has worked on this for a few years.
So, very, very appreciative.
I also just want to say thank you to Cindy and Melanie and anybody else at the department who put this together.
I do think, and Cindy was very modest, I think, in they're gathering this, they're doing all this outreach to
in lots of different ways.
She gave some examples.
And they're learning about this organically, and they're bringing it to us, which I am very, very appreciative of.
And I think it informs all of us and helps kind of see how this system is actually blossoming.
I'm gonna come back to county offices in just one second, because I want to make sure there wasn't a message lost there.
But just to conclude in my opening remarks,
I want us to remember this and kind of embed it in our head as we talk about the ESSA plan, because it has very significant impact, I think, and relevance to what we do or don't do with the federal government.
So just sort of park that in your mind.
But with respect to county offices, because we get this question a lot, I'm going to put on my CCEE hat now.
And we've had the opportunity to talk to county offices over time, work very collaboratively with them, with the work of CCEE.
And I think I heard, so I'm going to ask the Riverside County folks this question, and I think we're going to hear from the CCESA folks probably later in the system of support item.
But I just want to clarify that you gave us an example, the facilitation guide, that much of the work that you're doing has been guided at the state level by CSESA and by your colleagues, your curriculum and instruction colleagues, your business administration colleagues, and your student services colleagues.
in an effort to calibrate across all county offices how they interact with school districts.
So if you could just reinforce that or answer me, maybe I'm wrong, but at least that's my understanding of it.
And I think there is a great lack of information or understanding of that among LEAs, in the public conversation, because I hear the question all the time, what are county offices doing?
and how do we make sure that they're all operating off the same playbook?
And Member Burr, you are extremely accurate in that a large majority of our work in the foundation of the support we're providing has been in collaboration with CCESA through CISC, the Curriculum Instruction Steering Committee.
There's been a lot of work done in planning common presentations over the last couple of years that we have used
to ensure that there's consistency, not only throughout our county and throughout our region, but also throughout the state.
So we've been able to take tools that have been collaboratively developed at those levels and then make them applicable for our local levels.
So the work led by CCESA through CISC, through some of the other steering committees, as well as our collaboration and conversation with CCEE, because we have engaged in conversations with them as well,
as there's providing support to a district in our county.
So it has indeed been a collaboration and that has served as a foundation for us applying it at the local level.
Well I want to echo my colleagues that have gone before me and just support the and thank the CDE team and the Riverside County and Weaver's presentations because we do know that this is a different system than before and I really believe that people are doing the best with best intents but the idea of analyzing multiple data is different than what many of us did with just math and math and literacy scores and
Models that you're following and sharing with people, I think are very, very helpful as people get into multiple measures.
And I heard Riverside County say a couple of things.
Let me just say, I've been to their college and career network.
The energy in those room is amazing.
And the trust and the collaboration that.
that network has.
And what I've heard from educators and leaders around the state is these networks and collaborative are wonderful ways to get support to support the local efforts.
So I've just felt the energy and I think the Riverside team is a wonderful model.
But I also heard them say, and again to build on my colleague's comments,
they're focusing on the data and the multiple measures, and they're focusing on the school and the local classroom data.
And I think that's important for the particular subgroups.
And both presentations I thought highlighted what else technology has done beyond what the state provides.
And so I just asked to assess the shares, their models, and I'm assuming at the sixth meeting next week that's likely to happen.
Also, there's a state superintendent's meeting, so I don't know if we were planning to share,
I'm assuming that people want to know what's happening in local districts that they can share and just to see what technology can do to provide the opportunities to drill deeper.
And then I also heard Riverside talk about a use of protocol to follow that they're sharing protocols to give districts and sites because I think I really believe people do want to do the best but they don't necessarily know how to do it differently.
It's new and we've asked from the board level to
what are the models we're sharing with people, but we're a really big state, 58 counties, so the model of doing some exemplars and networks and protocols and then sharing, I think, is so important to help everyone get better at that.
So, again, the focus on student group performance, I think, is really to our hearts of
we don't wanna lose groups in high performing or schools where we want to make sure we're focusing on the needs.
And I appreciated the breakout also on special ed, because we know special ed has been quite forefronts for many districts.
They hadn't paid maybe as close attention or they thought they were dealing with it through IEPs and specialized support.
And yet, I think we are in a transition to say, no, this is a responsibility of everybody, not just a special ed.
special educators, all core teachers have responsibility for English learners or special needs.
So the fact that the data is providing that I think is a really good model and I would just ask that as we continue to see these wonderful exemplars both county-wise and school district-wise that we do share it not just in webinars but here publicly so that we can over the next few years really strengthen the skill set and the knowledge and the strategies.
Also, I appreciated the connection to the system of support because people I think now are saying so like what does this mean what kind of support and so to the Riverside team who put that particular day together and showed how all the components.
I think you really provide.
leadership.
I believe in success and across our state, but as well to provide districts in a variety as I know you have a few large, but you have lots of small districts too.
And I think as I've talked with county supes and superintendents within counties, they have to differentiate as well.
So they don't have big teams in some cases in small districts.
So
Again, that willingness to share and model for us, I think is what we're all about.
I just have to say, this is what we were hoping for.
I know we're early in the process and I look forward to the March presentations.
I would just ask CDE as you continue to outreach, that you continue to share the bigger picture at the state level with the combination of what is happening county and local wise so that we can share that and also understand for ourselves the impact as we hope to impact the local practice.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
So I have to echo what all my fellow colleagues, board members have said already.
Again, as Board Member Burr said, this is what local control looks like.
And the level of ownership and the robust data sets that you've produced at that level to meet your needs, it's amazing.
And it's great to see the framework that the state has set to support and develop that.
And so, and especially as a practitioner myself and doing a lot of work at my school level,
I thought we were all that with what we were doing, and then I'm looking at the work that you've done, and I thought, oh, we could do that.
That's awesome.
So thank you very much.
It's very inspiring.
You know, it's a very inspiring presentation, and yet, and this might also kind of foreshadow a little bit of our discussion for item five, is that, you know, what I still hear is a lack of trust that
Gosh, could the school district really do it?
Will they put their blinders on and not really recognize?
Can we trust that they're going to move in this self-improvement process?
And so we do know we need to provide a lot of support.
So I guess, I think maybe the counties, because of your perspective on all the different districts and schools that you're working with, I'd like to ask a couple things.
One is,
Have you had experience with a district or a school that's just not willing to look at its information?
And what's been your experience with that as far as the information coming, that's come out?
Yeah, I guess it would be Riverside.
Yeah.
Have you noticed the hesitancy?
I will say I don't know that we've had a district that has verbally said we're unwilling to look at our data.
There are systems that we have in place with our collaboratives and networks that really there's no way not to look at your data because that embeds everything that we do.
I will say though, as with any county, there are differing levels of capacity and ability to be able to look at that data and analyze it appropriately.
So, as one of the board members said, we do need to differentiate because there are different levels of expertise, different levels of knowledge, and sometimes even a different level of willingness to understand exactly what the data is saying.
And so, as a county office, we're there to differentiate to support in that area.
Very good.
I appreciate that.
And then I guess the other piece, too, is that there's the concern that identification of schools, that the support would be very narrow, that if, say, for instance, we identify a school is identified based on one subgroup or student group, that the technical assistance would just go in and focus just on that specific student group.
And nothing that I've heard or seen from the support that we've said that it would just be that narrow because I think we know that the indicators and they overlap in many, many ways.
So while a school could be identified by a certain subgroup, that when there is a support, we're taking a holistic approach and look at it.
And I think that's been the philosophy and I think that's been what our intent has been.
in the support system that we have.
Okay, thank you.
Board member Valdez is next.
So I have the unique opportunity because I'm part of Riverside County, I say I'm part of the county, but part of really working well with this wonderful, talented, dynamic group who have been at the forefront and I think and they really work collaboratively with districts and so I'm one of the districts that's been able to partake in all of this.
And so I really commend you and it was really nice to hear your story today and it was fun to watch you present.
I think one of the things is today's national Winnie the Pooh Day.
I don't know if you know that.
So here's a quote from Winnie the Pooh and it says, you're braver than you believe, you're stronger than you seem, and you're smarter than you think.
And I think that's what Riverside County Office is doing.
They're making, helping districts feel that way and with all of the tools and the resources and the ongoing communication and the just-in-time meetings, the networks, the PLNs, all of those things that you are growing and fostering
I think your sense of wonder as a county office has really helped push you forward in front of all of the CCESA and the CISC opportunities that you've had.
So I want to congratulate you on that.
And I'm really proud to be part of Riverside County.
And with that empowerment, I was with an assistant superintendent yesterday who had been in one of your meetings, your first meetings of differentiated assistance.
And I have to tell you, he was just so thankful.
And it wasn't like, oh, I went to this meeting and I got in trouble.
It was like, I really see where we can go.
And so I think that's what we're trying to do is in the spirit of moving forward, how do we move forward together?
And I think the approach is not that you have all the answers, but together we're going to figure it out.
Here's some tools to really dig down deep.
And that ultimately, your vision is that it gets down to teaching and learning.
And I really think that that's a true
hallmark of a good county office.
One of the questions I have is on the guidance document that CCESA put together.
I know in one of the letters that I read, and I think it's a good recommendation, something like that at the district level, because the facilitation skills, again, countywide, it's important to have that calibrated and an opportunity for different county offices to have that kind of a resource.
And I really think that down at the
at the LEA level, and then it would certainly impact at the school level facilitation guides.
I think that's one thing that I think everyone can get better at, and especially as we're really wanting to be inclusive of all stakeholders, so that's another piece.
And then finally, I really think that John Curry, you really modeled the way your data, and I really applaud you for really taking on that from the legal definition, if you will, of what MET means to actually breathing life into it and really being the transparency of showing that from year to year and asking the same kinds of questions because you're really looking at some trend data.
So thank you for that.
But anyway, thank you.
I wanna get back to the question of the dashboard and the design, and I'm glad to hear that there may be some funding to do that.
I think that it's great for us to take some of the lessons learned and some of the practices and really think of how we could use that to enhance the dashboard.
Because not every district has the capacity, the resources, and I think it was mentioned, the will to really take this information and really delve into the data.
So I want to see how we could use some of these lessons and really upgrade so that it's not a bright spot in the state that has access to this great information and practices, but that it becomes, again, the standard of the state of California.
In looking at the equity report, I think that this is a place where I really would like us to go out to different stakeholders and think how can we better enhance
this landing page because right now when I look at it, I like that we included the 5x5 into the dashboard.
I wasn't able to access the Google Translator when I was looking at it.
I'm not sure if there was a glitch that day.
But when I look at the way that we lay out the equity report, and I've said it before, it's not intuitive.
You kind of have to read everything to figure out what is this landing page.
And again, as I mentioned, my focus group was my husband.
He was like, what is this?
And I was like, ah.
So even things like changing the columns, all student performance, student groups in red and orange, and then total student groups.
That's one basic small change, but that it really starts narrowing the eye to what we're hoping to accomplish.
The other thing is the level of support.
I think that if a school is comprehensive or targeted, that should be
very clearly stated in the equity report.
I think that is accountability, that is transparency.
I think that there's better ways for us to really hone in on what equity means when we're looking at this landing page.
And I think that, again, we've made some great changes and enhancements, but we really should be listening to what others have done.
And it shouldn't be just a bright spot.
It should be something that all of our students have access to, regardless of the county office, regardless of the LEA, and regardless of the people who may have a will to really look at your needs and understand the root cause.
Because root cause is an interesting thing.
People could look at data and say, well, of course, they're getting suspended at a disproportionate rate.
They're oppositional.
Of course, this student is, that is not a root cause, that is an assumption, but that is a lens that some folks could look at this data with.
And so we need to make sure that not only do we have common practices and common systems, but a common mindset where we're looking at data and really owning what we've contributed to those outcomes.
Thank you.
OK, that concludes, I think, the comments on this.
We're now ready for public comment on this item.
With the following people, please line up.
Sheila Whitley, Doug McCray, Eric Adams, Liz Guillen, and Brian Rivas.
You have one minute to speak.
I'm Sheila Whitley and I'm here speaking on behalf of CTA.
Our area of concern with this accountability system is really in the area of how we measure growth and the status for our subgroups for our English language learners.
This is an area that a lot of schools and districts have been working with and we're not sure that we really have adequately indicated a correct measurement for measuring their growth.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, retired testing specialist from Monterey.
At your board meeting two months ago, I commented on the data integrity issues of the academic indicators on the dashboard.
particularly the 2017 Smarter Balanced Gain Scores.
I followed this with further written material on the problem on November 22.
No action or information on this problem has been forthcoming from either the CDE or Smarter Balanced until this morning.
I submitted a handout for this item to your electronic folder last week consisting of
Strongly worded op-ed published January 4th, as well as a one-page support letter from the Commissioner of New Hampshire calling for an opening of the wall with secrecy for technical information on this Dean's Corps problem.
to get to the bottom of the problem as soon as possible.
I think this gain score problem could be correctable within a few weeks if it indeed involves, in effect, scoring keys for the 2017 administration.
I'd urge the State Board to follow New Hampshire's lead on this issue.
I'll have more on this issue for Item No.
6 today.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We, too, are really excited about some of the bright spots in the way the dashboard is being rolled out and implemented and the information is being used to take actions for improvement.
I do want to however call out that the some of the items that member Ortiz-Licn mentioned are things that our community partners are also struggling with.
To have the dashboard and even to show that there are a certain number of student groups that are showing red and
and orange is good, but the impact of that and what that means needs to be more transparent.
So in the same way the state is having to communicate this new system and what its meaning is and isn't,
to districts and counties.
It needs to do that with parents in the public.
So we would agree that the dashboard could be more transparent that way and especially around the level of support.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Eric Adams and I'm a site organizer for youth together in California.
And I just wanted to say voice my appreciation for the addition of the chronic absence indicator to the dashboard I think coming from a place like Oakland, knowing that chronic absence does overlap with so many different issues graduation, even just
performance.
I'm really happy to see that there, but I will say that I would like to see more clarity and transparency, like has been said before by a few other folks with this, especially making it more accessible to families and stakeholders.
Throughout the year, this year, through our listening campaign and other organizing work, we've been able to get a keen eye and capture from some of the families that we work with and students
that the dashboard is difficult to understand and that it's actually kind of hard to navigate.
Also that they would like more pictures to be associated with some of the data, especially in the local context.
I also really appreciated one of the comments made about trust by Ms.
Sun.
And I think that honestly there are, sorry.
There is a lot of distrust from families and communities that needs to be allayed before something like the dashboard can be really successful.
Also, looking at the ways in which LCAP has been created to be something that is collaborative, we need much more collaboration.
I want to piggyback on a statement made earlier.
The dashboard definitely has to exist at the classroom level.
Time.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Ephraim Mercado, I'm Children Now.
I would like to appreciate the idea that what we just saw is a great example of local control and really shows our system is moving forward and that's fantastic.
We also feel that the funding in the January governor's budget will allow more county offices to increase their capacity to do what Riverside County is doing.
We'd also like to double down on the idea and the expectation from State Board and CDE that the dashboard will be impacting the LCAPs of districts as they move into this new cycle, especially those that were identified for differentiated systems.
Thank you.
Terry Barnes, California School Boards Association and board member of the Natomas Unified School District and I want to tell you that it is being used.
Last night I sat through two hours of presentations from each of our elementary schools where they showed us their dashboards, where they were, where they talked about what they're doing to help bring up those areas where we have weaknesses and celebrated what they're doing well.
It really is able to go out into the community, talk about our strengths and weaknesses, see it very visually, and encourage public participation in that process.
So I want to thank you.
We're working.
We're early at this.
We know we're early at this, but it is doing what you want it to do.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Revis speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
I want to compliment you and your staff for the presentation this morning.
Ed Trust West loves to see that kind of engagement with the data.
We want to see more of it, and I think you asked the right questions about whether or not this is the standard.
If not, that's the standard we want to strive for, and it raises questions about district capacity and will to do that kind of data analysis.
We have a recommendation for you that I think would help to integrate the dashboard with the system of support and make it a little easier to understand, and that is add to the dashboard when an LEA is identified for assistance, note that so that people have an idea of what's going on overall and how it relates to the system of supports.
Thank you.
All right, that concludes the public comment and the board will recess now till 1020.
Board member Holliday.
Sorry.
I could just make one quick comment.
It's not just about local control.
It's about ownership.
And what we're seeing here are individuals, counties and districts and schools and teachers and parents taking ownership of the data, taking ownership of their plan, taking ownership of how they look at the data and how they apply it.
That's huge.
Instead of the top down,
process where there's always the enemy and we don't want to look at the data because, you know, it scares us.
Now it is part of us.
We now take ownership of it.
And that's a major shift that leads to all sorts of good changes.
And one of the changes that we saw is that county offices and districts are able to decide
how they're going to analyze the data in different ways that meet their needs in particular.
So there's built-in flexibility.
So ownership and flexibility, I think it's a win.
Well, thank you for that concluding comment.
The board will reconvene at 1020.
We have two opportunities to talk about special education.
This one is about a federal report.
We hear it annually.
It hasn't been updated in a number of years in terms of the federal reporting requirements.
The next item three, we can talk and there will be another presentation on system of support for students with disabilities.
And so I think we ought to hold the support questions for disabilities for the next one.
And just here now, this federal report, which is a required set of indicators.
Kristen Wright will be here from the CDE to present.
Thank you, President Kirst.
Members, are we ready to go?
We're good?
We're ready.
So this is sort of a three-parter.
This first segment that we're gonna talk about right now during this item is around our federal reporting.
And as you know, we have indicators that we have to report specific data to the Office of Special Education Programs.
I'm sorry, I'm Kristen Wright, Special Ed Director.
Department of Education.
I am joined by Shiloh Bessariel, our administrator of our data unit.
When you're doing the work at the federal level, no special ed state director goes anywhere without their data administrator.
They're joined at the hip.
Today, because this is really her baby, if you will, she will be presenting the actual data points.
She'll be able to answer specific questions about that.
So, back to the three parts.
The first one is a data submission that's due February 1st.
That's why we're here today, to ask you to move that forward.
The second piece will be in the next item around the system of support.
We'll give a brief update, and then I have one of our contractors who's providing technical assistance to give you a flavor of what that looks like coming from the special ed division.
The third will be next meeting, and that will be our state systemic improvement plan, our indicator 17, that will more detail the work of the special ed division and all the contracting and other things we'll be doing for next year in all of our collaborations.
Before I turn it over to Shiloh, a couple of things I wanted to mention about the last item.
I appreciated so much all your comments about this holistic approach.
We've been talking about this for a really long time, I think a decade, and this is finally coming to fruition.
One of the things I wanted to mention was
member Rucker's use of the term appropriate use of the data and we worry in special ed that the data doesn't become about blaming a group of students but rather an opportunity to address more supports and needs for a particular student group.
And so we've had the opportunity to talk with Riverside, too, and see all the incredible work they're doing to desegregate the data, to really use the data that you're gonna be hearing about today.
Because all of these data come from individual student records and IEPs.
And so this is the real data for the state.
This is each and every student in our state.
But we do run the risk of, you know,
as we start to desegregate, especially by disability category, to blame certain categories of students when each disability category really spans the gamut of students with very significant support needs and very mild support needs.
So making any kind of generalizations about a particular disability category is a little bit of a slippery slope, but if we're looking at it from the extent of looking at how we're doing programming and what we need to beef up for support, so if we see
certain indicators that students with autism are far underperforming, that is a huge indication that maybe we want to look at our programs that serve students with autism and how we're serving students with autism and in what environment.
So, it's so much about how the conversation is couched that is so crucial in all of this work.
Also, appreciating Member Strauss' comments about accountability of all teachers.
We're really moving in a direction in the state around credentialing to really empower all teachers to be able to teach the full range of student needs, and then having our special ed teachers come in as those special ed ninjas that we've talked about in the past.
We're looking at that in the same way for how the special ed division works and how we support LEAs coming out of the special ed division.
So you'll hear more about that in the system of support, but I just wanted to say that in that we're not sending everyone off that 163 districts into special ed land, but we're collectively taking responsibility and we're working closely with the CCE and all of our partners to make sure that that happens.
So we're not just creating that bifurcated system again that we're trying to connect.
So, I am going to go ahead and empower Shiloh to come and talk to you, and I will see you at the end of this item and next item.
So, thank you for having us.
I'm a little bit shorter.
Sorry.
Thank you, board members.
My name is Shiloh Besreel.
I am the Data Administrator for Special Education.
So my responsibility is to collect all data on students with disabilities in California and report that both to the public, to the state, and to the federal government.
Kristen was right.
This is my baby.
When I came to the CDE seven years ago, my child was one years old, and I was assigned this report.
And it's kind of grown with me as I've been here seven years.
So it is really my baby.
I did want to kind of ground everybody in what we're talking about today.
We've been talking a lot about the world and how we see the world and sort of this grand scape and vision that we all have.
This item that we're talking about is just one small piece of that.
So just kind of making sure we're aware that we want to talk about how students with disabilities fit in the world and how we see the system of support becoming a big part of that.
But today this item is just talking about one piece of the federal reporting we're required to do.
People ask me a lot about how many students with disabilities we have in California.
We have about 754,000 students with disabilities on any given day.
So if you take a snapshot of a day, we have about 750,000 students with disabilities.
That's the largest number in the United States.
The next number is Texas with about 500,000 students with disabilities.
So obviously we have quite a large number.
And that's 10.9 of the overall student population.
You're going to have to kind of bear with me a little bit today because we are still becoming familiar with the new 508 requirements for our presentations.
And so a lot of the graphs and pictures that I had in my presentation previously are now turned into words.
So please bear with me as it's not as jazzy as it has been in the past.
So just to kind of give you a little bit of sense of how we've grown, the number of students with disabilities has increased 10% since 2005, while the total student population in California has only grown 1.3%.
Of all the categories you can see, we've seen a 200% increase in the number of students with autism.
And that is followed behind students with other health impairments.
To help you understand what other health impairments is, that is students who have typically ADHD or other kinds of health impairments, but ADHD falls in that category.
That's one of the reasons we see that large increase.
We've also seen an increase in our hard of hearing and some traumatic brain injury, but a decrease in some of our other populations as well over the past 11 or 12 years.
I like to show that because it kind of gives us an idea of what we're looking at over the period of time.
If you were to think of last year, and this report and the data that I'm presenting on this report is all 16-17 data, so we're required to collect the data from 16-17 and report it to the U.S.
Department of Education now in February, but it's for the 16-17 school year.
So that's all where this data is coming from.
When we look at the students with disabilities ages 3 through 22, we see that 39 percent of students have a specific learning disability and 21 percent have a speech and language disability followed by other disabilities you can see on that graph.
People ask us a lot of time about home language.
One of the things, and I'll show some data later on in the presentation, is we know about 15 to 16% of our students with disabilities are English language learners.
And people often ask me, what are the home language?
And we come from the home language survey data.
And this is that data here.
61% of our students identify their home language as being English.
And 32% identify their home language as being Spanish, along with other languages.
I couldn't list them all here, because there's very many of them.
And then one of the things that is a little bit different from when we're talking about our K-12 population is that IDEA affords us the ability to serve our three to five-year-old population.
And so people ask us a lot about our three to five-year-old population.
So 62% of our three to five-year-olds have a speech and language impairment, followed by 24% who have autism.
And then if you look at the ethnicities,
You'll see that 56% of our students ages three to five are Hispanic, 23% are white, 9% are Asian, and 5% are African American, followed by the other significant races.
I want to talk to you a little bit about the annual performance report.
I know this is not too exciting.
I'm not going to go through every single indicator.
I'm going to pull out what I think are the most important indicators, especially ones that are aligning with the conversations we're having on the dashboard and the system of support.
But just to kind of help you understand, we are required to submit the annual performance report to the US Department of Education on an annual basis.
Failure to do so will immediately stop our funding from the US Department of Education.
That's a $1.1 billion grant.
98% of that flows directly to LEAs to provide services to students with disabilities.
So it's really important that we prepare this report and that we send it to the US Department of Education.
You all, as the SCA, must approve this item.
The annual performance report consists of 17 indicators, and as we go through them, you'll see some of them are compliance, and some of them are performance, and we'll talk about them a little bit separately.
Just so you know, targets for compliance are either 100% or zero, and we do not get to set them.
They are set for us, either zero or 100%.
Targets for performance are ones that we do get to set.
We have re-benched the annual performance report
targets for the performance indicators and you'll see that through the items.
We benched them in 13-14 and they will be valid through 18-19.
So people ask me, and LA's often ask me, where did you get this data from?
The data comes from a couple of different sources, CALPADS, we get some of the data.
The majority of the data comes from CASEMIS, which is our special education information system.
I will tell you in 2019-20, CASEMIS will be no more.
We will be collecting all the data through CALPADS starting in 2019-20, and I think that's really important to point out because we will tend to see shifts in the data as people get used to the new reporting system and how the data is going to be reported.
So we expect to see a little bit of shifts in data, and we did see that when we switched suspension data over to being reported in CALPADS, and I can talk about that a little bit later.
But KSMIS has been collecting data in a system since 1988, and so I think it's time for us to put that to bed and start collecting it through CALPADS.
We also collect some of the data through the Office of Administrative Hearings as well.
So just to kind of understand what we're talking about, we're talking about data from 2016-17.
There are three indicators that we report that are lag year data, and those are reported from 15-16, and that's graduation, dropout, and suspension expulsion.
Get ready for the exciting stuff.
I know it hasn't been too exciting yet.
So I want to talk a little bit about disproportionality, because if you look at the item, you'll see the largest increases that we saw from last year are in our disproportionality indicators.
In December of 2016, the US Department of Education changed the regulation around significant disproportionality.
And I was here around this time last year, and I said, OK, everybody be prepared, because it's going to be really changed.
It really did change a lot.
It required the use of a risk ratio for all calculations, and it required the state to set a minimum in size and minimum cell size.
One of the things that's very confusing for people is we have two things, one called disproportionality, which we're reporting here, and one called significant disproportionality, which is what's changed in the regulation.
Disproportionality is a one-year calculation and it is a compliance review.
So we identify disproportionate districts and then we review them to determine if they had problematic policies, practices, or procedures.
Significant disproportionality is a three-year calculation.
And districts who are found disproportionate are required to take 15% of their IDEA funds and use them for developing an integrated service plan, an improvement plan.
So the reason I bring this up is because one of the things that we wanted to do with disproportionality is to mirror the calculations for significant disproportionality.
Why is that?
Because if you're a district who becomes significantly disproportionate, it would have been nice if you knew for two years that you were disproportionate and you were on the path to significant disproportionality, and you could have taken steps to identify ways to avoid that significant financial implication.
So what we did is we took the regulations that Ed imposed on us through significant disproportionality, and we applied it to the one-year calculation.
Just so you know, when we look at significant disproportionality, year one would be a root cause.
So hopefully districts who are identified this year would look at their practices, their vision, their ingrained beliefs, and begin to change those so that they can avoid becoming significantly disproportionate.
They would change some of those practices in year two.
If they didn't change any of their practices by year three, they would be significantly disproportionate and find themselves with a fiscal consequence.
So what does that mean for this year?
Last year, we had 63 districts who were disproportionate.
This year, we have 945 districts who were disproportionate.
So, you can see, we've seen almost a ten times increase in the number of districts who were disproportionate on that one-year calculation.
And so, we have had our monitoring units go to those LEAs, look at their IEPs, and begin to determine if there's problematic policies, practices, and procedures.
We're treating this as year one for most districts so that they can begin to really divide some root causes and determine if they can change their practices to avoid becoming significantly disproportionate in three years.
What did that mean for our indicators?
Well, what it meant is that we have increases across the board in our disproportionality increase indicators.
So you'll see we had some, not a big increase in indicator 4B, which is in suspension expulsion, but in indicators nine, which is disproportionate representation, we had a 2% increase.
And in indicator 10, which is our disproportionate representation by disability, we had a 16% increase in districts who were identified and they had problematic policies, practices, and procedures.
So the cause of that is the higher number of LEAs, but also looking at the LEAs more closely to identify those root causes identified more noncompliance.
I did want to give the opportunity for people to ask questions because this has sort of been a hot topic around the world, so if anybody did have any questions about disproportionality before I moved on.
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you very much for pulling this one out, and if you could just describe a little bit about the disproportionality work group that's convening, that would be very helpful.
We've had a disproportionality work group that has met three times.
I think we're probably going to need to meet more.
One of the things that was required in the new regulation was to convene a stakeholder group to begin to examine how we were going to implement the new Department of Education regulations.
So, we have convened a work group.
They met one time in June of last year, one time in September of last year, and they just met, I believe, a week ago on, or earlier this week, January 16th.
Sorry, things seem to be going by fast.
So, and they were discussing a variety of things.
One is the calculation.
The other thing they've been discussing is the notification to LEAs, how we notify LEAs.
And the third thing they've been discussing is how we sort of include them in our support system
and our TA system once they are significantly disproportionate.
I think we still need to have some discussion with the work group around the data and the calculation because one of the things we found when we identified those 945 LEAs, we had lots of very small LEAs who had maybe three students who had, they had three students who were American Indian with disabilities and one of them was suspended.
So all of a sudden they were disproportionate.
So I think one of the things that we've learned through this process is that we need to calibrate the calculation accurately so we're not getting very many false positives.
And I think we're going to meet with the work group.
And one of the things we talked about is bringing some of the recommendations from the work group back to the state board for you all to review once we have them finalized.
Other questions about disproportionality?
Board Member Rucker.
Hi Shiloh, how are you doing today?
As you know, this is an issue that I have been monitoring and bird-dogging with the staff for quite a while.
And one of the concerns I have is not just how this information will impact the way districts are represented and reported in this report, but I want to understand how does it also inform conversations that districts have about the student subgroup of students with disabilities.
In particular, how does it inform the work that they write about and the decisions that they're making with regard to their LCFF and any of the intervention or support that they probably are going to need on this?
The reason why I'm asking is because the other thing that I've noticed is since we have over 700,000 students with disabilities, what I have noticed is that in the reports that have come from a separate division about the use of accessibility tools, that doesn't really seem to match up.
And as a matter of fact, a lot of those supports and interventions for those students is relatively low, given the number of students we have with disabilities on any given day.
This report is probably one of the most significant reports that districts are on the hook for contributing data to for the state to submit, and it has almost immediate impact
for accountability.
So I want to understand how districts are then informed to make what they're reporting on this information a priority as they're turning around and developing information or concerns just for priority with these students in their LCAPs.
I think this year, well, I wanna answer your question in kind of two parts.
One, I think this year has been really enlightening for lots of districts.
Because when we had 63 districts who were disproportionate last year, and now we have a whole new set of over 900 that were disproportionate, it was like, oh my gosh, this is something I really have to look at and pay attention.
And what we've heard from districts was like, we have to have the hard conversations.
And when we were talking, we've been talking with CESA about this information, we've been talking about CCE with this information, it's like,
This is the first time they're having to really have a hard look at some of their practices of their suspension, their identification around race or ethnicity.
So I think as districts are starting to go through that root cause analysis process that they were identified, especially the ones who are identified for differential assistance, they're going to be looking at their disproportionality numbers and their significant disproportionality.
The second part of that that I want to answer is you may or may not know the U.S.
Department of Education has issued a request for comment to delay the implementation of these regulations.
We as at the Special Division has determined that we will not be following that delay and that we will go along with the original intention of implementing the regulations starting in July 1, 2019 because we just feel like it's a really important issue that people need to look at and delaying it wasn't going to help anything.
So I'm kind of looking at it that way.
Thank you.
That's very, very good to know.
Okay, so moving on to some of the other parts of the report, I do also always wanna show some of the good things that we've been doing in terms of compliance.
Last year when I came to you all, I said, oh, you know, we're having some real hard times getting the infants transferred to the preschool program in a timely manner and we'll be working with the regional centers and the Department of Developmental Service.
Well, good news, it seems to have been working.
We see an 8% increase in the number of students
who are transferring from the infant program into the preschool program on a timely manner.
And it's really important when that occurs.
The other thing I like to show is our indicator 13 is our secondary transition indicator.
That's whether or not students have a transition plan by the time they're aged 16.
We are about as close as you can get to 100%, 99.8%.
So actually I'm really proud to see that still increasing in terms of having transition plans.
When we talk about college and career readiness, this is a step in that direction.
Okay, so I'm gonna talk a little bit about some of the performance indicators, and I'm aligning some of this with some of the indicators that are also in the LCFF and the dashboard.
So I wanted to talk to you all about graduation rates.
So we have, this is the graduation data from, again, this is lag year data, 2015-16, and we have a 65.5%, a 1% increase from the previous year.
not a huge increase, but it is moving in the right direction.
So I like to always point that out.
Remember that this is a four year adjusted cohort rate.
And so oftentimes our students with disabilities take five or six years to graduate with a diploma.
And so really understanding that process as well is that you are including, there's students who are not included in this rate who have graduated with a diploma because they took five or six years.
We keep students until they are 22
in the hopes that we can get them moving towards the direction of a diploma.
One of the things I'd also like to point out is that our statewide participation rate, we did make the participation rate for ELA, but unfortunately we did not make it for math.
We have to be at 95%, so we were pretty close, 94.6%.
But in terms of our assessment criteria and whether or not students are meeting the standards, we are finding that in ELA, students are for the most part meeting our targets.
One thing that's typically pointed out to us and we acknowledge is that the targets are relatively low, so we do want to continue to increase those targets over time once we are required to look at those targets again.
starting in 18-19, we'll have to begin to re-bench our targets because the new requirements around targets will come out from the U.S.
Department of Education.
We hope to be able to kind of re-bench those targets, but the good news is that districts are making progress year after year in the assessment indicator.
So that's one thing that I think is really important to point out.
So one thing that is sometimes a little bit hard for people to understand is our suspension and expulsion data that we report.
Now, we have seen an increase in the number of students who are suspended greater than 10 days this year.
And that is obviously disappointing for us because we would like to see that decrease.
One factor that may contribute to this is we started collecting this data in CALPADS.
And so one of the things that we often found is that many of you work at LEAs, you know LEAs have two systems for sometimes collecting data on students with disabilities.
They have a student information system and electronic IEP system.
And the suspension expulsion data is collected in the student information system.
And sometimes the individuals who are collecting that data don't always know the rules and requirements around students with disabilities.
And so we've been working with LEAs to help understand and cross-train their data folks to make sure that this data is entered correctly.
Because we have seen an increase just as switching over from K-SMIS to CALPADS in collecting this data.
And I think a lot of it has to do with really understanding and having that training position.
But also I think working with LEAs to really recognize that some LEAs have very high suspension rates, and high suspension rates among some of their most vulnerable populations.
And so if you're implementing things like PBIS, the expectation is that you reduce those suspension rates.
And I think Kristen is gonna touch a lot about on some of that, I'm not sure, either in the next presentation or next time when we come for this statewide systemic improvement plan.
Indicator 5, I also want to bring up this one.
We look at three things for Indicator 5, which is least restrictive environment.
The students who are 80% or more of the day in a regular class, which is what we would want to see.
Students who are less than 40% of the day in a regular class, those are typically students who are what's called a special day class.
And then students who are in separate schools, residential facilities, or homebound hospital placements.
One of the things I'll point out, and I'll show this in a graph a little bit here, is that we have seen an increase.
We are meeting the target.
But in terms of our targets for 80% or more of the day in a regular class, the targets are still relatively low.
We're seeing incremental increases, not huge increases.
So we're hoping, again, more of the discussion that's happening around the state system of support will help broaden students' access to a regular classroom and regular peers.
Yeah, I have a question on this one.
Do you know how we rank nationally on this indicator in terms of the least restrictive environment?
Compared to other states is what I'm, yeah.
For the most part, we're very low.
I don't have the exact number.
Very low, meaning what?
So many states are in the 70% range.
70% of their students are in the classroom more than 80% of the day.
So I would say we were about middle of the pack.
I'm happy to bring back the exact spot where we land.
I haven't analyzed that data.
But many states have more students in the regular classroom than we do.
And that's been something that's been pointed out to us by stakeholders on multiple occasions.
they are, and getting more students in the regular classroom.
For example, one state that's typically pointed out to us is Colorado.
Colorado has something like 75 percent of their students are in the regular class greater than 80 percent of the day.
Obviously, we would strive to have more of that.
So there hasn't been a lot of correlations between students who are in the regular classroom and the outcomes.
And so I can't actually speak to that part of it.
But we would suspect that access to same age peers, access to the regular education curriculum, that is the goal.
That is the belief of IDEA.
And so students have access to that are more likely to do better, to progress more in their classroom with supports, obviously.
I turned it on.
This is a little bit off topic but it is related to the question I just asked.
I was off mic when I asked how does it correlate with the outcomes that we are reporting.
Because there was the Supreme Court ruling last spring
concerning the higher standard for the outcomes that should be reported for students.
I think that this is something that's important.
It's not related to your report here, but it is a conversation we need to be aware of and that we need to monitor and look at because while I understand that we're in the middle of the pack on increasing the percentage of students who are in the least restrictive environment,
I think we also have to look at what the dashboard is telling us as an indicator for the student subgroup about their performance and whether or not it's trending in the correct direction and are we on track for meeting this new higher standard created by this Supreme Court decision.
Just for everyone else's knowledge, Board Member Rucker is talking about the Andrew case, which set a higher standard that students should make beyond de minimis progress.
So students with disabilities, so it really set the bar higher for districts to make progress for students with disabilities.
And part of that was having them have access to a regular education curriculum and ensuring that they're having access to their general education peers.
I will say that one of the things that we're focusing on, and I bring up this slide here on least restrictive environment for preschool, is the least restrictive environment around preschool.
So if preschool students, if we're starting off children who are ages 3 to 5 in a regular
environment, if they're in an environment where they're around other peers.
If you remember back to the data that I showed that the majority of students with disabilities who are ages three to five are students who have a speech and language impairment.
And so we want to encourage those students to have access to a regular preschool program because that's where that language is going to flourish.
That's where they're going to have real access to peers where they can understand correct language, speech, and those kinds of things.
So if we are giving students who are ages three to five access, then what the expectation is when they're entering kindergarten, they should have access.
And so it's starting that period.
And that's one of the areas that we really want to focus on in the division is in special education is allowing children to have access from that ages three and on.
because if you have a child who's in a separate setting starting at age four, when they start kindergarten, the expectation is they're gonna be in a separate setting.
And so not setting up those expectations and ensuring children have access to a regular education curriculum.
Board member Holliday.
well I agree with Member Rucker in that I do think often we're very well meaning and the idea sounds really great and yet we really do need to understand how these students are performing.
Those who are in the least restrictive environment.
I'm not an advocate for more restriction of course but at the same time are we serving them well?
And so if there's any way we can get the data on that I think it would be important for us.
I'll be happy.
And again, we're going to be back here next, or not next month, I feel like it's March, and so we can definitely bring some of that data back, at least to survive.
I am one of the board liaisons for the significant disproportionality work group.
They keep scheduling the meetings on days I can't attend because my boss expects me to show up for work every so often.
I know, what a mean guy.
This is on TV, isn't it?
He's a nice guy.
He's really a nice guy.
I'm just saying.
I do want to make sure you know I will continue working with the group and they are really doing good work and having great conversations on this.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I also want to know more about the data and I didn't know if this was coming with item 17 when you come back next next time because I think that if we look at the data we may find that
even within this student group, I am sure there are gaps within categories and across categories.
And I really wanna make sure that we keep an eye on that because when I look at language and speech, which is one of the highest categories for students three to five, that is where my son was.
And I've said this before, I had my son identified at 18 months because I knew there was a delay.
When I went through the IEP process, it's a very complex process, even as an educator, but one of the things that I didn't see was questions or support within the IEP, and he wasn't an English learner because he had a delay, the speech was all in English, and that became his first primary language.
But I'm wondering how many of our students in this category, three to five, are ELs, and what we're doing in the IEP process to identify their needs as language learners, besides their needs as, you know, just speech needs.
And so I don't know if that's part of the IEP process, and I don't know what percent of our students
in language and speech are also EL students?
Because it could be something that's being confounded.
We know that.
But I'm wondering, have we analyzed the data to that level?
So one of the problems with that, and I think you bring up an excellent point, is that we don't do the LPAC until a student is in kindergarten.
And so when you are making determinations about whether or not a child is EL, we have no assessment to do that.
So oftentimes,
LEAs might be using the home language survey as an indicator of an EL determination, and so it's not as clear as when you have a child who's K-12, because they are given the LPAC with that assessment, so determination what their level is.
And so that, it's more complicated.
We have some indication of the data, but it's not as clear-cut for K-12.
It is a requirement to ensure that we are addressing needs on both the EL side and the students with disability side and understanding that relationship.
There is currently a work group going on that are developing guidelines around EL and special ed to help better define and delineate that.
So more to come on that in the near future.
Sorry, just to clarify, that last piece, there was a bill that was passed that directed the department to develop a manual.
So I just wanted to clarify, that's under state law.
Yes, so point well taken.
And will that be reflected in the IEP template?
So their language needs again because when you need it.
Sorry just this is getting beyond the scope of what's been noticed in the agenda.
It's getting very much into specific individual student IEPs so just for Bagley Keene purposes that this is a little beyond the scope of what's been noticed in terms of reporting data.
We're happy to bring that back to you.
Legal alert.
Thank you DASAB.
Go ahead.
I will say that you're not the first person that we've, and it's a concern we obviously look at as well.
So I think we can bring it back in more in another iteration.
Does anyone have any other questions about the annual performance report itself?
Okay, I do have a couple of things that I would like to talk about in terms of preparing you for the next set of items.
Because remember I showed that big picture of the planet in my first slide saying that you're talking about the world, we're talking about this.
Well, people ask a lot about what's happening with students with disabilities and the LCAP and the state system report.
I wanna give you some things to kind of put in your brain as you get ready for that.
next set of conversations.
So again, this slide isn't as jazzy as it's been in the past.
It used to be called the Pac-Man slides because they look like little Pac-Mans.
But just to help you understand, 10.92%, that's the number of students with disabilities we have in California compared to the overall population.
When we look at the LCFF subgroups, we notice those students, those percentages are much higher.
So 12% for students who are in poverty, 15% for students who are EL,
English language learners, and then 25% of foster care children are students with disabilities.
So there is a greater percentage.
The other data that I really like to show is a lot of people say to us all the time, well, you know, all this focus on students with disabilities, what about all the other subgroups?
Well, 69% of students with disabilities are in one
of the LCFF subgroup, so something really important.
The one thing that I did want to prepare you all for in the next sets of conversation that I think Kristen is going to be talking about is around, people ask us, well how have students been doing over time?
So I wanted to bring you three sets of information to show you.
You know, we at the department have been doing a lot of work.
around improving performance, looking at students with disabilities, improving outcomes, but really in our own narrow focus in our siloed world.
And so if you look at the work we've been doing over the last seven years, you'll notice that the data shows that we've been relatively flat.
The decrease that happens in graduation from 2011-2012 happened when we implemented the four-year adjusted cohort, and since that time, we've incrementally increased, just one or two percentage points per year.
We're not seeing major increases.
Same thing when we talk about suspension expulsion.
We've seen the suspension expulsion rate for students who are suspended greater than 10 days increase over time.
And the data that I really like to show is on least restrictive environments.
So when you see this, this is the data I like to show quite often, that our least restrictive environment categories have remained very flat.
There's a bump here and there, but for the most part, they are very flat.
When districts are doing work in a siloed environment, where special ed is expected to fix itself, what happens is you have really flat outcomes.
And so we're very excited the work that's being done in the system of support.
And I wanted to give you this data to kind of help you set up that conversation that you're about to have around the system of support because it really does integrate a lot of both the special education and the general education together.
And I think that's really important to set forward.
And then if you wanted to kind of assess that.
So just a few last-minute considerations as we close this item and that is that really access to general ed begins in preschool and so just giving that last plug for really starting our students off on that trajectory.
That really
Our employers and community members of tomorrow are the children who share the classrooms of today.
And this was really pointed out by our director of Department of Rehabilitation, Joe Xavier, who has been working with a lot of employers of individuals with disabilities.
And in order for people to believe that people have potential, they have to see that potential as they're growing up with them.
So, if they've been separated from them their whole lives and they suddenly arrive, they don't understand individuals with disabilities or how to support them in employment.
Also, that equity and diversity apply to disability.
I know we're preaching to the choir here.
But sometimes we get that we have the equity and access conversation without people with disabilities.
And so just always want to make sure we're part of that conversation.
And again, thank you for supporting the notion that really the task force brought to light, which was we are one coherent system of education.
And we've seen so many incredible, positive changes.
And a lot of that is due to your support and continued drive to bring that home.
So thank you so much.
Are there further board comments on this presentation before we go to public comment?
Okay, not seeing any, we're ready for public comment.
We have three speakers for public comment.
Gina Plate, Terry Burns, and Jim Anderson.
Please line up.
You have one minute.
Good morning, President Kurtz, Superintendent Gillis, and members of the board.
My name's Gina Platon.
I chair the Advisory Commission for Special Ed.
And I just want to start by saying how much I appreciated the discussion this morning about accountability and board member Straus' comments about how we are responsible for each and every child.
It's just very exciting to hear the ongoing discussion and commitment to that.
So the commission has been engaged with the department specific to the plan that you just heard our data guru Shiloh talk about.
And we voted in our last meeting to support the plan and have really appreciated the transparency that the department has shown throughout the process.
So I want to thank them and commend them for that.
But we also see this as a call to action of sorts.
And many of you have articulated something similar this morning.
The commission's eager to continue working with the system of support and the other stakeholders that have come together in a very collaborative way.
we're ready to roll up our sleeves and continue in this conversation.
So just want to encourage you to support the plan as it was presented and thank you for your ongoing discussion in this area.
Good morning.
I'm Jim Anderson.
I'm the current chair for the Self Administrators Association of California.
And we are excited in the direction that we're seeing things move towards one coherent system.
We appreciate the collaborative work of the Special Education Division.
There's been a lot of hard work, there's been a lot of change, and it is felt that we are truly moving towards one coherent system for students with disabilities.
The shift from special education only focusing on compliance to special education and the focus for students with disabilities on performance outcomes is tremendous for our students with disabilities.
And again, the leadership of the special education division, the work around understanding the data and understanding the shifts,
It's tremendous, and we look forward to further collaboration and continued hard work on this.
Thank you.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I want to thank the Special Ed, the Division for Children with Exceptional Needs, we're going to keep calling it, and Kristen and Shiloh for their tremendous work and leadership in this area.
Really appreciate the efforts by both the Governor and the Board to create a more integrated system and provide some resources to
to help our most underserved students.
But I do wanna echo the comment and I was very pleased that Shiloh raised it relative to smalls who have been designated as disproportionate because it is often one student that's doing that.
And so we look forward to having conversations and working with, so we wanna make sure that issues are being addressed and we do so in a way that is reflective of the circumstances.
So thank you.
Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
And I certainly want to commend the quality of this report, the readability, the understandability.
We have shared it with our members as a teaching tool and an experience tool.
The issue was raised that a lot of times these students are hidden in the shadows.
And if you don't have one of these students, you don't know that they're out there.
We think this is a really useful tool in teaching our community about the variety of students we serve.
and their very special needs.
So thank you for this work.
All right.
This was an information item, so an action item as well.
We have to approve the report for the federal government to send this plan forward.
So looking for a motion on that.
Yeah, I just wanted to mention, thank you.
I appreciated Ms.
Burns comment about using this information to inform action.
So thank you for sharing this as a tool.
And this is just the first segment of work.
We have, they're going to be coming back on indicator 17, which is actually a plan for how do we address these issues.
So while we've seen incremental improvements in some areas, we do have a lot of work to do clearly, but we will be
looking at that in more depth in March.
So I move approval of the CD's recommendation to approve the executive summary for FY16-17.
Second by Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that is approved.
And now we're on to item three.
Before we have our presentation, I wanted to note that Governor Brown's proposed budget, released last week, has proposed more than $70 million in ongoing state funding to implement the state system of support, including around $55 million for county offices of education to provide differentiated assistance
$4 million for LEED County Offices of Education to support the work of their peers, and more than $11 million in ongoing funding for the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
There will be more details released on this proposal very soon.
It's called the budget trailer language and that will sketch out the details.
So that's a context setting for the item on the integrated system support and Melanie will present for CDE and then we will have several guest presentations.
Good morning.
I'm very excited to be here.
We might have to work off a PDF instead of my PowerPoint.
It seemed to have disappeared, but that's all right.
Do you mind if we take, it's a PDF though, sometimes it gets awkward.
So if you don't mind if I take 20 seconds just to make sure of the PowerPoint version.
All right, good morning.
President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
Oh, thank you.
I'm gonna do it again.
The screenshot here is... Is it wonky?
You know, I... See, you call on the magic of Cindy and it just comes, it just comes forward.
And look, it's even gonna go forth.
Okay, thank you.
And you know, I have to say, there were two board members that did see me here at 8 a.m., trying to make sure I had my right side.
So, you know I take this very seriously.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I am very excited to be here.
I am Melanie Sheppy, the Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division here at CDE.
And I'm happy to present an update on California's system of support for local educational agencies and schools.
Today is a unique presentation because we're able to pull together chunks of information that you all have discussed and digested since July.
It's an opportunity to tie together those big pieces of information so that we can see the big picture.
I think it's so valuable that the Riverside County Office of Education presented earlier because really their work is living out these pieces of the system of support.
So for those of you that are really concrete,
I think their presentation gives you a way to visualize these pieces in action.
And for those of you that are maybe more high-level and want to see the larger picture, the next few minutes will help you see that larger statewide view.
And so just keep that Riverside presentation in your mind as we go from the high-level, state-level view of the pieces to then what is that looking like in practice.
After I present on pulling those pieces together, we'll pause for questions and discussion, and then we'll have Peter Birdsaw and Ed Manansala from the El Dorado County Department of Education to talk about the work to support County Offices of Education with differentiated assistance, and then we'll end with an update on the California Department of Education Special Education Division's evolution of their support, which Kristen and Shiloh set up in the item before mine.
In July, we started very high level with the goal for the system of support, and you'll see that on the screen.
And even though I, Melanie Sheppy, am presenting today, I cannot stress enough that this work is really the result of collaboration between all the state agencies and stakeholder input in conversation.
And this work will continue to develop in that way.
As I have personally discussed this goal in a variety of settings, the focus on building capacity so that communities can continue to improve on their own is one aspect of the goal that resonates across stakeholder groups, from district office staff to teachers to advocacy groups.
This is the goal and this is what we're working towards.
It's a way to test our actions so that we can ask ourselves if what we're developing or implementing is aligned with what we value and where we want to be, where we want to go.
You saw this slide earlier when Riverside County Office of Education talked about their levels of support to districts and schools.
And even though the goal we just talked about is helpful, it wasn't enough to shape a new reality.
The new reality of accountability and continuous improvement in California is really what the local control funding formula statute set the foundation for.
And so we start with the goal, but then we think about levels of support.
These levels are very similar to an RTI, or a response to intervention, or an MTSS, multi-tiered system of support, approach to education that we see districts and schools striving for today.
You begin with level one.
Level one is the support that is available to all districts and schools.
When you think of the classroom, it's the teaching, it's the support that's available to all the students.
However, beyond the support for all districts and schools, the local control funding formula statute identified that some LEAs are going to need additional support.
And that's where we get to differentiated assistance or level two.
again making the parallel to the classroom, you will have a group of students that will need additional support and the teacher will work to address that in tutoring or have a different scaffolding or building of prior knowledge to address that specific group's needs.
One thing that's really important and I know I'm speaking to the choir when I talk about this,
But in a multi-tiered system of support model and approach to education, level two support really leverages what's happening in level one.
So if we think about the classroom, the teacher is leveraging what they're doing whole group, but then meeting the needs of their students perhaps in a smaller group setting or perhaps with supplemental text.
And I think you can see California trying to live out this approach and this value through the expansion of the SUMS cohort, or the MTSS cohorts, through the Orange County Department of Education.
The Orange County Department of Education has committed to adjusting the requests for applications for Cohort 3, so they've done Cohort 1 and 2, and now specifically for Cohort 3,
Priority will be given to any school district that's been identified for differentiated assistance based on the fall 2017 dashboard release.
And I think this is a perfect example of California trying to live out a model of a multi-tiered system of support by leveraging support that's in level one for districts that are identified for additional support.
And districts who go through that Cohort 3 process will also have their county office of education going through that with them side by side, because they're doing that work understanding the data and underlying causes together.
So that's one way.
We're not just sending them off to Cohort 3, but it's leveraging what we have for everyone for specific groups of LEAs that need additional support.
Beyond the levels of support,
We made sure that we tried to bring forward to the public the results of learnings from previous school and district change efforts.
And you'll probably remember us talking about this earlier.
Two of the biggest learnings is that we need to build district capacity to support schools, rather than focusing on schools in isolation, and that we can't create a one-size-fits-all approach to improvement work.
I think we've heard loud and clear, we need expectations and quality to improvement work, and that's something we need to make sure we continue to focus on, but that it also needs to be able to adjust to local needs.
And I think you can hear how Riverside County Department of Education has done that, and also in previous presentations from Mary Barlow from Kern County, and when Ed Menanzales spoke with us a few months ago for El Dorado County.
Yeah.
Hi.
How are you?
It's cutting off for people that are watching.
They can't see the bottom bullet.
It's a PowerPoint, right?
Oh, OK.
Let's see here.
Oh, this is a PDF document.
Yeah, let me see here.
Well, let's bring it down to there and then full screen it right here.
What's that?
Right here.
It's a PDF, so it's a matter of having to find the right size for this.
And when you full screen it, it resizes again.
So again, a few months ago, we put forward the research, and stakeholders found it really digestible.
It was about four pages.
WestEd helped us synthesize it, and I know it resonated a lot with your experiences in previous school and district change efforts.
So we've talked about the goal, we've talked about the levels of support, we've talked about how it's moving forward, we're learning from previous change efforts, but we're also regularly incorporating stakeholder feedback.
And so the first few bullets here, stakeholders asked for, when we asked them what does support look like, they want more assistance conducting needs assessments, developing action plans, protected time and support of how to create the space for data analysis, not only among staff but with communities.
Sharing of best practices.
I think I heard loud and clear.
Don't just tell me what best practice you're using, but how did it become a best practice at your site?
Tell me about your improvement journey so that can inform some of the barriers that I might have to overcome in my improvement journey.
One thing I want to make sure I highlight, it's the last bullet, and it's one thing we're hearing currently from stakeholders, and they're asking for more support in helping build the capacity for districts or local educational agencies to engage with stakeholders throughout the LCAP process.
And so I think it's our responsibility, all the state agencies, to think about, well, what capacity building can we help support so that LEAs are able to authentically engage with their communities throughout the LCAP process?
So from here, we talked about the shifts to improvement, because it's not only important to learn from past practices, but also to instill that into guiding principles for the future, especially because folks only know what they've experienced, and we're really trying to help paint a vision of how work can be different.
The shifts to California's approach to improvement combine what we've learned and what stakeholders have asked for.
And it's through the actual work currently underway between counties and districts that we see these shifts taking place.
Now I'll have to say, I'm a very optimistic person.
I bring a lot of enthusiasm and joy to the work.
But as you all know, this work is hard.
This work is challenging.
I think with each shift here, you can think of all the challenges associated with working in that new way.
So thinking about support providers working alongside LEAs, that creates authentic, that needs authentic relationships.
And I've heard a lot of county offices talk about, I'm working on my relationship with my district so that they trust me as we're looking at their data together.
And relationship building is hard.
And so I say that because
This approach to improvement is very different from past efforts and it's a big shift.
But it's our responsibility to make sure that we're taking steps to make sure leaders in education and in the field can take on this shift.
We can't just paint the future and then let people try to create it without additional specific concrete support.
So today I'll highlight just a few of the steps that the different state agencies have taken
So I can highlight today a few of the concrete steps that we've taken to make sure these shifts aren't just aspirational principles, but real things that we can see living out in improvement work.
The first one was highlighted earlier, and that's the CDE dashboard webinars, including making sure we focused on how do you combine the dashboard and the LCAP process and the physical LCAP template.
There's also the CCEE, California Collaborative for Educational Excellence trainings.
They're spring trainings.
I was just part of their dashboard update training last week.
But also on February 8th, they have a data and evaluation training.
And we know we've heard from stakeholders, we want more support in thinking about how to evaluate some of the work we're doing.
We also have an RFA, a request for application, that just went out yesterday for the funds that were in AB99 to create equity teams.
And that's specifically helping build not only county capacity, county office capacity, but also making sure there's direct connection to work in schools and districts.
And then finally, just as one additional example, the county offices of education have had incredible improvement science trainings to build the capacity of county office staff and also peer-to-peer efforts.
So I had the privilege of being a part of the LCAP directors meeting, I think it was last month, and every county first shared out in their region the struggles and the positive aspects of the initial outreach to districts.
And then they shared out a whole group.
And I think one board member asked earlier, I think it was board member Sun, about districts, the willingness and the trust to look at the data together.
And you could hear counties authentically sharing both the positives and the struggles of even that initial conversation.
and you can see them brainstorming in regions.
So I know it's not perfect, and I know we'll have a lot of more work to do, but I think it's important to highlight that we put these shifts forward, but then we're trying to take concrete steps so that it really can live out through the improvement work between counties and districts.
One other piece we put forward in a board item and that we all discussed together were the elements of support when you think specifically about differentiated assistance.
Because I think for level one, people understand that.
Okay, it's what we're doing for all.
You can almost make a parallel to any system or any support structure.
But we really wanted to be more clear about what we're talking about for the differentiated assistance process and what would happen at each part of the process.
You'll remember we've brought up several counties to talk about what their work looks like and how they're organizing to support this.
One thing is I was going over the slides like the hundredth time.
One thing that stood out to me on this slide was that the review of data.
So we're talking about what specifically is happening in differentiated assistance level two.
Review of data and understanding underlying causes being a huge cornerstone of that work.
And that's what we're expecting to happen in level one with all districts and schools.
So again, just an example.
California is trying to leverage what should happen for all districts and schools for those identified for differentiated assistance.
So you're still looking at your data.
You're not doing something else, but you're looking at your data with the support of your county office.
I just think that the more we can make those levels clear and show how we're trying to leverage level one for level two support, the more it will show that California is trying to walk the walk, trying to talk the talk.
One of the last pieces I'll go over are the possible examples of support and assistance.
This is in the November item.
I've had several people ask me, but what happens if it's a one-time issue?
It's not very lengthy for each of these examples of support and assistance, but I think it is clear.
And so oftentimes I've said, oh, well, if it's a one-time unique situation, I would imagine that after understanding that, your county office would then, you know, check in with you on how your plan is going to address that one time.
Because if it's a one-time situation, but you never address it, it's gonna be a one-time situation again, and then we're gonna have a pattern.
So this is a nice place for folks to go if they, you know, they say, well, what if it's persistent issues?
What if it's something that the school and the county, or I'm sorry, the district and the county can't really address together?
And I think what's important is that these examples help show that there's not a clear cookie cutter response.
if you get to that point where a district has a need and the county office can't directly provide the support for that need for whatever reason, that there's not, then do this, then follow this checklist.
Instead, it's really the collective responsibility of the state agencies, and one of the primary reasons we created the cross-agency group
is to discuss that.
Here's a district that has a need.
How can we get that need met?
Is there a partnership that that county office can engage in to support the district?
Is it an initiative that they don't have access to because they weren't in first round, but we can expand that?
So I think this concept of mutual accountability and all the state agencies being in regular communication and collaboration so that we can work together to get districts what they need just in time
is really also part of a cornerstone of a multi-tiered system of support approach.
You need to have everyone in regular communication about the folks that you're trying to get support to.
So just for my part, just I wanna close with, what does this all mean?
And we talked about this at our last meeting in December.
I think we cannot stress enough that this means that LEAs are the primary drivers of assistance.
That the LCAP process is the place to identify needs, goals, outcomes, and resources.
And that support opportunities must be leveraged across California.
And I tried to give examples of that today.
We do continue to hear questions about the roles and responsibilities of the agencies charged with support.
Specifically, thinking about how are we gonna make sure that they have the capacity to provide the support that districts need.
The overview I provided today ideally responds a little bit to that question, and hopefully the updates that you'll hear next from Peter Birdsall, Ed Manansala, and Kristen Wright and Kristen Brooks from the Special Education Division will continue to respond to that question about the roles and responsibilities of the agencies.
But as I said, we do not have a clear cookie cutter approach that says these are the needs people have and this is how each agency will respond.
Instead, we're trying to be in deep relationship with districts and then make sure county offices are connected to the resources they need so that we can get districts what they need just in time.
And if we find that we don't have it, then we try to create it or we try to make sure that need doesn't go unmet.
I just really want to stress that there's so much more work to do.
Today's presentation was really to try to pull together the pieces that we've talked about over the last four meetings, and hopefully with this update we'll be able to continue to not only talk about the work that needs to be done, but the evolution of the work and be able to talk about how are we making sure
that the work is of high quality across California?
Because I know that's a question you all have asked and one that's also on top of everyone's mind.
One demonstration I will have, because I think it's important when I say there's a lot of work to do, to then highlight some of the work we've done to respond to the needs out there.
So I'm gonna pause for questions, but then I will go into a GIS demo, a Geographical Information System demo.
And this is a tool that responds directly to stakeholders who have asked for assistance and understanding where are people doing this well,
Where are the support opportunities that are out there?
What does all of this look like?
So I will do that next, but I do want to pause before I get into that tool to answer any questions you have or just to, President Christy, encourage any board member discussion.
Right.
I think this is a good place to stop because we have another group of students here to be honored and it's on item four, the Senate Youth Students.
And so I think before we take the questions, we can do that and then
the students can get on to their other needs of the day with their award.
So I'm going to turn it over to Superintendent Torlakson to handle this part of the... So we're moving to item four temporarily.
We will go back to item three.
Thank you, President Kirst.
And this is always a fun opportunity to see bright young people who are future leaders for this state and for the United States.
And Dina Fong is going to come up and just give a little background on the United States Senate Youth Program.
And then I'll go up and ask each of the honorees to be recognized and tell a little bit about each of them.
And then President Kirst, you and I will hand out some certificates of commendation and get a photo with them.
So, Dina Fong, who runs this program, does an excellent job organizing the interview panels and hard choices because there's so many talented people in California, so many talented young people.
Dina?
Thank you, Superintendent.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst, and honorable board members.
As Superintendent Torlakson said, I'm Dina Fong, the U.S.
Senate Youth Coordinator for California.
And today is a special day and one of my favorite days that we have here to honor our United States Senate Youth students.
To give you some background, the United States Senate Youth Program is sponsored by the U.S.
Senate and funded and administered by the William Randolph Hearst Foundation.
Now in its 56th year the program provides an opportunity to selected students to gain an in-depth view of the Senate and the federal government as well as provide a foundation for those considering a future in public service on the local, state, and national level.
High school juniors and seniors are nominated by their principal to apply for this highly competitive merit-based program.
To qualify, students must hold student body office or another elected or appointed position in their communities and show academic interest and aptitude in government, history, and politics.
Our students have gone through a rigorous application process and have demonstrated outstanding leadership qualities, school and community involvement, and a desire for public service.
The last phase of the program is to formally present our 2018 U.S.
Senate Youth Delegates and Alternates.
These students are among the best of the best in their school, community, and the state.
There is no doubt that they will succeed in whatever they do and will serve their communities with passion.
Our two delegates will represent California during an all-expenses-paid trip this March in Washington, D.C., where they will see national government in action and hear from senators, cabinet members, and other officials.
They'll each receive a $10,000 college scholarship for undergraduate studies with encouragement to study coursework in political science and history.
Now, I'd like to invite Superintendent Torlakson to come forward so he can introduce the students to you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dina.
And it's a pleasure to introduce each of the four to you.
And I'll start with Mackenzie Hawkins.
Please come forward and stand here as I read a little bit about your background and your aspirations.
Nice to meet you.
Congratulations.
Our first delegate is Mackenzie, a senior and student body vice president at Amador High School in Pleasanton, California.
She's an advisor with the Diversity Week Committee and serves as delegate president to the YMCA Youth and Government Program.
McKenzie has a wide variety of skills which she uses to help her community.
She tutors at a local elementary school.
She teaches special needs children and adults how to swim.
She translates Spanish for low-income families shopping at Kohl's department store.
She hopes she's working hard to attend Stanford University and major in political science and international studies.
and attend a law school and get a master's degree afterwards.
Then she would like to work in the nonprofit sector before pursuing a career in the State Department or United Nations and someday run for public office.
Congratulations.
And if you could just stand by here, I'll invite the second delegate up and we'll read a little bit, share a little bit about their background.
And then we'll get all four of us and get a presentation from the president of the board.
Our second delegate is Cole McCann Phillips.
Please come forward.
Berkeley High School, congratulations.
Senior at Berkeley High School serves as a member of the Student Senate and the Berkeley High School Site Council.
He's active with CASC, the California Association of Student Councils, and serves as their Governed Affairs Policy Director.
where he participated in a working group on the new accountability system that we've been talking about here this meeting and many others before.
He actually testified to the Senate Committee on Education about his thinking on the accountability system.
He serves as the president of his school's speech and debate team, improving the team's record from 71st in the nation to 14th in the nation.
Great accomplishment.
He created Students for Mental Health Reform and has coordinated fundraising efforts for homeless students at his school.
He hopes to attend Brown University and plans to double major in political science and public policy.
He aims to become a federal prosecutor to bring justice to the downtrodden and knows his future includes social and political advocacy.
Congratulations, Cole.
Our next, and again, thank you, you can stay right here, we'll invite up Olivia Fu, who is an alternate delegate to the United States Senate.
Congratulations.
A little bit about Olivia.
A senior at St.
Francis Catholic School in Sacramento, she currently serves as Lieutenant Governor of the Key Club, International Division 7 North, serving over 1,000 members.
I spoke to Key Club members just earlier this week in Antioch.
They do a great job, the Key Clubs,
Thank you for your leadership.
Throughout high school, she has volunteered close to 5,000 hours in community services.
She served as an Okinawan peace scholar in Japan as an exchange student and is the founder president of the chapter of the Girls Up Club through the United Nations Foundation.
She is a volunteer attorney and juror for the Eldorado County Teen Court.
She's interned and gained experience working in Sacramento Mayor Daryl Steinberg's office, and she wants to be a major in international relations and minor in economics.
Her future career goals include working abroad as a diplomat and someday becoming a U.S.
ambassador, using her multicultural background to forge connections and build bridges.
So congratulations.
Our second alternate, another outstanding individual, would Steven Pineda come up?
He's a senior at university, senior high school in Los Angeles.
Congratulations.
Steven presides as a student body president focusing on campus unity.
He also serves on the Los Angeles United Superintendent's Student Advisory Council and on Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti's Youth Council.
Steven plans to attend Stanford University and will be the first in his generation in his family to go to college.
After he graduates, he wants to work as a community organizer and set up job training facilities in South Central Los Angeles.
Then he wants to become a civil rights attorney and focus on immigration and work discrimination issues, advocating for all citizens.
Please join me in applauding and recognizing these outstanding youth, bright as they are, contributing so much already.
You have a future that will brighten California so much more.
Please congratulate them.
Aren't they impressive?
So encouraging to see and hear their desire to create positive change.
And let's also thank their parents and their teachers who helped guide them along the way.
The parents can stand up if you're here.
Please stand up.
The parents, just be recognized.
Thank you again.
And now President Kirst will join me in presenting you with certificates of commendation, and then we'll have some food together and share more about your aspirations and dreams.
Thank you.
And the certificates are on standby right here.
And maybe a photograph.
That's a good idea.
Right here.
OK.
Follow us.
This one's for Mackenzie Hawkins.
OK.
She's the one in black.
Dina, can you hand those to me?
Thank you.
And I'll give this one to Mr. President Kirsch.
OK, where do you want the framing?
OK, by the flag.
So I think I do have Mackenzie's first.
Yeah, Mackenzie's to get hers first from President Kirsch.
Congratulations again.
Hang on a second.
You guys are just going to share.
Do you want to go down?
I took a few classes here last summer, so.
You know, he's a Stanford man.
Oh, really?
I've been here for 49 years.
Thank you, Mackenzie.
And the next one will be Paul.
Why don't you stand between us, and we'll get that photo.
Got it?
Thank you very much.
You are so welcome.
And next we have Olivia.
Olivia Fu.
Can you take two steps that way?
OK.
There, perfect.
There we go.
All right.
We'll see you at the lunch.
Good.
And would our student board member like to say a word?
Definitely.
Good to see you.
Well, I'd like to commend you guys.
So much potential that our generation has, but even more so that we can catalyze change right now.
You guys are all doing it actively in your communities.
And in the future, as you guys said,
in your biographies, I'm sure you guys can do amazing things for the state, amazing things for our nation.
So I'm really just so proud of each and every one of you.
When I grow up, I hope I'm like you guys.
Cole and Steven are actually two of my closest friends.
So every day, I get to see the amazing things you're doing in the community.
And Mackenzie and Olivia, even though I don't know you guys personally,
I'm sure you guys are doing astounding things, too.
I mean, I just heard, like, I'm sure just the surface of the things you guys are doing.
So just congratulations again.
I'm very proud of you guys.
And have fun in Washington, DC.
Thank you.
Thank you
It's like you got paparazzi.
Thank you.
Sure.
Okay, Melanie, if you can come back up.
I think we're ready for... We're now returning to item three on our agenda and we will have initial set of questions on the first presentation if the board has any questions for Melanie.
Any questions?
Seeing none, I think we can move on then if you introduce our guests.
She's still finishing.
Real quick, I promise.
Can you all see the GIS map on your TV?
And it's good size?
Okay, great.
So again, my name is Melanie Sheppy.
I'm the Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division, and I have the ultimate privilege to present a tool that I did not create.
So this is the work of Greg Dixon and Jonathan Eisler in Cindy Kazanis' division, and I think
It's a direct response to some of the resources and information that stakeholders are asking for.
So again, this is a GIS map, geographical information map, and what Greg and Jonathan put together is a storyboard of different ways we could show information.
This is just a demonstration.
It's not the full capacity of the system.
So if you have an idea of could we also map this or could we map this, the answer is probably yes.
But for this presentation, so that I could show you three discrete tools, we kept it narrowly focused.
So what you see on your screen is just a map of the counties in California.
Now, you'll see districts that are identified
for support under the local control funding formula.
You'll notice the purple spaces are districts that are identified for support, and the gray spaces are districts that are not.
When you have this on your computer, you can zoom in as much as you want.
You'll be able to see that there's district lines in the gray.
So you'll notice down here in Southern California, the gray spaces are several different districts.
Up here in the middle of California, those purple spaces are different districts.
So those are some of the more details you can see as you drill down.
So beyond seeing spatially who's identified or who's eligible for support, you can also take that and look at, well, how many student groups met the criteria for support?
So on this map, the size of the circle indicates how many student groups were identified for that district.
So if you look at a larger circle,
they had four to five student groups identified.
Again, if you're on your computer looking at it, you can click and it will give you that information.
These five student groups here are the specific ones for this district.
The smaller the circle, the fewer student groups that were identified for that district.
And again, we're looking at districts for this demonstration, but you can also do it at the school level.
So now let's move to looking at support opportunities.
So we've heard folks ask for not only information on level one resources out there, but also where do they exist across California?
Do we have any gaps?
So for the purpose of today, Greg only mapped one support opportunity, and that's participating in a professional learning network with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
So what you see on the screen
Purple districts are ones that are not participating in a professional learning network, and yellow districts are ones that are participating.
And I do say I have heard many counties talk about expanding their professional learning network to include other districts.
So this is just the formal count of districts that are in the professional learning networks.
We know there's a lot of other informal networking and kind of growing of those participants.
You could map any type of support on to this map.
You could think about state-provided support.
You could map networks that are out there with other types of funding or other types of organizations.
Finally, the last piece I wanted to show you, people have asked for support in making connections among districts.
Specifically, if I have a need, how can I find someone who's doing well in that area?
And so what you'll see on the screen
So this is very busy, it's a lot of colors because this is all the districts and their overall student performance on the suspension indicator only.
So if you see a blue space, that's a district that has blue overall for their district suspension indicator.
Again, you can do this by school site as well.
Now let's say you were really interested in connecting districts who had a blue performance level with districts who had a red performance level.
You can very easily see where, I felt a little magical there, right?
Should I do it again?
Okay, let's do it again.
All right, so we start very colorful.
Don't egg me on, you know I'm really gonna ham it up.
So we start with all the districts and then.
You can see districts specifically, thank you, Board Member Rucker, ooh, you can see specifically districts that overall their suspension indicator was red or overall their suspension indicator was blue.
Again, you can do this at the school level.
So we wanted to demonstrate this tool for you, also just to get your feedback if there's specific things you'd like to see mapped out.
Again, this is very narrow, just to provide you three different ways that we can visualize information, and also respond directly to stakeholder feedback.
I know the last CPAC, the California Practitioner Advisory Group meeting, specifically they were asking for this connection support.
Can you provide me a tool so I can see connections very easily?
And this is one way that we'd be able to provide that to the field in counties and districts as they're doing the work together.
So I'll open it up.
Any questions for my overview presentation or any comments or questions about the GIS tool?
I'm sorry, President Kirsten, open it up.
Board Member Rucker was first.
Okay, so I have just three comments.
Comment number one, in looking at this tool, I don't really understand all of the things that you just showed us, but I want it.
And comment number two, now that's what I'm talking about.
This is the kind of information that people keep asking to try to understand what are we doing and do we know what we're doing and what are we doing with the information that we've got to understand and give a really good profile about what's going on with our schools and where the work is going.
and how to define the interlocking and overlapping levels of support that's being provided by different agencies that really shows that.
And then finally, I just have to say, wow, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
Now this is really flirting with me.
I really like this.
And once upon a time, I received this degree in urban planning, GIS is, which I never really used, but go bears.
And GIS is, go bears.
GIS is a very powerful tool.
You could overlay density, you could look at racial and ethnic breakdowns.
This is a very powerful tool and I am so glad that we're looking at this.
I have a perfect home for this, it's called the Equity Report.
Landing it with a link so that we could then look at all these tabs and more.
I mean, the possibilities are endless really with GIS.
So I think that this as a visual is great and you could really zoom in and start geocoding things and start really understanding if we're looking at Riverside County, if we're looking at LA County and we're seeing this information, then we could really make inference about other things and start connecting the dots.
So yes, thank you.
This is great.
I couldn't, I was trying to figure out the link so that I could retrieve it and play with it.
I'm not sure if that's available to us, just so that we could explore it.
We'll send you also a PDF of the reports if you just kind of want to see them in static, if that's kind of easier to digest at first.
But you'll be able to get a link because it is hosted on the web.
So it's something that we could eventually make public so that the public in the field can use it.
So yeah, we can make that available.
Okay.
Yes, more and more of this.
Thank you.
Yeah, I have a question on the providers.
The Gates Foundation did a pass at this three years ago or so and in looking at networks and consultants that were working in various places and there were these high concentrations and then there were complete deserts with nothing.
And so how are you going to populate the providers?
And you know, because there's so many out there and classify them and all that sort of thing.
Well, I think the first thing we can do is ask for your old feedback on what providers would you like mapped.
And then we can go and get that information.
So when we were first looking at this as a department, we had also mapped on there the CCE, the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence pilots.
We had also mapped some of our federal resources, so our Title I, Title III leads that are out there.
So really, as long as we can get a spreadsheet of the information, it doesn't matter who's providing the network or the support.
So it could be a private or a nonprofit set of networks, and then it can just be clearly labeled what you're looking at when you filter that.
So absolutely, depending on what you all are interested in seeing mapped, then we can go out and get that information and have it in ways that you can see it in different ways.
Okay.
Yeah, I think this would elucidate something.
To me, a lot of the media coverage of our system of support is misleading in that it implies that the counties are going to provide everything or it's all going through the counties.
You read over and over again, well, they're going to, you know, need some assistance and the counties are going to do it.
Well, the counties
cannot do it all.
They have to, there will be other providers in the mix.
The county role, as we'll elucidate later, is not to do every bit of the assistance.
So, anything that we could do to clarify that, and this is one thing, I think would help greatly.
Thank you.
All right, any further questions?
So now I would love to introduce Peter Birdsall and Dr. Ed Manansala, who will provide a discussion on County Office of Education Support for Differentiated Assistance.
And then, like I said, after that, we'll have Kristen Wright and Kristen Brooks talk about the evolution of the Special Education Division support.
Well, thank you.
I'm Peter Birdsall, Executive Director of CSES, the County Shrink Tents Association.
I just wanted to touch, provide a brief update on three things.
First, what we've been doing to support counties, to prepare them to support their school districts.
Second, a review of the rollout of the dashboard and the identification of differentiated districts, districts for differentiated assistance last December.
And then sort of a
feedback loop where we are right now.
In terms of the preparation, we have done, when I say we, this is a global we.
This is in collaboration with State Board staff and department staff and CCE and lots of other people, but have done trainings for more than 200 county office staff in 16, 17, so last year was four days of training concerning the LCAP and the dashboard, so they were
very familiar with all that and comfortable with that.
This year, as you've heard, it was very much focused on improvement science or continuous improvement.
Six days of training for that.
The 200 number is important to us because our obligation, our commitment to the state is we will reach every school district, every part of the state.
It is a statewide implementation strategy.
There are 51 counties that serve multiple school districts, and so we have been very purposeful in making sure we add teams from every one of those counties at these trainings.
So 200 people, more than 200, suggests, and in fact, we could give you the data if you wanted to go into that, but there is a team that's been trained in every county in the state to work with the school districts in that county, so there's consistent approach statewide.
The second part of it, I'm really lucky to present or provide this update after you heard from Riverside, because it is a different kind of model that's taking place.
It's not traditional.
We invite state people to come and present the system.
Most of the material is developed, reviewed, and presented by county office staff or other people working at the local level.
So it's local materials that we then
vet and review with the State Board staff, department staff, and CC, and obviously ourselves.
And sometimes we do ask them to present, but primarily it's the counties like Riverside, Sacramento, San Diego, all those counties that are preparing and sharing information with their colleagues.
We were lucky three years ago to get a grant from the California Education Partners to bring together six counties to start developing tools and assessment protocols to work with their districts on this.
That then expanded to 11.
They then each partnered with a district in their county.
So we've had several years of piloting and refining those, and those have become this resource that was talked about earlier, the facilitator's guide, which is like a compendium of materials that people could use as circumstances require.
And the third thing is the connectedness of it.
So obviously there are those trainings, but it's also been presented to the CISC.
You're familiar now with the Curriculum Instruction Steering Committee, but also our LCAP directors have been presented there.
Tomorrow we're having a meeting of what we call our math community of practice, the math leads from all around the state, and we have a section in that presentation on differentiated assistance.
We'll have Nancy Brownell, who you all well know, and Melanie will be there, Sue Stickle from Sacramento County, now retired, so people coming together to connect that across the system.
On the rollout, the commitment we made to the state, when I say the state, it's really this cross-agency group that Melanie talked about, so the State Board, Department, CC, and CCESA.
The commitment we made is the county superintendents would call the superintendent of each district that had been identified, so they would have, first of all, make sure they know they've been identified.
know what the next steps are, and confirm this commitment that the responsibility of leadership still rests with the school district.
The county role is to be there in partnership and to help, to collaborate, but that the ownership of the plan and these assessments with the district.
So we had 10 days to make those calls.
It was 223 school districts located in 43 county offices of education.
We talked to all 43 of those county superintendents and by 10 days later, every one of those calls had been made, every district superintendent had been contacted individually.
So I think that's pretty impressive outreach in terms of trying to have a fairly smooth implementation.
The feedback we got was very positive in the sense that the phone call
and the commitment to working collaboratively, there was a small minority of those districts that were surprised.
Most of them already knew they were being identified.
The ones that were what I would call surprised was because primarily the student groups of homeless and foster youth.
I was just asked, you know, this is just sort of feedback of how it's working through.
The major concern we heard at that time, and you've had presentations on this already, is because most of these districts have been identified for student disability, how is this going to interface with the department's technical assistance around the disproportionality and program indicator technical assistance?
CC and the department have really stepped up to help provide guidance on that.
We just approved an addendum to our facilitator's guide.
So we're working together, as Mellon indicated, to identify a problem, work together, and try and address it collaboratively.
The final thing on feedback, our commitment to, again, the cross-agency group, is that we would routinely be
cycling through, if you want, the county superintendents to see how things are going, provide feedback to that.
So we have four CSESA staff assigned as liaisons to each of the CSESA regions.
The commitment we made is that the county superintendents, there will be a meeting with the districts, each district, by the end of January.
So we're currently making sure those meetings are taking place, how are those going, so we're collecting feedback.
We will bring that to the cross-agencies group.
We will be working with Melanie and others across agencies to have a formal kind of survey in terms of what are the needs and what are the capacity concerns, because we know that's of interest to everybody in the system.
But we have consciously put in place a feedback system to collect that information in real time.
The concerns we've heard about scheduling those meetings have not been any kind of resistance.
It's been just a juggling of schedules of how many people there are.
But the first of those meetings began to occur in December, and we are convinced they will all be done by the first week in February.
So we asked Ed to join us.
Ed is not only Eldorado County Superintendent, but he is our President-Elect and is very involved in all this work.
So I'd like to turn it over to him and then open up for questions.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Chief Deputy Superintendent Price, and members of the board.
It's good to be here with you.
As I was walking up to the podium, I didn't realize the pressure that would occur following a GIS presentation.
I'm going to do my best.
So there's two things that I would like to just give an overview on.
The first is just a snapshot of how the differentiated assistance has been rolling out, even from December until now.
And providing that overview is very similar to asking a student who is on the second day of school, how's your academic year going?
So we're really early on in the process in the piece that I'm gonna be describing.
Second, I wanna step back and look at the context of work briefly in respect to the county offices from 2013 until now.
So first of all, we received word of which students, or I'm sorry, which districts would be eligible for differentiated assistance in December.
And as was stated, county superintendents made individual calls to those superintendents.
And I want to give you a glimpse
of not only the tone, but the nature of what those discussions look like, even from my perspective.
So there were three district superintendents that I made personal calls to.
I'd say all three were in a position where they were not surprised.
They knew their data specifically around students with disabilities.
But the clarification of the process, even though we took roughly multiple meetings to explain
the difference of the old paradigm to this paradigm prior to those telephone calls, we had still a range of reactions.
So one superintendent articulated both to me and her school community, you know, I sincerely believe this is a great opportunity to dig in, to look at instructional practice and behavioral practices within the districts.
Like again, seizing the ownership and opportunity to do that, which was very positive.
A second superintendent was ready to share the work that they were currently doing, meaning they recognized it was an area of development and were ready to engage.
The third was an interesting response.
Again, even though this was a relatively new superintendent to our county, his response was at the end of the call, Ed, you know, I'm ready for this.
I've gone through program improvement before.
even though we had articulated in formal and informal meetings the difference of the process.
And the point that I'm trying to make is this shift that we're describing is significant internally for our superintendents, leaders, and teachers reacting to this new system that we together have been working on for quite some time.
An initial call is still an initial call, and an initial reaction is an initial reaction.
Second, we had an individual from our county office follow up with the superintendent personally to really give a more in-depth overview of the process.
And while I'm articulating our experiences in Eldorado County, this process was taking place across the state with the other 57 superintendents.
A team was then developed
within the county office in addition to a team that was identified on the district side.
What was interesting to me about one of the recent meetings this week that our team, our county office meeting had with a district team around differentiated assistance was the invitation of a district to bring a parent to their team.
And so the parent said, when we were talking about this process of root cause analysis,
The parent expressed, you know, it's refreshing and I appreciate this process to not rush to a solution, but rather look at this as a thoughtful process to a long-term fix in our community.
This is a parent view in the context of the educational team.
So it's great to see even a community that's embracing this process.
So we have set up five to six meeting times with these three districts.
Kern, I'm sorry, Riverside did an exceptional job today demonstrating what in-depth work looks like with a district.
And so I'm choosing not to give you that in-depth.
overview of what that looks like with our districts but again I'm just going to highlight that and as you know this will conclude with a report that will be coming from each county superintendent.
I want to make it
Clear on the record, President Kearse, we do not see the 58 county superintendents of the county offices that are gonna provide all of the support to all of these districts, and we recognize that.
And we were also aware, as I shift to this second overview, we as county superintendents were aware that from 2013 to now, that this was going to be a significant shift, not only in our role,
but as the new dashboard rolled out.
So let me go back to 2013, and I'm just going to give you some points to give you an overview of how we've been preparing for this.
So even though I am in my first term as a county superintendent, and there are 58 total, here's what's interesting to take note.
Since, if you look at the 58 county superintendents, 43 of the county superintendents are either in their first term or second term.
So in the rollout of this new system, we have embraced this process.
There are a good number of strong instructional leaders that are present as county superintendents who have lived the old accountability process and are embracing this new process.
So just one point I wanna acknowledge.
Early on, we recognized that CCEE was going to be playing a pivotal role.
We wanted, in this case, Eldorado County wanted to leverage our current structures of collaboration to start introducing these changes that were taking place.
Obviously, LCFF, the local control accountability plans.
We had CCEE come in even two years ago to start talking about the work.
As a county superintendent, and then I know many other county superintendents, we're having one-on-one meetings with district superintendents, really getting a pulse of what their needs were.
Again, this is all acknowledging the importance of that issue of trust as we move into this change and relationship.
As we speak, we weren't highlighted on the GIS map as a learning network because we would fall under that informal category.
But right now, if we were to put a new color on there,
you would see all 15 of our districts meeting this moment in a rural professional learning network focusing on math instruction.
And what I'm pointing to is leveraging all of the current structures to support building capacity in this midst of change.
So while I'm describing the view of the changes that have been taking place from 2013 till now, or I'm speaking to the unfolding of this new model even in these first few months, next week I look forward to meeting with all of our county superintendents at CCESA and we meet, as you know, on a quarterly basis.
And that is our opportunity to continue to share about the best practices that are taking place and the challenges.
And we're very appreciative.
of not only the opportunity that is before us, but the partnership that we have with you, CDE, CCEE, and all of our other partnership agencies throughout California.
Thank you.
Okay, questions?
Do you want to take questions now for this group?
Yeah, do we have Mary Ann Dewan?
Oh, she's probably going to do special ed.
Yeah.
Yeah, there is a question for the two of these persons here.
Board member Burr.
Well, I just wanted to express my appreciation to Peter and to Ed for being here, because I think it does help kind of build out the statewide county work that we heard about with Riverside.
So thank you for that.
I do also, though, want to just clarify one thing about county superintendents and their role in this work.
There is a statutory role for county superintendents on behalf of the state.
They are our agents.
They have constitutional authority, et cetera.
really in our, we used to call this years ago, our arms and legs in the field to actually do the work and to let the state be assured that the work is going forward and that they are touching every district, just as Ed eloquently described.
So I just want that to be clear because I do hear feedback from LEAs who say, what if I don't want to work with my county superintendent?
which I think we have to clarify that, that A, that's a relationship issue that needs to be addressed, which I know the counties are working hard on and I expect the LEAs are working hard as well.
But it doesn't preclude LEAs from working with other providers if there's specific expertise they need or the counties can't do it.
But the initial touch does have to be by county superintendents.
So just wanted to be clear about that.
Because I do think there's an expectation on the part of some providers, which you addressed, Mike, that we, either the State Board or we get this at the CCEE, are going to create lists again of providers, like our favorite SES providers.
Exactly.
And at least my intention at the CCEE, and I think everybody who works at the CCEE is
has the same attitude, we're not going to create lists of providers.
We're helping LEAs build capacity and making their own determinations about who they would be working with.
So just wanted to clarify that because it does come up periodically.
Okay, no further questions.
Thank you.
All right, go ahead, sorry.
Kristen Wright, Special Education Division.
I am here with the Coalition of Christens.
This is Kristen Brooks.
She does a project with us with Santa Clara County office of education and back to Ed's comments about Leveraging we are leveraging and aligning from the special ed division you can I'm sure read attachment 3 which sort of describes some of the work that we're doing around
changing our infrastructure internally to be more poised to assist LEAs in a more strategic manner, in a more focused manner, in a more transparent manner, and one that really involves our stakeholders in every monitoring practice that we do.
So my staff is in the process, as we speak, of completely reorganizing and changing up units.
Again, you can read about that more, and we'll describe that more in our next item in March.
We are expanding and updating all of our contracts to be aligned to the successor regions, to the state priorities, so everything that we're doing is in the same vein and will look very familiar to LEAs as they're seeking specific resources related to students with disabilities and specialization in that.
We are also working closely with CCEE.
We are having weekly calls and working with the Special Education Collective, which includes our partners with SELPA and CSESA, and our other key strategic partners to make sure that we are all aligned as a state.
It's very exciting work.
We're working to complement each other and not duplicate each other.
And expanding existing projects.
So I've asked Kristen to come and just share a little bit about what she's and her project is doing to support LEAs, particularly around supporting increasing access to the general education environment.
And I think that's of interest based on some of the earlier statistics you saw this morning.
So I'm pleased to introduce her to you, and then we'll let you go to lunch.
So thank you.
Go ahead and talk amongst yourselves as I find this.
Yeah, I just wanted to say, you know, you got the thing on the lunches.
Go for it.
You all can see that, right?
Great, excellent.
All right, good afternoon.
Hi, my name is Kristen Brooks.
I'm a director with the Santa Clara County Office of Education and I'm in charge of the Supporting Inclusive Practices Project.
So I'm very honored to be able to share some information with you about the good work that we are doing right there in the trenches.
So I'm really hoping that this will piggyback off of everything that you've heard today as we kind of talk macro and drill down to micro and what that really means for each and every child each and every day.
So thank you.
So the project focus really is around technical assistance for indicators three assessments, five and six which you've heard about earlier today, least restrictive environment for students ages three to five and then six to 21.
And really we're targeting three areas.
So when we talk about what are those barriers to inclusion or what things do we need to beef up when we're talking about systemic and systematic change, three things really stand out.
One being education policy to practice.
So are we looking at our vision and mission statements?
Are we looking at how we are running our IEP meetings?
How we're structuring our supports within our schools?
And are our practices mirroring what our policies are?
Also universal design for learning.
Are we designing our lessons to meet all marginalized learners?
and really reach the ends as we know through UDL that there is no average learner.
And so we don't want to continue to design lessons for this student and this student and this student, but really for all students to have equity and access regardless of their abilities and skills.
And then professional learning communities.
You heard earlier about silos, and we really want to bring the general ed and special ed worlds together and really bring everyone to the table about students.
These aren't your students and my students.
These are our students.
So those are really three main focal points of the project.
project.
These are the list of our grantees.
So each of these districts are unique in that some of our folks are kind of those exemplar sites who've been identified that their LRE numbers are already at or above the state benchmarks, whereas the other individual districts may be receiving support toward improvement efforts.
So some have joined this year.
We brought on nine new districts this year.
Some have been participating the last couple of years.
So they're at different stages in that improvement plan process, which you can see who's been identified here.
So these grantees reach anywhere from Siskiyou, way up north, all the way down to Imperial County.
So we span the whole state.
And these are some of the providers.
So this supporting inclusive practices has evolved over time.
It used to be that we had facilitators who would kind of deploy out to the districts and improvement plan process, and those would be individual people to provide that support.
But we really learned that districts learn from districts.
And so what we wanted to do was provide more like hubs throughout the state.
So each of the districts and partner agencies that you see here bring a specialty.
And so it might be Chime Charter in Woodland Hills, who has a 99.9% inclusion rate for students with and without disabilities, and spanning all the way to our most significantly impaired students.
It might be Pleasanton, who just opened an inclusive preschool program.
It might be Sanger, a PLC and RTI district.
So everybody kind of brings something unique.
And so what we've done is take our grantees and arrange them demographically and assign them, quote, to these providers.
But that doesn't mean that's who they have to receive that technical assistance from.
They can receive supports from any one of our partners.
It's just who is your kind of one contact that is demographically at least close to your area.
This year we also have two university partners or institutions of higher education, University of Redlands and San Francisco State University.
and their role has been extensive in that San Francisco State has helped develop a teacher survey, so we're doing a pre and a post survey about perceptions around inclusion and what supports teachers there in the classrooms are needing.
We have the University of Redlands who has been partnering also with Digicoach, a company that has a data
using in our classrooms so we're looking at the data around that.
A lot around the policy practice and also helping with our logic model within this project so all of these different partners have been really instrumental in the work that we're doing to increase achievement and inclusion for our students.
with disabilities.
And I know this is specific to students with disabilities, but at least every time I meet with our teams, meet with our districts, I'm really focusing in on we're talking about all kids.
Yes, this is a special ed division, you know, kind of promoted and supported project, but we're talking about all kids.
So that's key to this work.
This is a little quick snapshot of our logic model.
If you guys are familiar with logic models, you start with your inputs, your activities, and then your outputs and what you expect your outcomes to be.
So our inputs being those different partnerships with the California Department of Ed, with the different universities, with those exemplar districts who are providing those supports, as well as I mentioned our DigiCoach, kind of our community providers who help us with some of that data collection.
We do have pallet walls, information and resources that we share kind of virtually that way.
In terms of activities, a couple of different institutes that we provide, one is the fall and we held that at the University of Redlands.
That was a chance for representatives from these grantees to come together and talk about what are the goals of the program, where do we want to head, what is this logic model, what are the deliverables under this project.
And so then we also had presentations around UDL and policy to practice and PLCs just like we talked about our focus So it's all aligned We're gonna have the next Institute which will be in the spring April 24th at San Francisco State and that'll be more of a coming back together again Around what was our progress?
What did our data look like over this involvement this past year?
what do we need going forward and then really focusing on that sustainability piece and
and some of the work around Patrick Lencioni's ideal team player, where each of us brings something unique to the table, and how do we then continue this forward momentum that we've started.
We also take the districts through a root cause analysis and action planning.
And so this isn't a kit, this isn't a, you know, this is how you do inclusion, or this is how you increase your assessments.
It's what do you need in your district based on your population, your culture, and your community?
How can we establish those relationships?
And what can we bring to you to help support you in the space that you're in?
And so that root cause analysis, although guided by documents Colorado uses, Dean Gano's work, it's really specific to those individual districts and the perception data, the demographic data, the achievement data, the LRE data, all that, the deeper dive that we need to do, but it's done
on an individual basis for those folks.
And same thing with the action plan.
Those outcomes of that root cause analysis, some districts, as I mentioned, have been participating in this for a couple of years, while others are just on board.
And so we don't expect everybody to be at the same place at the same time.
We just want to get off the hamster wheel and move forward.
Other things, we have biweekly classroom walkthroughs using this classroom walkthrough tool through DigiCoach and that really is kind of a Likert scale of what are we seeing in terms of evidence-based practices happening in the classroom and how might that look different for a quote exemplar site versus a quote improvement site.
How can we leverage some support to bring everybody you know kind of
all boats rising together.
And so we're doing walkthroughs.
And really, that template is around UDL.
There's a very heavy emphasis on UDL to see if we're seeing evidence of action expression and multiple means of representation and engagement and those sorts of things.
And then ongoing technical assistance.
So again, what do you need?
What do you need, Palm Springs?
Is it different from what you need in Harupa?
Is it different from what you need in Wairika?
And so we're trying to deploy that on a very ground level.
And then you can just see, as you zoom in a little bit more closely, what those short-term and long-term outcomes are.
But really it's around increasing achievement, increasing LRE, and also perceptions, and making a shift in what we've been doing in the past and how we need to do it differently going forward.
But there's a very heavy emphasis on that relationship base.
You know, you can't just go in from a compliance lens and say, you know, here are our numbers and we're comparing it to what they're doing in Boston.
and we are completely off the mark.
It's like, no, no, no.
We come in and say, the compliance piece is there.
We know we need to do better than what we're doing today, but let's do this together, not with the hammer, but with the heart.
I know that sounds very lofty, but it's real, right?
When you're in a room and you have to talk about those hard numbers and that data that some people don't want to look at because it's been in their faces for a long time now, and they're not surprised by those phone calls.
But guess what?
We still have to look at it, and we still have to do something about it and hold hands together and say, we're not going back.
So it's about that relationship piece.
So these are some of the deliverables that I talked about, just kind of a visual representation, but the root cause analysis, the action plan.
We have webinars throughout the year around those topics that the districts are coming back and saying we need support with.
So whether it's UDL, and we had Katie Novak in September, if it's behavior, we had Dr. John Pelletieri in November.
We have one in February on PLCs with Mike Meadows from Solution Tree.
So what are we hearing that our districts need, but also what have we been seeing over time as a focus for this work?
Again, the institutes, the two institutions of higher ed, so all of these kind of supports within those deliverables.
And then the project focus being progress monitoring, continuous improvement, and in a phase.
So start with your vision, your mission, your values, and your goals.
Get your leadership team together.
bring a general ed rep, a special ed rep, an administrator, a parent, a student, you know, bring your teams together to do the work that is messy but that needs to be done for our kids.
Invite those stakeholders, develop those action plans, adopt those action plans.
We know through
the work of Everett Rogers decades ago, that there is kind of that curve about adoption.
We have those early adopters that are really, really on board, and then we have those laggards that are just kind of waiting to see, is this stuff really going to work, or is this the shiny object that everybody's looking at right now?
So we want to work people through those processes to make sure that we're creating real change, and that this isn't something that's going to go away.
So that's it.
Was that fast enough?
All these presentations?
So I know you guys are getting hungry.
So contact information, and I'll step back.
Thank you.
So I hope this was a good little snippet of some of the work that we've been doing in the division and that we hope to do a great deal more of.
And so our goal is to provide our LEAs that are in differentiated assistance another option through the special ed division should that be the road that they choose to go down.
And so we hope to clone and scale Kristen and her project as well as other projects that are similar that are doing really great things for kids.
So let me just thank Kristen and all of the presentations are really building from Melanie's and laying out the whole picture about how all the pieces are starting to cover our entire state in a differentiated way across.
I'm interested in the, and we've had, every presentation has helped build on the other and I think gives us hope into the future.
I'm interested in the collaboration with the cross agencies, particularly the role, I know you spoke about the collaborative and I see Josh in the,
I hate to have him come without having any opportunity to share anything.
I'm just interested in how you're collaborating with him.
I know people have been saying their role is developing.
What's their role?
How are they working to help you?
So I wonder if you could share that and maybe have him.
How have we been doing that?
We are taking a closer look at what the needs of those differentiated assistance districts are.
Clearly, there is a very large number that are special ed.
Basically, starting with what are we currently doing, what do we need to shift a little, where do we need more partnership to scale?
I think everyone at the table in the SPED Collective, which includes all the partners, everyone brings a unique piece to help us do that work.
At our core, the department is responsible for
compliance and monitoring.
That's where, that's the core of our work.
So it's helpful to have other entities come in that are working and talking to districts in a different way.
We are working towards coaching to compliance rather than, you know, the hammer that we've talked about before.
But we're still, we still are in that role as a state, that at the end, if someone isn't meeting their requirements, we do have to take some kind of action.
That's a very different role than someone coaching and holding your hand in a different way.
So I think
The complementary relationship with CCESA doing a lot of the regional, with CCEE being able to bring in more of the thought partnering, and we're looking forward to some deeper dives around the data and doing some correlations around our underbelly data, which I think will really help to inform the conversation and offer folks a way to talk about the data that doesn't become divisive.
So, I don't know if that answers your question, but I would say we continue to meet and talk about what each of us are doing in our assigned roles to make sure that we're complementing each other.
So, we will have more specifics at the March meeting when we talk about our state systemic improvement plan, which will give you more, I think, nuts and bolts that you're looking for.
Are you all comfortable?
Josh, do you want to add anything since you're here?
Good morning, thank you, Board Member Strauss.
Josh Daniels, Director of Training and Outreach for the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
Just very quickly, I'll mention two things related to the collective work that we're doing with CDE around students with disabilities.
We have a governing board meeting scheduled for February 1st, and we're bringing forward two items for board approval.
One, a position specific to the work of special ed.
and also some contracts with special ed experts that we're working with around the data analysis and sort of developing the statewide system of support, particularly for those 163 school districts that have been identified because of students with disabilities.
And I'm happy to answer anything else, but specifically that's two things we are working on.
I want to unpack this system of support a little bit more because, you know, as I was reading some of the letters and listening to some of the comments, when there is limited capacity, limited resources, there is an accelerated race to the margin, right?
Who is the most marginalized in the system?
And we have many student subgroups that could really claim that.
And so I think that one of the concerns that has been expressed, and I know that Ting Sun spoke a little bit about how this system would be more comprehensive and not just look at one student group or one indicator, but be more comprehensive in its analysis.
And I really want us to discuss that publicly because I truly believe these are all our students.
And I've said that for English learners, for our ethnic student groups, for our students with disabilities.
These are our students.
We need to own them.
We need to own their outcomes and move towards improving upon.
But I also know that we can't oversimplify what that means.
you know, I don't want to default into we're all human argument.
Yes, we're all human, but my experience is very different than your experience and your experience because of who I am as this human being.
And so when we're looking at our students with disabilities, there has to be, we need to address their abilities.
We need to address their needs.
First and foremost, that is who, what is their need?
If, you know, I went into a school once and asked,
how many of your students are ELs?
And they said, we treat all our students as if they were gifted.
Well, that's great, except gifted students also have language needs.
And so what are you doing to address their language needs, right?
So I want us to really emphasize what that means when we're looking at the one student group that triggered the identification for most of our LEAs, but understand that there are needs according to abilities.
And then that student could be of an ethnic racial background, low income, English learner.
And so it's a very multidimensional person and student.
So when we're looking at our systems of support, how are we going to make sure that we're addressing their needs,
by their ability level.
And then we're also looking at the majority of these students are Latino, just like the majority of our students in California.
You know, there's a good number of them that are English learners.
So how are we making sure that we're addressing the needs of students beyond their ability level so that the rest of the folks here that are thinking,
If you look at African-American students, there's a lot of needs there, and they may not be captured under this group, but we need to address their needs, and we need to address the needs of English learners, and we need to address the needs of Latino students.
How are we going to do that?
Because we have limited capacity, limited resources, but great need out there, and we don't want to pit subgroups against each other.
I think you make a great point.
Could not agree more in terms of that coordination.
And so it starts with thinking about students and what students need to be supported.
And I think it goes back to some of the things that Kristen Brooks was talking about around how you design classrooms and schools in a universal manner.
So you're starting off making them the most accessible universes in tier one that you can.
And then you're recognizing that many of them have all kinds of different needs at tier two, tier three, and then within the special education sort of
through the tiers.
So one of the things that we've been doing, and Melanie can speak with this too, is really looking at how the system overall, so our fiefdom is the state system, what can we do at the state level to start integrating all of those particular student groups and areas where currently we've all been doing our own work?
So as a state, we have to take the lead in saying, we need to be talking about our students and how we're going to gather around them with those supports and services, whatever they may need.
Now for students with disabilities, the IEP is a great vehicle because it allows us to ask those questions.
So the most important piece about that, if we're just talking about students with disabilities, and I know we're talking about all students as well,
is that we have the right people at the table when we're at IEP meetings.
So it means IEP meetings are not just the special ed teacher and the parent and the principal, but it includes your EL specialist or anyone else that may need to be participating in that student's education to ensure that those supports are wrapped around that student.
There's a baseline, but there's nothing that's precluding us from having all the right people at the table.
So your point is well taken, and I don't know if you have anything else to add, Mel.
The only, Melanie Sheppy, the only other thing I would add is that it's very important to continue to reiterate that publicly in all of our messaging.
So I know in talking about students with disabilities and how they cross over with different other student groups, I've made sure that's in my messaging in the presentations or discussions that I've had.
I've seen staff from the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence also talking about that intersectionality and seeing people in those discussions or those stakeholder sessions
say, oh, I'm going to need help to understand that for my own population.
And then in a specific instance, we've connected at the next curriculum and instruction steering committee for SSESA, we've connected those county representatives with two staff from CDE
one specializing in students who are homeless and one specializing in students who are foster youth, to connect county staff with the right understandings about how to understand that data.
So I think it's, A, publicly always reinforcing it, because to make our shifts real, we all have to say it in different contexts.
So I think just your question in bringing that up is what we need to do.
But then also concretely,
make sure that local educators and communities know how to look at the intersectionality of their data.
And as they're doing data analysis, make sure our message is not, oh, you're identified for this specific piece, then that's what you're looking at.
And I don't think I've ever heard that message come across, but then I think it's in
reflecting on how the work is going to make sure that doesn't happen.
Because we can make sure we have the right messages and we have the right intentions, but it's then circling back in February, reflecting with the counties, how is the work going?
Are you having districts that are resistant to looking at data beyond those student groups?
Do you have excellent examples where you're able to really look at all student groups across all indicators and then drill down?
And I know that's one of the reasons the LCAP Director Network was set up, so that counties could talk in regions and then with each other about struggles and successes.
And I think this is a perfect thing that should be top of mind, especially as counties and districts are looking at the data together of, okay, well, how was that data analysis?
Were you able to go deep?
Or did you get stuck?
And if you got stuck, well, let's go back to the table.
So I think that's a great question, something we need to reflect on as the work continues.
In light of that, thinking about the data and knowing that we have students who transcend across multiple student groups, how do districts organize that?
What are the resources that they have?
I mean, they have their own SISs where I guess they could pull and they could see, but I think bringing that to light and really looking at it really helps them sort the data and get down to
You know student groups that really need tremendous attention, but also are in four or five different student groups.
I just think that that organization or the The help that districts might need and in building those lists I mean it sounds simple, but it really would help them be more strategic and streamlined absolutely and that's why we've been trying to make sure we connect the right staff that understands how to
succinctly and clearly pull that data from different information systems connected with counties and districts.
So I know Jenny Singh has done a lot of work with counties in helping them navigate the data and how would they pull it together and then with their work with districts, districts reach out directly.
So I think making sure it's clear that if you have that need, ask for it.
And
We need to make sure either through your county support, if you have a county that's able to really support you in the data analysis, or direct CDE support.
I know also, mentioned a little bit earlier, California Collaborative for Educational Excellence is doing the data and evaluation webinar.
You know, someone might go to that, but then have a specific need about the system that they have and how to work it.
So I think we need to make sure that we're talking about it and making sure that when someone says, hey, I don't know how to pull this from Aries or whatever my system is, that we're there to support them and make sure that that's something that you can ask for, you should ask for, because you're not going to be able to understand your data if you can't really understand the different intersectionalities of your students.
And in addition to that, we've already started planning on a rollout of data boot camps related to the special ed data, because I know that is also an area that LEAs are feeling like they need some support in.
So not only can they at any time contact us and the folks that are assigned to their regions and speak directly with Shiloh if they need to, but we will be rolling out a series of regionalized events to be able to support that effort as well.
And Kristen, will you be sharing that information more with us in March at our next meeting about what the steps are?
Yes, we will.
Great, thanks.
That's not a question.
I really appreciate my colleagues questions are great questions.
And thank you for the presentations.
And I just want to acknowledge the leadership of Director Wright.
She's just the perfect person at the right time.
And with the restructuring that's happening, too, I think this cross disciplinary work has already been happening.
And so I'm just encouraged to see that it's there's a more formal restructuring that will enable that to happen.
And then also the Advisory Commission on Special Education, led by Gina Plate, really has been involved in this work for so long, and it's just great to see it happening.
And again, commissioners who are working in a cross-disciplinary way already to inform this work, and that really helps leverage resources and expertise, and aligns our system, and makes it more coherent, so thank you.
Oh, I also want to say that the governor's budget includes a hundred million dollars for increasing the supply of teachers in special education.
Fifty million dollars for a new teacher training program called for teacher residencies that has a lot of promise for creating teachers that will stay with districts a fairly long period of time.
and $50 million going to local districts to enhance their ability to attract and retain special education teachers.
So, you know, if this is approved by the legislature, I think in a number of ways, we're really on the move on special education, including today.
And I think it's a very heartening movement.
Any further questions?
If not, then we're ready for public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Sheila Whitley, Mish Cabal, Gina Plate, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Brian Rivas, Jim Anderson, and John Affeld.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and I'm representing Californians Together and the California Association for Bilingual Education.
First I would like to commend staff for the very hard work in addressing the issue of assistance and support to our LEAs.
I would like to bring to your attention a significant concern that we have regarding the new calculations of the performance levels approved by the State Board on November 2017.
We now have a completely different picture of the performance level for ELs on the academic indicator.
Over 64% of districts with the 2017 data are now orange and red compared to 60% last year when they were primarily yellow and some green and some blue.
The letter that's being distributed to you has three questions on page two that we would like for you to take a look at and consider.
Most importantly, we would like to see what will happen with regards to whether districts will attend to this data.
We recommend that the State Board of Education direct CESSA staff to take steps in addressing this issue.
Thank you.
Hi there, thank you for the opportunity for letting me speak.
My name is Mishka Ball and I'm a site organizer for Youth Together and I'm here to talk about how districts can better engage stakeholders.
For us, as people who engage with youth often, as I mean all we do is community organizing with our youth,
Authentic and meaningful engagement means requiring more than just youth and parent presence, but their perspective and critical feedback regarding issues that directly impact them.
It also means long-term relationship building with community members who are also fighting locally to make sure that resources are being distributed equitably.
Because there are limited opportunities to critically engage our youth and parents due to lack of advertisement of crucial meetings or even decision-making meetings that are closed, our youth have taken it upon themselves to collect data through our listening campaign to provide more student voice around their needs.
Data can be in the form of narratives and lived experiences.
And it is both the state's and district's responsibility to want to include, fund, and advocate for the voices most often silenced in these conversations and to develop more community relevant solutions.
Thank you.
Good morning again, President Kirst and Chief Deputy Price and Board Members.
My name is Gina Plait, again, Chair of the Advisory Commission on Special Ed.
Thank you, Board Member Sandoval, for your comments about the commission.
We have been very excited about engaging in this process.
And, you know, we knew that the recommendations that came out of the task force would be a very heavy lift.
But what we're seeing coming to fruition, I think, is even beyond what we expected.
And we heard about the recommendations in the budget that we're very, very excited and optimistic about.
The collaboration that Melanie and Kristen and the other presenters today described and what you saw modeled today, the way that we're operationalizing our commitment to each and every child, in my experience, my career here, it is unprecedented and it's really exciting to see the commitment going forward.
So we've made significant progress, but I will continue to highlight that we still have much work to do.
And while this is not an action item in front of you, I ask that you continue to shine the light in this area, continue to hold the field accountable for what we are doing for all kids.
So I pledge the continued support of the commission and thank you.
Jim Anderson, current chair of the SELPA Administrators Association of California and also the SELPA director for the Los Angeles County Court School SELPA and Los Angeles County Charter SELPA.
SELPAs reflect a range in diversity and resources and we've heard that here today about county offices and LEAs across the state.
Leveraging existing resources across all systems is critical.
As an association, we are working to increase member SELPA capacity to collaborate and align the existing work around their LEA members LCAPs
the areas of need highlighted by the dashboard for students with disabilities.
There's plenty of work to do.
SELPAs are prepared and engaged as a critical member within the statewide system of support to do this work.
The association appreciates the work of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence Collective that was mentioned, including SELPAs, County Office of Education, California Department of Education, and other partners.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members, John Affeldt from Public Advocates and on behalf of the Equity Coalition.
Two things.
One, appreciate the call out to involving community stakeholders in the continuous improvement process, but I think we need to have the state board and the cross agencies be much tighter in making sure this happens.
For example, the facilitator's guide, pretty good guide, allows it to be optional to include community stakeholders in the root cause analysis.
This is a non-negotiable.
Community stakeholders need to be part and parcel of the analysis and the decision-making of the root cause and how the district's going to move forward.
Secondly, ACSA, we understand, is taking the position that districts don't have to change anything in response to the differentiated assistance conversation because they're in a three-year fixed LCAP plan.
That makes a mockery of continuous improvement.
If we've identified problems on specific groups, districts need to be able to modify their LCAPs, have to, in order to move forward.
So we need some more guidance on that.
Thanks.
Sheila Whitley speaking for California Teachers Association.
CTA is disappointed that there was no opportunity to provide public comment on the revised ESSA plan this time.
We've had an opportunity.
That's the wrong item.
That's the next item.
The ESSA plan is the next item.
This is the system of support.
Sorry.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis, Executive Director of Teach Plus.
We were encouraged to hear Melanie talking about moving from principles to more concrete action, and like the Equity Coalition highlighted, one of the areas where we feel like there needs to be more clear articulation of what steps and action is on the role of stakeholders
in this process, and particularly, our teachers are most interested in the role of teachers.
Specifically, if you want to have sustainable, comprehensive change in a school, they have to be central to that process.
And so, we would encourage the board and the cross-agency to think about what are the steps, whether it's training on needs assessment, or what are the levers for the state to ensure that this is happening in a meaningful way and that teachers are at the center of this continuous improvement and this change.
President Kirsten, Brian Reeves speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
I want to agree with my colleague, Mr. Affeldt, on the point he made about meaningful engagement.
I think we'd like to see greater assurance that communities and the public will have an opportunity.
Well, one, we think they need to know when an LEA, their LEA is identified for
And two, we think they deserve an opportunity to play a role in the discussion around how the LEA is helped once identified.
And we think that the root cause analysis will be enhanced by the inclusion of the public
Secondly, I was pleased to hear the discussion around the way assistance is provided in the context of a particular group.
We think it would be a mistake to focus narrowly on a particular subgroup.
I think we're in the same page with regard to the need for a broader systemic analysis that looks at how the school is doing for everyone.
And that will be the most meaningful way to actually get at the improvement that's needed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Ephraim Mercado from Children Now.
I'd like to highlight our letter that we sent to you guys and also say that between the state board items, the cross agency group expanding their participation groups, as well as the January budget, we think that the system is on a very promising trajectory to really have an impact in our state.
All that said, we have some questions within our letter that we still want to discuss with State Board and CDE and the key groups, but also feel that the best path forward for equity across our state and for closing the achievement gaps will be through the robust articulation of what level one supports really are and how districts receive them, whether that's different for a large district that can do it themselves, medium to small that need more support, what that looks like will be very key, and we look forward to partnering with you guys in the future on this.
Thank you.
OK, that concludes the public comment.
Board member Ortiz will comment.
Several of the speakers asked about the root cause analysis and the role of stakeholders.
So I'm wondering if somebody could describe that process.
The other comment was around the LCAP template and I think that was mentioned earlier on.
It is a living document.
It is intended to be updated based on new data.
So I think that question has been answered during item one.
But if you could address the root cause analysis and the role that stakeholders play in this optional
an optional role that stakeholders like teachers, parents, and others would play.
Absolutely.
Melanie Sheppy.
I think what's so important is I'm glad that people are asking about this.
The fact that if someone had a concern that stakeholders wouldn't be involved, that they have a place to ask.
And we actually, we being the different state agencies, got an email a few days ago from an advocacy group wondering the same question.
And we were able to create some talking points around stakeholder engagement so that it's very clear
The improvement work that you do when you're eligible for differentiated assistance should show up in your LCAP, which means it should be part of your LCAP process.
Part of an LCAP process is stakeholder engagement, not only in selection of actions and services, but in setting goals and understanding your needs and what's underneath your student outcomes, both qualitative and the indicators on the dashboard, but also your local data.
I think there's this very specific point of, well, what about that, those initial data, analyzing data between counties and districts?
Is there a policy that you have to have the specific representation?
And what we're saying is your stakeholders have to be involved in your LCAP process, and your LCAP and your LCAP process have to reflect your improvement work.
And the mechanics of those initial data analysis meetings
There's no absolute process of who has to be involved.
So some counties have had several data and are starting kind of a series of data analysis meetings.
First, it's between the district leadership team and the county leadership team, and then the subsequent meeting is between the county team and the district team and community stakeholder groups and teachers and principals.
Other counties kind of started, I think you heard Ed Manansala, they started with the first initial data analysis sessions or meetings with community groups there at the table.
So I think the actual mechanics and breakdown of that data analysis and the support counties are giving will look different in each context, but your improvement work needs to show up in your LCAP.
It needs to be part of your LCAP process, which is dependent on stakeholder engagement.
And so we're working on some talking points to make sure that's something we can send out through all the advocacy groups and all the state agencies so we're having the same message.
But I'm really glad people feel comfortable enough to bring that up so that we can address it.
Board member Sun.
So what you just said makes absolute sense and it's aligned with the purpose of the LCAP.
How will stakeholders know if a school or district has been identified for support?
Well, I think that will also come across in a variety of ways.
So it might be a part of the LCAP process and discussion of the data and how a district sharing the support they're getting from their county with stakeholders.
There's also a posted list of all of the assistance status.
So if you go on the accountability web page and then also the local control funding web page, there's an Excel spreadsheet that has every district of California.
and if they have general assistance or differentiated assistance.
And then if it is differentiated assistance, the student group, how they were identified.
So that's an additional place if someone wants to find the information on their own, but is for some reason not getting it somewhere else.
So I do think that it would be a high expectation to have parents who may not be familiar with the information to look at their specific school or district information LEA and then go to a different website to try to find that identification.
Are we looking at maybe the districts or LEAs self-identifying in their LCAPs, a place where it says, hey, these are the schools that have been identified or we've been identified in some way or on the dashboard or any of that?
That's a good question.
And I think what we can also do is ask counties and districts how that has unfolded.
So what are some of the best practices in how districts are engaging with their differentiated assistance eligibility and that specific piece with their community?
And then we can make sure we publicize those and we get those out to all districts so they know, here's some best practices of how to actually engage with this eligibility for differentiated assistance.
But as far as I know right now, there's no specific prompt where a district would say,
I was eligible for differentiated assistance.
So what I heard was a second from Ting Sun to add that to the dashboard.
Because I know that it was part of the memos, December one of the memos identified the districts.
And it's an Excel sheet with a host of cells.
And I was trying to compare that to a legend to see what subgroups prompted the identification.
And then it was like general support, what's the other level?
Differentiate it.
And of course, I'm trying to just get a list with differentiate it just to minimize it.
So I'm sitting there deleting the general support.
It was a lot of work.
And I'm kind of in this, right?
And so I'm looking at different things to try to figure out, well, what is this telling me?
And then, of course, we received more simplified versions of it.
But the point is that you do have to visit several places and you would have to know as a parent off the street that there is this memo on this website that would tell you if your district has been identified.
So I think that we need to really be transparent and simplify that and assume that the rest of the world does not tune into these meetings and may know what we know.
I think that's also a place where the GIS mapping would be helpful because when I saw it visually, it just kind of opened up a lot for me.
So I think making sure that we work towards having that be something that's accessible and public could also address this.
So I appreciate Melanie, when you started today, saying I'm going to recapture for you from July and September and November, and that this is a project that is developing over time.
And so I feel like questions I even had yesterday before the meeting are starting to be more clarified about what our plans are.
And I know the staff and the collaborative partners are planning more updates in March, and we'll have more specifics in March.
With that, there were some clarifying questions and comments from our stakeholders who did public comment, and we had followed up with staff.
I just want to clarify directions and updates.
We are continuing to put new data on our dashboard.
My understanding is that the governor's budget has some money in it, and there will be stakeholder input to look at continued improvements in the dashboard.
That's correct, right?
So information to make it more linked and
what is on it, we're gonna continue to hear about that.
So that's one that I think we're getting better at this.
Two, that as we put more data, like we know EL and we know college and career is coming up next year, there'll be additional data provided.
And it's my understanding as a board member and has been part of this process, that the legislation requires that districts use the data to do updates.
That's why there's an annual update.
And there seems to be a misconception that I do a three-year plan, not by a lot of people, I think, I'm not sure.
I just want to clarify from the understanding from CDE, who we hear does lots of monitoring compliance as well as leadership in going forward on new ideas, that this is an expectation that we have that people will use current data to update their plans, inform their practices, and that it's the county office's role to make sure that that is being done.
Is that true?
Absolutely, that's correct.
Okay.
And that we will see more next steps in our March meeting about how this will develop as more.
And then, and when will the state, do we know when the stakeholder input sessions on the dashboard, are they starting soon?
I'm not sure.
I think, I don't think we, I want to make, I want to make sure we don't get ahead of the budget, but I know that when those get planned and all that plan that I'm sure Cindy would then present that and also get your feedback on it.
Okay.
Thank you.
Board member Rucker.
Well, I want to again thank all of the folks who made the journey to come and make the presentations and talk to us about what is going on with the rollout and development of the systems of support for education across the state.
In the good old, bad old days of accountability, there used to be this very expensive mandate that the state had to require districts to annually send letters to parents about the status of their school in the district and all of the work that that status actually meant.
And they had to send all of these, it was an avalanche of paper and of notices that went home to parents that while the effort was to create this, to remove or push aside the curtains so that it created great transparency, it actually did more to obliterate the works than it did to actually create some form or sense of engagement for parents.
So what I'm hearing is two things.
There's two sides of this conversation, and I'm hearing two things in this conversation.
It's like we're sitting at a bargaining table.
So on one side of the table is the school and the school officials saying, here are all the things we're doing, here are all the ways we are engaging, and here is all the deep levels of work that's currently going on.
And on the other side of the table, there are stakeholders who are saying, we are not engaged.
And so I'm touched by what the superintendent from Weaver said about defining the why and defining what it means to have met the standard.
I think that we're still having a conversation about engagement and about whether or not engagement is happening.
because engagement looks different depending on which side of the table you're on.
For the bureaucracy who thought it was a great idea to make districts send out letters and all kind of notifications to parents, there was a belief that that was actually creating transparency and getting parents engaged and involved because if you get a letter, that should make you curious and want you to be involved.
But stakeholders are talking about a different type of engagement.
And so I think maybe while the guidance from CCESA and all of the agencies and the conversations you're having about the work is clear, I think the takeaway from today's conversation is we're not saying you're not talking to us.
But I think there's a need to look at the preposition that's being used.
Because I really did hear people say, we're talking to people.
But there's a difference between talking to people and speaking with people.
And I believe what I'm hearing is we need to not only look at our action verbs, but we need to understand our actions.
And so the stakeholder engagement conversation is about not whether or not conversations are happening, but how the conversations are being both facilitated and conducted in ways that are meaningful to both sides of the table.
So that's the first takeaway.
The second takeaway is the continuing surprise that people still have about what should be going on with the LCAP and with the continuous review, monitoring, and editing and revising process.
The fact that, again, we really do have some people who believe
that once the LCAP has been approved by the county office, that approval means something, and in some ways, it seems like a finite process.
Despite our continuing effort to show that this is a circular, continuous, cyclical process, some people still think this is linear and that there's an endpoint, and that endpoint is with the approval of the plan.
I think a lot of that goes back to what my colleagues on the board have talked about,
on putting the local and local control.
It does require, again, not only the actions of the leadership, but a clear process so that people who are involved in this process not only know where we are in the process, but they are clear, this is something we will be coming back to.
That the points of the, our goal is to reach consensus,
But there will be clear points of dissent where we may not reach consensus, but it's a question we will live with because the process continues.
So if we do have those places where people feel the process ended with the approval, that's a leadership issue.
And that is a local control.
That's an ownership and an action issue about perception and about perspective.
And so I think that the work that's left to be done is not a mandate from the board demanding that you put the data into your LCAP because the statute is clear.
the process is clear, the guidance is clear, the template clearly asks for evidence on how that data was considered, but there has to be clear leadership that shows when we review and read those LCAPs, we clearly see that something has changed and that change was informed by my role and my perspective as a stakeholder.
So that is a leadership process, that is a local control process, and it is about taking ownership
Stakeholders can take ownership in the process.
Let me change that.
A lot of stakeholders feel that they can take ownership in the process with permission from those that they perceive who are in control of that process.
And so I think that where this conversation lives is in that conversation there locally.
Yeah, you want to continue on this line?
Because I wanted to shift to another topic that was brought up.
Go ahead if you want to.
Unfortunately, we're not able to agendize but repairing trust.
And I think that that was something that that board member Sun brought up earlier.
A lot of what we'll hear in the next item and in this item does have to do with the lack of trust.
And rightfully so for some groups, right?
There is a distrust because a system has wronged them historically.
And so we cannot expect for us to put up this new system and give local control and say, just trust us, it's going to work.
because we haven't given evidence to some communities that this actually will work for them.
And so we need to be aware of that.
And although we cannot sit here and agendize trust, we could do it.
And somebody, I quoted this earlier from one of the earlier presentations when they said that they were looking at problematic practices, policies, and procedures.
And the thing is that trust is manifested when we're looking at policies,
We're looking at practices and procedures and processes, right?
And so I think that on our end, that is one way that we could really try to restore trust with some of our stakeholders and students and communities.
But that's something that has to be really be done at the local level.
Because it doesn't matter if we come up with the best system, it won't be a good system if there isn't trust.
And we unfortunately don't have the track record to really say, tell people, just trust us, it's going to work.
I wanted to comment on the some groups saying that, you know, implying at least of me that they don't want to, they don't need to do an annual update.
And this is surprising and I'd like maybe Jeff Beshears could come up and this is in the law, right?
The annual update, it's been a crucial part of our theory of change.
How, you know, could you clarify what the legal situation is and how you view the annual update requirements in the LCAP now?
Jeff Breshears, again, Director of Local Agencies Support Office.
Certainly statute and the LCAP template itself requires an annual update and to look at the data that is provided, not only on a local level, but within the dashboard itself.
When the board adopted the three-year fixed year plan, it's not a static plan, and we were very careful not to say a static plan, but a three-year fixed plan was the idea to set a three-year goal.
Look, where do we want to be in three years?
and then what are we going to do in between to get there and evaluate that our progress is the LEA's progress of getting to that three-year goal.
And so absolutely it is expected, required to look at the data and to look at their progress and LEA's progress on an annual basis
One of the prompts within the annual update in the template says, as a result of your review, what are you going to do differently?
And then the template then allows to identify goals that are either new, modified, or potentially unchanged, and also the actions and services are either new, modified, based on the review of data at the local level, and also review on the data within the dashboard.
Thank you for that clarity and we will try and communicate that through CDE and other purposes.
Any other comments on this item?
Thank you.
If not, we're ready to move to item five.
We already did item four.
And we'll have a CDE presenter, but before we do, Marguerite Reese is here.
I wanted to lay out some of the background as I see it at least.
After hearing from the U.S.
Department of Education in December, we heard the day 21st right before the Christmas weekend.
So that's part of why we're scrambling for time.
It is clear that we needed to provide more background in the specifics of our state system of accountability in our state plan and some other parts of the plan.
I don't think they were able to grasp what we were really doing.
We hope that the new detail in the state plan will clarify the issues raised.
And we'll hear about that more.
We made the decision to wait for three years of data before finalizing our State Plan.
And this pushed our timeline out.
I suspect we might be in the last third of States that are finally processed by the
U.S.
Department of Education.
And I think including three years of data rather than two years was the right decision to make, particularly, for example, on our new assessment data.
And so I think that's something that we did right, but it'll make us, I think, a little slower in the processing.
We are, in March, going to
finalize a discussion of the identification of low-performing schools to provide more time to hear from our stakeholders.
And we also have taken the opportunity learned from our peers in other states that have approved ESSA plans especially in the large diverse states to see how their plans address the requirements of ESSA and how that might give us some guidance on how we go.
So our goal continues to be the creation of one coherent system of accountability rather than what we had under NCLB and with that I will turn it over
to Marguerite to introduce this item and help us understand what are changes being recommended to the board.
Well, thank you, President Kirst, Chief Deputy Price, and members of the board.
My name is Marguerite Reese, and I serve as CDE's Federal Policy Liaison in the Government Affairs Division.
I am a different face, I think, than they're used to seeing talking about the ESSA State Plan.
Barbara Murchison was California's ESSA State Lead.
And shortly after our state plan was turned in in September of last year, Barb took a position as the Director of the Professional Learning and Support Division, and so the work of the state plan transferred within CDE to the Government Affairs Division, which is why I am here before you today.
I do have formal remarks prepared, and I will be happy to answer technical questions at the end of my presentation.
So as President Kirst indicated in his opening remarks, I will provide information related to the first half of item five.
The approval of the revisions to the Every Student Succeeds Act Consolidated State Plan and Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch, will then provide the update to the eligibility criteria for the identification of the lowest performing Title I schools.
There are four attachments related to this item.
My comments today will begin with an update of the ESSA state plan submission revision and approval process.
I will then provide an overview of the feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education or ED related to the ESSA state plan submitted in September of 2017.
Attachment 1 includes a matrix of ED's interim feedback cross-referenced with the page numbers from California's ESSA state plans.
Attachments 2 and 3 of item 5 provide identical content but are displayed for the board using two different formats.
State and federal agencies must comply with Section 508 of the Rehabilitation Act of 1973, which in part requires documents and other public resources provided by public agents to be accessible for individuals with disabilities.
Attachment 2 displays the proposed revisions of California's ESSA State Plan in a format compliant with Section 508.
You will note that the new language is displayed in green highlight, changes in yellow highlight, and deletions in red highlight.
Additions, changes, and deletions are further delineated by double brackets indicating the modification.
Again, Attachment 3 includes the proposed revisions to California's ESSA State Plan displayed using Microsoft Word Track Changes formatting.
The formatting in Attachment 3 is the method in which the U.S.
Department of Education has requested that revisions to state plans be resubmitted.
Once I've completed my update, I will pause to answer clarifying questions from the board, and then I'll turn it back over to Carrick to provide the second half of the item, which includes information from Attachment 4.
As the board takes a second look at our ESSA state plan, I will spend just a few moments reiterating the foundational elements of the Every Student Succeeds Act, the reauthorization of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act, or ESEA.
The ESSA maintains the original purpose of ESEA, excuse me, ESSA maintains the original purpose of ESEA, equal opportunity for all students.
This act ensures that disadvantaged and high-need students receive the same educational opportunities as their peers.
A hallmark of the 2015 reauthorization is the increased emphasis on local control.
ESSA grants much more authority to states than under its predecessor, No Child Left Behind.
Despite a change in presidential administration since the law was reauthorized, the U.S.
Department of Education, led by Secretary DeVos, has continued to encourage local collaboration through increased flexibility.
As you can see at the bottom of this slide, Deputy Assistant Secretary Jason Botell was quoted as saying,
Each state has flexibility in how it meets the statutory and regulatory requirements.
In the years prior to the reauthorization of ESEA, California embarked in an overhaul of its public education system.
New standards, frameworks, and instructional materials were developed and adopted.
A corresponding assessment system was implemented.
And California's new accountability and continuous improvement system, rooted in the local control funding formula and local control accountability plans, was rolled out across the state.
In many ways, the principles of the Every Student Succeeds Act complement California's efforts to increase our resources and attention on continuous improvement for all student groups.
California continues to be committed to ensuring the ESSA Consolidated State Plan simultaneously meets the federal requirements while allowing for the full implementation of the Local Control Funding Formula.
The State Plan originally submitted in September and the proposed revisions provided today for the Board's consideration both outline the steps taken to develop an integrated state, federal, and local accountability system.
As previously indicated, the work to integrate the revised federal requirements are grounded in the principle of the LCFF, which empowers local communities to make local decisions to address local needs.
Throughout the plan development process, the Board and most stakeholders have been in full agreement on this point.
Following the action taken to approve the ESSA Consolidated State Plan at the September 2017 State Board of Education meeting, California submitted its application on the 15th of September.
Peer reviews took place in late October and early November for just three sections of all state plans, Title I, Title III, and McKinney-Vento.
From the date of submission, the U.S.
Department of Education had 120 days to review states' plans.
A few days, as President Kirst indicated, before the winter holiday, the U.S.
Department of Education reached out to California to set up a time to review their feedback of our state plan and provide their interim feedback letter.
Staff from the State Board of Education and the California Department of Education participated in a conference call with staff from the U.S.
Department of Education on December 21st.
During the call, ED staff walked through each of the points listed in the interim feedback letter and provided for the board today in Attachment 1.
The tone of the call was collegial and professional and by all accounts appears to be similar in tone and duration with the conversations between other states and ED regarding feedback on their plans.
I speak regularly with my counterparts from other states and they confirmed that ED is deliberately working to provide a uniform process for all September submission states.
In most instances during our call,
ED staff read directly from their letter and occasionally provided some additional commentary.
In several instances in which ED staff requested additional information, State Board and CDE staff were able to point out and reference where the information was contained in different areas of the plan, information contained within the disproportionate rates of access to educators being one example.
The following day, ED posted the interim feedback letter and peer review notes to their website.
The materials for this item of your agenda, item five, were posted to the State Board of Education's website on January 5th.
On January 9th, the CDE hosted a public in-person webinar meeting related to the proposed revisions to the state plan for the accountability sections.
Staff walked through the areas of feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education and described the proposed modifications to our state plan.
There were approximately 100 individuals that participated in that meeting.
During the call with ED, staff indicated that all states were required to respond to the feedback by resubmitting their revised plans within 15 calendar days.
Many states opted to resubmit within their 15-day window.
However, given that in California any revisions to the ESSA State Plan must be reviewed and approved by the Board, California requested and was granted an extension for resubmittal until January 26,
to allow for the proposed revisions to the state plan to be brought before the board today for your consideration.
As you will recall, states were permitted to submit their ESSA state plans in either April or September of last year.
As of this morning, 26 state plans have been approved by Secretary DeVos.
16 states and the District of Columbia submitted their plans as part of the April submission window, and all but one of those states, which is Colorado, have been approved.
Another 34 states turned in their plans this fall.
Thus far, 13 of the September states and territories have now been approved.
And 11 of them were approved just earlier this week.
It is worth also noting that no states were immediately approved upon their submission.
All received at least one round of feedback.
California's approach is somewhat different than those recently approved September submission states and that our state board weighs in on each draft of the state plan.
The proposed revisions to the ESSA state plan clarify technical points and provide additional information that will help bridge differences between our state and the U.S.
Department of Education on interpreting key elements of the ESSA statute.
The revisions offer a deeper explanation of what the plan contains.
Unlike the September submitted version of the ESSA State Plan, the proposed revisions included in Attachments 2 and 3 add additional state systems context to clarify how federal and state requirements fit together.
The expectations of LCAPs, Local Control Accountability Plans, are woven throughout the revisions.
The revised state plan has the same intents as the September submitted version, but with greater rationale and explanation for each of the items raised.
Specifically, related to items 1, 3, 5, and 11,
California has provided statewide student level data for all student groups for the English Language Arts, Mathematics, Graduation Rates, and the English Learner Progress Indicators.
We have added 5x5 tables to the suspension rate for elementary, middle, and high schools, and added data from November of 2017, which of course was unavailable when the state plan was originally submitted in September.
The following slide highlights the areas of feedback identified by the U.S.
Department of Education.
All page numbers I will reference during this slide are related to attachment to the section 508 compliant version.
During the call with ED, staff requested and the CD has provided for the first bullet change, additional information for how goals meet the statutory requirement.
Modifications can be found in item one, page 22,
academic achievement, long-term goals.
The state plan provides additional information for how goals meet the statutory requirements and includes new statewide baseline data for all students and each student group in ELA and math.
This can be found on page 30.
These baseline data are also included for graduation rate, page 41, and the English learner progress indicator, page 48.
Please note that there is a typographical error on the English Language Arts statewide student group table for the socioeconomically disadvantaged student group.
The change is listed as negative 44.6, and it should be negative 1.3.
This is found on pages 30 and 38.
This will be corrected before the state plan is resubmitted to ED.
The state plan also discusses that many student groups would need to make significantly more progress to meet the goal within seven years, pages 29 and 30.
The next bullet, interim measures, refers to item 2, found on page 32, measures of interim progress.
California added context for reference to the 5 by 5 grids.
We expanded references to the local control accountability plan on page 32.
And this section now describes the role of the LCAP to establish goals for all students and the statutory student groups across the priority areas identified in statute.
It also describes the required actions and services and related expenditures to meet the goals for student performance.
California added information regarding how the LCAP template requires LEAs to discuss any indicator where the performance of one or more student groups is two or more color-coded levels below the performance for all students.
We also included a note that state law requires LEAs to describe the efforts they are taking to make progress to close those gaps.
The state plan was also updated to include the required LCAP annual review and update process.
Related to the college career indicator and 11th grade assessments in item one, part B, page 31, the academic achievement long-term goals that include high school.
The revisions provide further context for the purpose of the CCI, the extensive research completed during its development, and the indicator's background as a cornerstone as an academic achievement measure for secondary schools.
California provided additional third-party context about the robustness of the CCI.
Related to the English learner progress indicator, item five, page 45, English learner proficiency, California provided additional context for the English learner progress indicator.
One, we added that the state board felt it was important to include reclassified students from the prior year to show growth.
And two, that by not including them, we cannot show progress or the growth students are making as they exit this group.
Item 12, page 60, relates to the weighing of each indicator.
We added language to describe that only one indicator in California's new accountability system is non-academic, the suspension rate, and the remaining six of seven indicators, or 85.7% of the indicators, are academic.
Related to the identification of lowest performing schools, item 14, page 64, comprehensive support and improvement.
The revisions to this section of the state plan describes technical assistance provisions in place to assist LEAs rather than schools to build local capacity.
The additions further describe the 228 LEAs identified for assistance under LCFF representing 2 million students and 54% of California's
non-charter Title I schools.
An in-depth overview of the data simulations will be discussed as articulated in Attachment 4.
The student growth model.
This area of feedback is in progress as indicated in Item 1 of the SBE agenda earlier this morning, and the State Board will receive an update in a February information memorandum.
And finally, access to educators.
We received letters to the board related to this item.
And as I mentioned earlier in my presentation, during the conference call with ED at the end of December, when they walked through California's feedback letter, CD staff were able to point staff at ED to information within this section of the plan related to the assignment of teachers in Title I schools.
The plan has been revised to include the timeline for which California will determine the process through which teacher misassignment data will be collected.
The California Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education approve the revised state plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education on January 26, 2018, pending the State Board of Education Executive Director approval of the final revisions requested by the State Board of Education and correction of any typographical errors.
I will now pause and see if Dr. Kirst or others have questions from members of the board, and then I will turn it over to Cara Cashly for the second half of this item.
Board members want to ask, let's have Kerrick come up.
Thank you.
Always.
Victory.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
I thank you, Marguerite, for the overview of our SSA plan.
Just as a reminder, attachment four and what I am presenting for you is not for action.
What I'm presenting to you is some different options and some data about lowest performing schools in California and how that might fit into our accountability system.
Of course, if anything in my presentation impacts what you are taking action on, which is submitting the plan for ESSA, you can certainly make amendments to that.
But we're not asking today for a decision on
on what I am presenting, which is, again, the lowest performing schools and how that fits into our accountability system.
The purpose for my presentation is to get some feedback from you so that we can come back to you in March and perhaps make a decision then about where we're going as far as identification of schools.
So what you have an attachment for, and I first apologize, it's a lot of colors, a lot of combinations.
I'm going to try to make it as simple as possible in the presentation, but at times it even confuses me.
But what we're taking a look at is data from the fall 2017 dashboard.
So just always keep in mind that when fall of 2018 comes along, we'll have a new dashboard, right?
Because we will have a more complete dashboard as our last two indicators, state indicators, college and career, and chronic absenteeism will have more than just the data that is there now, and there is data there now, but there are no colors assigned to those two indicators.
But come fall 2018, we will have a complete dashboard for all of those indicators, including the colors.
I apologize for going over a little bit of background, but I just want to make sure that we're all on the same page as we have this discussion.
Those of you sitting here are even more informed than those that are in the audience or those that may be listening online.
And so I think it's important that we just have a little bit of background.
So I apologize if some of this is a repeat for you.
But ESSA requires that states identify their lowest performing Title I schools for what's called comprehensive support and improvement.
Some say CSI for the acronym.
California was actually one of the few states that had already been discussing their accountability system and, in fact, had quite a bit of it in place when ESSA came along.
So, of course, our job, our task, is to take what we have been working on
and marry it with the federal requirements so that we meet our goal of having a single, coherent accountability system, not dueling systems, not two systems, but a single system using where we are with our foundation, which is LCFF and the identification of those schools through that criteria.
So again, as background, this first bullet point, what we're identifying for LCFF, same student group, must meet the criteria in two priorities, state priority areas, to be identified for assistance.
And that's what we have done.
Those are the 228 districts that I think you're familiar with.
And we've talked about some of that this morning.
So that has been done.
The ESSA, though, requires criteria for identifying schools for support.
And it's based on the all-student group, not what LCFF does, which is the student performance at the student group level.
I am not going to go over these four bullets, but this is just a little background of where we have come in the last year or so.
You have approved the criteria for LCFF.
We provided you quite a while ago some three options that we might use in terms of meeting ESSA criteria for identifying those for support.
There was a follow-up info memo in which we ran some data simulations on the LCFF criteria and then therefore after that took action to actually identify the 228 districts for support who are currently getting support as you heard this morning from some of our counties and districts.
And then, of course, the State Board did approve the all applicable indicators methodology for the baseline methodology to identify the lowest performing schools.
As a reminder, the baseline methodology being all red or all red and one orange, the baseline methodology.
The dashboard itself, as you know, was released in early December.
We refer to it as the fall 2017.
Early December is still fall.
Fall 2017 dashboard, it has six indicators as listed here that you're familiar with.
And as I mentioned before, just as a reminder, in fall 2018, all of them will have colors assigned to these state indicators.
The state indicators blue through red.
which the colors are assigned based on both status and growth, something that is fairly unique as far as I can tell, looking at different state accountability systems, not just looking at a proficiency level, but looking at status and the growth or the change, I should say, from one year to the next.
So when we look at these color determinations, it's just again a reminder that each of these indicators is in some ways unique in the way that it's looked at, the way that it's calculated, the data that it's used.
For instance, the graduation rate applies to obviously schools with just 12th grade students and high school, whereas the academic indicator is just right now for grades three through eight.
Graduation rate, based on a four-year cohort, means they start first time in the ninth grade.
Four years later, what is their status?
Suspension rate is based on what's called the cumulative enrollment, which is something that we actually fairly recently done, calculating a cumulative enrollment, and that is the number of students, not that are just there on one day in October, that are there for the whole year.
And so that's referred to as a cumulative enrollment and that becomes the denominator for suspension rates.
So this is all by design, each indicator looked at separately and what makes the most sense to be used as far as a calculation and a denominator when you're looking at percentage of students.
Of course, colors are only assigned if a school or a district, for that matter, if it's very small, has at least 30 students.
So 30 students is the minimum for calculating this.
And you have to have those 30 students in both the past year and the current year in order to receive a color determination on the dashboard.
The numbers of indicators are going to change on the dashboard depending on what kind of a school you are and what size of a school you are.
So again, just as a reminder, a very large K-12 school might have up to six indicators.
All six indicators might apply to them.
If you're a high school serving 9 through 12, of course, you'll have a graduation rate.
But if you have less than 30 English learners, you might have only three performance colors.
And then a very small school with less than 50 students very likely could have just one of these indicators.
So when we designed this system and we looked at the different color combinations, again, for those who would receive support, we give these indicators equal weight and we treat them equally in that.
depending on the number of indicators you have, whether it's one, two, three, four, if you're all red, you're all red, whether that's one indicator or six indicators.
If those are all the indicators you have, you would be identified in the support system.
Let me step back and say something that I often find myself saying, and I apologize again if it's a repeat.
What we're talking about here when we're identifying schools and districts for support is exactly that.
We're using the system to identify them for the support.
That doesn't mean these are the only schools or districts that are doing something, and I think you heard that this morning both from
Riverside and El Dorado and Weaverville.
Every school and every district are supposed to be looking at these dashboards, taking a look at their data, seeing what it is that they need to improve and make that improvement.
If you have yellow, no, that's not good enough.
Everyone can improve.
Everyone can get better.
It's not just those with reds and oranges that need to look at this data.
It's everyone because everyone can improve.
What we're looking at in the system of support and identifying color combinations is who might receive some outside assistance at the state level or money coming from the state down to a local level.
in addition to what they have locally available to them.
So who might get some additional support in this process?
So the methodology for using color combinations is part of attachment four, and there are a lot of different options there.
I'm not going to go over all of those color combination options for you.
I think I heard a sigh of relief in there somewhere.
But I will go over a few as some of the basic ones here.
We did four simulations, the first one being the baseline methodology.
That was the all red and the all red and one orange category.
We then took a look at what ESSA requires, which is Title I schools that don't have a graduation rate as high, it needs to be as high as 67%.
If they're not at 67%, then they would be identified.
We also took a look at non-Title I schools because ESSA does not make a distinction in this regard in identifying a high school needing support, doesn't make a distinction as to whether it's a Title I or non-Title I school.
And then last, there are some calculations in there and some different color combinations about beyond these first three, what might be used if we wanted to expand this baseline.
And expanding the baseline would just mean using different color combinations.
Instead of all red and one orange, the color combination might be three reds, one yellow, and one orange.
And as you can imagine, the combinations are not
They are limited, but there are many.
Again, I'm not going to go over all of those color combinations, but we could, if we chose to do that, use different color combinations to expand what we have as far as identifying schools for assistance in districts.
So using our current data, meaning the fall 2017 data, and again, fall 2018 will give us different results, but using fall 2017 data, that's part of your attachment four, took a look, if we were to look at the school level using the LCFF formula, we would identify an additional 84 districts to the 228 that have already been identified under LCFF.
So the next slide is a visual that I think will help identify for you who these 84 are that would be additional.
So if we kind of start in this visual from the bottom up, starting from the bottom, as I mentioned, the LCFF criteria, that's the blue.
Those are the 228 districts that are already identified already receiving support.
Then we use the baseline methodology, that's the all red and or all red and one orange, and that gets you an additional 17 districts for support.
Then the next one up is the graduation rate, using the graduation rate of 67%, below 67%, both using Title I, non-Title I schools, that would bring in an additional 20 districts.
And then lastly, if we were to use an expanded methodology, one of those methods, you'd get different numbers here, but it could identify an additional 47 districts.
So you can see on the left, it is the left side, yes, the left side of your visual, the cumulative total going up.
So it starts with 228.
with the LCFF criteria, and then as you add each of those bars up, it can get to as many as 312 districts identified.
So now, I'm gonna go back for just a second.
Those are districts, right?
So now let's look at how many schools this would impact if we wanted to look at the schools.
So this chart, going across horizontally, it starts with the LCFF criteria.
As you can see in that fourth column, 228 districts, which I've mentioned a number of times, in those 228 districts are 2,911 Title I schools.
So already, under the LCFF criteria, 228 districts has 2,911 schools.
Yeah.
So then as we add the criteria, so the second half of the chart talks about the ESSA criteria in conjunction with the LCFF criteria.
So again, the baseline methodology, looking in that fourth column, identified districts.
If you remember from our visual, we added an additional 17 using the baseline methodology, all reds, all reds plus an orange.
That would give us an additional 80 schools to the 2,911 schools already identified under LCFF.
Then we go to the graduation rate.
You go to, that would identify for those in Title I schools, it would identify eight districts, an additional 30 schools.
You add in the non-Title I high schools that didn't make that 67%.
That would add an additional 12 districts and an additional 28 schools.
And then lastly, this expanded methodology that we talked about using different color combinations could identify 47 additional districts and another 216 schools.
So when you add those up, that's a lot of schools.
That's a lot of schools.
And we haven't even gotten to the last line in the chart yet.
So just take that in of how many schools that is that would already be identified.
Then, the very last line of the chart talks about targeted support.
We haven't spent a lot of time talking about targeted support, but the ESSA law does identify schools as targeted support and improvement, or TSI.
So up until now, we've been talking about the comprehensive support, or the CSI.
The targeted, the TSI, are schools that get identified by ESSA law
in that you take the same criteria, you apply it to every student group in the schools, and if any school, any student group, one student group, doesn't meet the criteria, you would identify that school.
So by applying that methodology, or at least applying it in this way,
There probably are other ways to apply a methodology, but applying it in this way would identify another 2,649 schools.
Now, there is one, I'm hoping this is what you had your hand up for.
There is one little mathematical error on this chart.
Next to it, it says 2,999.
If you add the 354 to the 2649 number, it's actually 3,003 rather than 2,999.
A little mathematical error there.
But basically, an additional 3,000 schools we're talking about.
In addition to what?
In addition to the 2,911.
So in summary, thank you for- The total number then is five- I'm getting there.
Yeah.
The gifted students are always ahead of everybody else.
So these last two slides are the summary, which is exactly what you're getting to, President Kirst.
First, using this Fall 17 dashboard, 2,911 schools using the LCFF criteria in 228 districts.
Just those, just the LCFF criteria, look at the second bullet, that already represents more than 2 million students attending Title I schools.
in these identified 228 LEAs, 54% of California's public school students in Title I schools.
That's what the LCFF criteria has already identified.
And it's actually 32% of the total enrollment.
One more slide and we'll get there.
So this is the summary chart then.
That means approximately 5,900 schools could, and again this is a could,
be identified for support, 2,900 under LCFF.
It's actually 2911, if you remember.
And 3,000 under ESSA, or 3,003 if you wanted to be precise, but again, this is using fall of 2017 dashboard numbers.
One last reminder, fall of 2018, we're gonna add two more indicators, which will change the numbers, but these numbers are what we have right now, and so these are the numbers we should use to have the discussion.
Yeah, I think I'm going to resign from this board and go in the technical support business.
We're going to need everybody.
So that is the end of the slides for this part of the presentation.
So thank you.
I'd like to call on member Burr first to make some comments, then we'll go around.
Well, so I appreciate you putting that table back up, Kerrick, because I think that's the one that's the most relevant.
So I just want to start, sort of back up for a second, and I think that during the earlier presentation about the proposed changes in the ESSA State Plan, Marguerite did a really nice job of kind of walking through how we got here.
And the fundamental tenet was this federal plan is gonna be driven by our state accountability system.
And I think where we were asked questions, the plan appropriately gives additional information as we should to say here's what we're doing and here's how we got here and this is the backup that maybe wasn't quite so clear in the first submission.
But this part about the identification of the lowest 5% is a significant
deviation from LCFF and I think we as a board have to say what what do we do about that and I for one am not comfortable with what's proposed in the plan about which yields these much higher numbers of schools and
even well beyond if we just tried to hit the target number of what 5 percent would be.
But it does reflect conversations that we've had before, and especially addresses some concerns I know that were addressed by
board member Rucker and Ortiz-Lincon about districts where we seem to agree, I don't want to put words in people's mouth, but that our approach should be through LEAs.
That's the way the system is built.
Schools don't operate in isolation.
They can't be successful on their own without the support of their districts, etc.
So that's why LCFF premise works that you do it through LEAs.
But we acknowledge while there may be some schools that really are outliers that exist in districts that are kind of bifurcated and have circumstances in which those schools would otherwise not be identified.
So we agreed to add those and those would be part of this.
Then we have this whole other thing about the graduation rate that I think we would all agree below 67% is not acceptable.
So it does make sense to address those, but to completely deviate, and in my view, get to a place where we really would have two separate systems, a bunch of schools identified potentially
as whatever we're gonna call them, targeted or comprehensive.
And I would submit that 50% of our schools is not targeted.
It just, on its face, doesn't make sense to me.
So anyway, I just want us to think a little bit about that, and I wanna hear the rest of the conversation, but I think potentially there is some language that needs to be changed in the plan.
to reflect our reaffirmation of using our state accountability system, not promising that we're gonna do these additional color combinations.
And I think appropriately and in a not so subtle way keeps reminding us that we don't have all the data yet.
We don't have to make these identifications, as I understand it, until the next academic year anyway.
So I, for one, would not be comfortable sending a plan in that makes a commitment based on data that is not yet fully fleshed out.
Again, maybe you want to comment on what we'll do in March and what we're doing here.
Because we're going to go, you know, the March will have
we will, the board will consider in more detail the identification of the schools.
That's correct.
So we're not asking for a decision today on what member Burr's talking about?
So the action item for today, or the recommendation for action today, is to approve the revision to the state plan, which is most of the attachments in item five, to send back to the US Department of Education for their review.
What I'm hearing Member Burr say is that there may be something in that plan to be amended, so that would be an action item today.
Not asking to select a specific methodology today, but we're just here to hear some reflection from you as to what these numbers mean to you, and if there are future data simulations or things that you want to direct us to do to bring back to you in March, then we're welcome to hear those.
just for clarity's sake, so people understand, the language that's in the draft, that's in attachment two, is on page 64 and 65.
And it says, based on current data, here's something we would do, which is essentially we'll consider a different color combination.
It also, I think, has an inaccurate statement that says,
The methodology does not result in the identification of at least 5%.
But we've got 2,911 schools.
Like, how could that not be the case?
We're way over the number.
So anyway, that's the language that I'm most concerned about.
I just don't think we want to put that forward.
All right.
I think board member Rucker was next.
Yeah.
Pardon?
What page is the attachment to?
Attachment to page 64 and 65.
Member Rucker, I think you're up.
Well, I'm glad that I followed my colleague, Board Member Burr, because she explained a lot of what my comments and my concerns would be.
I just want to verify, and again, in honor of National Winnie the Pooh Day, I'm going to give you another quote that I think is germane to this conversation.
Oh, bother.
I just want to be sure, when you talked about the schools that are identified under the LCFF identification, that's 2,911 schools.
And then the schools that are identified for the ESSA and LCFF identification, that's 3,003 schools.
I want to make sure I heard you clearly when you said there is no overlap in names of schools in those two lists.
Is that correct?
Okay, so we're not actually, so.
Let me repeat that for those who might not have heard that.
This is not necessarily an unduplicated count, so there may be some overlap.
So it's possible that we're talking about a little less than 5,000 schools, all right.
So I suppose the good news in that is
You know, under the old system of accountability, we were headed to 100% identification of our schools.
So that would have been considerably more schools.
So if you're a glasses-half-full kind of person, and I am, I always ask, well, what's in the glass?
That's what's in the glass.
I suppose that in looking at what's in the plan, and I also read the same statements on those pages, I have a concern that the revisions are more than material because they do seem to mark a departure from our intent to let the central driver
of what we do for federal accountability purposes be focused on the use of the LCFF criteria.
And in saying or suggesting here are some ways that we could do this identification
I think that we are over identifying schools in the way that criteria seems to be operating because this is significantly more than 5% and it's not necessary for us.
Well, let me change that word.
it is of great concern that that would be the sheer number of schools that would be identified.
And so I guess my question is, is it necessary for that particular revision to be included in the plan at this time, especially since we don't, we have some time between today and when the actual identification and intervention is supposed to begin to include that language in the plan at this time.
because it is my feeling that that's more than a technical change.
Even the mere suggestion to me seems more material as a revision than a technical revision.
I'm also concerned that if we approve this draft with the changes that are suggested today, there's no public vetting.
How would stakeholders who have previously weighed in on this plan
have an opportunity to take a look at it?
How would the CPAG, who has contributed a lot of work, a lot of study, and done a lot of recommendations to this board in looking at and reviewing this data, have an opportunity to see this?
So if the action is to approve this plan, I think there needs to be some other vetting subsequently to this or some other work that's done.
to make sure that the agencies and the groups that have been working with us up to this point have a chance to give us some feedback before we do all the other work that the plan suggests that we could do or that we could consider before implementation.
Before you answer that, let me clarify this implication about 5%.
And now you'll correct me, but there's 5% in the law.
Then there's some other part of the law over here
that talks and the 5% relates to schools.
There's another part of the law that's, that is entirely separate that has an add-on that says targeted support must be given to any schools where any subgroup is what?
Any subgroup is, is what?
Yeah, any single subgroup.
And that applies in our case to 13 subgroups or how many subgroups?
Because we have 13 in LCFF.
Thirteen subgroups.
So there's a separate part of the law.
So take 5% of the schools here.
That's what people are wondering, having their head.
But then you've got one of 13 subgroups.
And those schools have to go in.
And that's how you get these numbers, which I think, remember Rucker said it was 5,000?
Wasn't it 5,900?
Not, you know, 1,000 here and there.
It doesn't seem to matter in this calculation.
But, you know, I thought it was 5,900.
So, yeah, it's about, that's about half our schools.
It's a little bit more than half our schools.
is that it's not 100% of our schools.
And again, going back to Pooh, I guess it's easier to have a conversation with a person who doesn't use big, long words, but short, simple, easy words.
5,900 is a really short, easy word to remember.
Okay, now, I want to clarify, now you should respond to Board Member Rucker's question.
I just want to get that straight.
I'm sorry, I guess I missed the question.
My question was kind of buried in a comment.
I'm concerned that the language on page 64 and 65 seems to suggest that we're adding this identification.
to the plan and that we may be overselling or over promising what our identification process will be that's going beyond our intent.
So my question was how was this vetted or how will this be vetted by stakeholders that have previously weighed in on the state plan and will not have an opportunity to weigh in on this if we make this decision today
and you send in the submission, and how will this be vetted and discussed by the CPAG, who also have not had the opportunity to see this suggestion and this revision?
Because it seems to me this is material to conversations they have had, and the revision is more material than technical.
I did understand.
And to me, it sounds less like a question and more like
an indication that can we amend the plan if we want more stakeholder feedback on that section?
So the answer to that would be yes.
I mean, that's the purpose of this action item.
To either approve the revision of the state plan as it is presented to you or provide some amendments if you think it's been, if there's an overreach there, you want to walk it back and get more public input on it.
That is an option.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Just to clarify, that option would then mean that we would have to also request a further extension to the department, which would then delay the approval of the plan.
No, I was not, yeah, perhaps I wasn't clear on that.
So I guess I'm assuming that this plan that we send in won't automatically be approved by the U.S.
Department of Education and there would be more time for public input.
I wasn't suggesting that we ask for an extension while we get that stakeholder input.
I think we meet their deadline.
We could even indicate in our submission in a cover letter or whatever that we're seeking more input on certain sections.
One process detail I can add is that by California or any state asking for an extension, we waived our right for a 120-day review by the US Department of Education.
So they have assured us informally that they will take a fair amount of time, given that we've asked essentially for two extra weeks.
They will try to only take two extra weeks.
But any delays on our end, I think it's safe to assume will result in more time on the US Department of Education's end.
And I think I agree with you.
I think that this will come back to us.
There was a couple of comments that were echoed in the letter from the U.S.
Department of Ed that were echoed by Bellwether Report, by Fordham Institute, by advocates, by reviewers that are still not addressed in this state plan, in this revision.
So I'm going to limit my comments to the 5% identification because, you know, I stand where I stood back in September with the state plan.
In terms of the bottom 5%, there was another layer that President Kurz, it is the bottom 5%, it is the targeted, and it's additional, the schools are not graduating 67%.
So there are three tiers that we have to identify here.
And I'm with board member Burr.
The reason we were trying to identify an expanded baseline is because we were under 303, which was a magic number.
And so when we had these discussions and we were looking, we were like, the magic number is 303.
That's the number of schools that makes the 5%.
And we were way under, so I'm not sure what happened, but I'm assuming the data dashboard happened, right?
We have new data.
So, I have questions about just the technicality of this.
We have LCFF identification.
There's overlap.
We need to know how many schools overlap.
But also, we have a one-year review process, identification process, and a three-year identification process.
What does that mean when we're looking at identifying the bottom 5%?
And when we're looking to identify the bottom 5%, right now we have only Title I schools that are part of our data dashboard.
We have not included the alternative schools.
So I wanna be clear that this bottom 5% is based on Title I schools, and then alternative schools will be bottom 5% of alternative schools.
Otherwise, if we bring them together, the majority of those schools would be alternative schools.
And then, once again, we have limited capacity.
So we haven't made that decision here, and I wanna make sure that as a policy decision, we agree on what is the bottom 5%, considering that we haven't developed the dashboard for the alternative schools.
So my office and our division, I'm Jenny Singh, Administrator of the Academic Accountability Unit.
We have been working under the premise when we identify the 5% that we will identify 5% of Title I non-alternative schools and 5% of alternative schools.
Just for the reason that you indicated, if we did Title I, if we did 5% and didn't make a distinction, all the schools that would be identified would be alternative schools.
Does that mean there'll be more schools when we get the alternative?
Okay, so yes, so we have maybe 60, 70 percent full and we got, you know, a hundred down from a hundred, but that's right.
So we have about a thousand alternative schools.
Okay.
Board Member Burr.
So I just again want to be clear about what we're looking at that under LCFF and reinforces especially for our commentators who we keep writing about that we're apparently not hard enough on districts that we've identified under the LCFF statute
which is based on student subgroup.
I'm having a hard time understanding the interaction between LCFF subgroup focus or student group focus versus targeted support.
I'm also kind of messing with my mind here.
But of the 228 districts identified under our system that we've been developing now for five years, of those districts, they contain 2,911 Title I schools.
And could you just say out of what's the total universe of Title I schools?
The Title I school, of course, changes every year.
Roughly 6,000.
Jenny says 6,400.
So third-ish and heading toward half, okay.
So I just wanted to, while Marguerite's here too, just suggest an alternative and would be happy to share language with folks.
I do think we should strike those two paragraphs on page 64 and 65 because I, for one, and I think I'm hearing other people say, don't wanna go down this path of let's try to identify all the schools, which is what we would be doing by expanding
Instead, do just some simple language that I think would allow for this stakeholder input language that says we would provide a plan supplement based on our March 2018 deliberations.
After we have additional stakeholder input, we do some additional understanding of what this data means.
I just think that might be a way to go forward.
to the extent people have other questions about the plan, and I want to hear from board members Sun and Kirst, who are the federal liaisons, but that might be a way to allow us to go forward, if that makes sense.
And I think Dave or somebody's got language that he could share so you can see what I'm talking about.
Yeah, let me put more context in this as well.
We're not the only state that's facing some of these issues.
They may not be as, we may be more extreme than most because of our local plan.
But if you scrutinize other state plans, they have ideas and some of them have been approved.
which do not follow the literal interpretation that we have heard today, which Carrick did for enlightenment purposes.
So that was what I mentioned in my opening remarks.
One of my first reaction was, we can't be the only person in this, and though I think we're going to be at the extreme end.
But there have been other state approaches.
They have been approved.
So that was part of what I think we need to take a look at.
Board Member Sun.
And I just, on this particular issue of identifying schools, I guess I just want to add, we did have that 5% number in our heads and so we were trying to get to that 300 some odd number, right?
And the difficulty was that in trying to do that, we were trying to mesh
LCFF with ESSA and it wasn't working.
It wasn't working very well and frankly we're kind of punting a little bit to try to get to that number.
I think when we finally just let it go and said let's trust our system, let's just trust what we've designed might actually work well and identified schools that need to be identified, this is what we got.
And of course we had updated data.
Because if you remember, we didn't have the fall dashboard.
I mean, yeah, well, this December fall dashboard come out yet.
So I think that when we saw this in the new information we have, I think is very valid reason to make some changes to the wording of this particular plan.
And I think it would still allow for some time for stakeholder input, because this will be an iterative process.
I'm sure this is not going to be submission, and then that's going to be it.
Yes, go ahead.
The other thing, too, that I just hope that when we do the stakeholder input, and I know we'll hear from people today, that we do this in the context of the policy and what is this, what are we doing this for?
Because I feel like, and I've had these conversations with the board staff, it shouldn't be about chasing numbers.
It should be what is this doing to improve student learning in the classroom?
I don't know what it's supposed to be doing.
When you have that many schools, number one, and you're dividing, if it's really about, well, let's try to get additional resources, the amount of money that would be available to each school is budget dust, my favorite term.
I don't know that it's enough to really make significant change.
So again, I think we have to have these conversations in the context of what are we trying to do to help Title I students
And, you know, I don't know the answer to that.
And I feel like we get lost in the identification and trying to hit some number.
To me that is the best comment I've heard about this whole conversation in that if there are 6,000 schools that need support, great.
There are 6,000 schools that need support.
But in the context of what can we actually do and to what extent and how successful will that be, that should guide us a little bit more as to how we
pick and choose the indicators, not indicators, pick and choose the method to get at this group of schools as opposed to simply following an arbitrary sort of policy or plan.
Board Member Valdez.
I agree with Board Member Burr and I really think that if we're looking at improvement science and we are looking at starting small and doing it right and then scaling up, we really need to look at this.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Is it possible when you come back in March to also let us know how we identified that 2,911?
What were the subgroups?
What were the indicators?
A little bit more information behind that.
That would be great.
The other thing is I know that
You know, this will become the focus of any revisions or amendments to the SSA plan, the revised plan.
One of the things that I want us to really consider in the context of the California way, because I know that that's the only way we will operate, is that there was a lot of discussion through stakeholders, through the feedback, through the reviewers, about how we plan to really hold ourselves accountable for growth and for meeting the state determined timeline.
I don't believe that we addressed that in the revision of this state plan, but I do think that the LCAP, currently the template that we have that we adopted for the next two years, because now we're in the second year, looks at internal gaps, so subgroups red and orange to the LEA.
But we're also assuming that that LEA is hitting the state target, and it may not, right?
And so it's important for us to consider, at the very least, looking at our own LCAP template to say internal gaps, but also subgroups to LEA, LEA to state determined timeline, and we're looking at addressing the targets.
How will we look at moving?
You have seven years, but it is unfair to expect a parent
to say, okay, well, they are significantly behind with Latino students, and I'm just going to trust that in seven years, they're going to get there.
Without showing me as a parent, what is your growth?
What is your target for year one, year two, year three?
And if you're not making gains, how can we assist you?
How can we support you?
That has to be somewhere, and that has been my permanent talking point.
We need to show how we're moving in that direction.
You know, to say that you have seven years and vaya con Dios, you will figure it out.
It's not responsible of us as stakeholders, as policymakers, to expect that we should just do it.
And I know it's local control, but there's also parents in that system.
There's students in that system.
And that was brought up in this estate plan.
It was echoed by many, many other independent and external reviewers.
And I still feel that we are not addressing it.
So let's address it at least through the California way.
Let's use our LCAP template to look at that.
Let's really consider that feedback.
Let's listen to the feedback, not just say it's our way, no way.
California is great.
We are a great state.
And when you look at other state plans, we are great.
But we are still missing the mark and we need to own that as well.
So just sticking on that point, we have the annual update in the, in the LCAP now.
So I don't, pardon?
But we have an annual update in the, in the, in that they, so there is an annual process.
It's not like we're going away for seven years and we'll come back seven years later and, and look at where you are.
if it's not included in the template, we could say here, encourage folks to do that.
But if it's not in the template, they don't have to do it.
If it's not in the design, is it the seven-year target?
No, no, the annual update is in the LCAP template.
Right, but what we're saying is we've identified what our seven year or state determined target is for each indicator.
And we need to now see our LEAs making progress by subgroup to meet that.
Okay.
Where are we here?
Who's next?
It could be either one.
Ting Sun.
Okay.
So I think the issue around growth, because if we are contingent improvement, we want some way to be able to measure that, either at the local level, state level, whatever.
So I think that's going to be a multifaceted approach.
Remember, our system isn't done yet, and we're still working on that.
I think there are opportunities to maybe look at that when we hear more about the growth model.
I think that's going to help with looking at perhaps setting some progress measures or targets and all that.
I don't think that just a change in the template for the LCAP is necessarily going to get us to where we would like to be.
So definitely, I don't feel it just because we have not thoroughly addressed that or feel like we've thoroughly addressed that in an ESSA plan.
that it is not something that California is committed to continue to do and to refine the system so that we can ensure that there is continuous improvement and progress being made for students.
Board member Valdez.
To go along with what you were talking about President Kirst is that I think what's been missing for districts is that we haven't had that target that's now identified in the plan in terms of for all of the indicators and so as districts in their updates are putting their goals and and you know annual goals but long term in terms of here's where we want to go
It was to go to where.
And so now we have the where.
And we have a timeline.
And so we're 45 days, if you will, into after the dashboard has come out.
So now districts are beginning to wrap their heads around.
We now really have a clear target where before it was sort of we know we need to get better, but the improvement model didn't really have
a real defined termination, if you will, destination.
So I think that we're in a really good place to put the whole system into place.
And so I agree with you that we now have that and it will be in the, it has to be in the dashboard.
I'm not the dashboard, but the LCAP as part of the reporting part.
Okay, perhaps we're ready for some public comment now.
So call the list.
Following people, please line up.
Doug McRae, Michael Flores-Castaneda, Sheila Whitney, Ed Manzala, Colleen Pagter, Brian Rivas, Dean Drescher, Terry Burns, John Affelt, and Eric Premack.
Thank you.
Come forward, please.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, retired testing specialist for Monterey.
This is on the ESSA lowest 5% requirement we've just been discussing.
I'd urge the board to maintain use of the status and change model, though ESSA appears to have a status only.
The data to comply with ESSA status only model is present and if ED requires, Education Department U.S., requires status only data to be submitted, you can do that only to the feds.
You don't have to publicize it here.
However, the ESSA requirement for identifying schools is clear in their statute, and I don't think there's a compelling evidence that identifying districts is a better comprehensive assistance model.
Finally, to credibly identify a lowest 5%, I think we need indicators for
Indicators for strong and less strong indicators and potentially aggregate data by just counting numbers of reds or reds and oranges.
I suggested that last September and I'd be happy to resurrect that and provide it again.
Thank you.
I'm Colleen Pachter on behalf of Los Angeles Unified School District.
In response to the proposed approaches to identifying the lowest performing schools, LUSD believes that the state should identify schools regardless of LEA affiliation.
We understand that the state is trying to focus support on LEAs and align the federal and state systems.
However, doing so at the expense of certain LEAs and potentially misidentifying the lowest 5% of schools would hinder the state's effort to support schools of greatest need.
If the state only identifies the lowest performing schools from LCFF support districts, then low performing schools outside of those LEAs would not have access to the same resources.
In addition, identifying schools among certain LEAs would stretch those districts' capacity for support.
This would put an undue strain on the resources of certain LEAs while leaving other LEAs without the same responsibilities, accountabilities, and financial obligations.
Lastly, we agree with the U.S.
Department of Education's concern that limiting identification to certain LEAs does not meet ESSA requirements, and therefore the state plan should be revised to clearly state the method of identification.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
We are pleased to see in your revisions that you are holding the course.
Many of the federal questions are in the process of being answered as the system evolves.
We think that we are already on track
to get many of those places.
That direction evolved from a great deal of very, very broad stakeholder engagement, which we appreciated and participated in.
I am glad that you are not doing a unilateral shift away from that.
or our organization, like many, has suggestions and expectations for improvements in the system as it grows and builds out, and we encourage your continued stakeholder engagement in that process.
While staying the course on a system that is focused on local engagement and decision-making, we encourage you to build the capacity of our LEAs to actually do this work, not just find districts that need help and need suggestions.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Michael Flores Castaneda with the California Teachers Association.
CTA believes the plan should be based on what California needs and wants for the students.
It's essentially the same thing as my local district's LEA LCAP plan, which should be centered on our students' needs and aligned to the state board guidelines, not influenced by them.
ESSA was designed to encourage local innovation through federal flexibility.
Senator Lamar Alexander, ESSA's main architect, said the path to better schools is through decisions made by those closest to our children, not a distant department in DC.
The system is already in place in California.
In CTA, we often refer to the California way when discussing national topics.
LCFF complements ESSA and goes much further.
Our plan was developed to give the state maximum flexibility to meet ESSA's requirements and also allow the state to continue implementing our new accountability and support system.
California is the biggest and most diverse state, which requires maximum flexibility to innovate and continually improve our work.
Thank you.
Sheila Whitley, speaking for CTA.
CTA is disappointed that there was no opportunity to provide public comment on the revised ESSA plan.
There has been opportunity all along the process to include stakeholders, and now with this revision there is basically
no opportunity for the public to give input.
We are especially concerned with the new methodologies being considered for identifying the lowest 5% of schools.
We wanted to express our concern that expanding the criteria just to reach this arbitrary number of 5% seems counter to the philosophy in California for education and would then force schools to be included and labeled as bottom 5% that are actually making improvement.
We would like you to consider keeping our current methodology that was previously adopted and provide some very specific support for schools who are making progress yet need some support in a few areas that they might be struggling with.
Thank you.
I'm Brian Revis on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We're concerned about the conversation that suggests maybe California shouldn't do the identification of schools at all.
I've been watching you long enough.
I understand the concern about the state system driving the process.
We think there's a path forward that allows the state to meet the requirement and actually builds on the strengths of what's federally required and the strengths of the LCFF system.
Don't jettison the work on identification of schools.
We're worried that if you only look at districts, you're gonna overlook some pretty poor schools, and we don't want districts to be able to hide a bad school in the system.
We agree with Member Ortiz-Licon on the comments regarding interim progress.
If you leave that work to LEAs to monitor gap closing in their LCAPs, it really departs from the experience we're seeing on the front line.
We need some big changes to the templates so people know clearly that they're supposed to be undertaking that monitoring.
Good afternoon, members of the board and President Kirst.
My name is Dean Drescher, and I'm here representing EdVoice.
I'm also a former first grade teacher.
Section 1111 of ESSA was very clear, signed by President Obama, requiring that every state provide, in its plan, academic achievement measures for high school.
California's plan has ignored this requirement, and the recent feedback to that effect from the United States Department of Education.
On top of this, an audit recently from the U.S.
Department of Education found that CDE failed to appropriately monitor local agencies' graduation data.
This gives us all the more reason to respectfully and with urgency encourage the board to take seriously the notion of accountability for students in high school and to start using 11th grade Smarter Balanced assessments that we already have for this very purpose.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Samantha Tran with Children Now.
Clearly identifying whether gaps in achievement are closing or not is good policy and is well aligned with federal law.
There are a number of issues in the state plan that we'd like to see revised, but I want to focus on this one because it's so critical.
Ideally, and Children Now has mentioned this in the past, we'd love to see that gap closure by student subgroup included in the dashboard because we think it's the most transparent way to get it out to the public and to meet these federal requirements.
We've heard from the materials that you're contemplating including this in the LCAP.
We think that might be a little unwieldy given the size of these plans and the fact that there are hundreds of pages and already focused on kind of broad goals.
That said, if the board does decide to move in this direction, we do think that updates to the instructions are critical.
If you go back and you look at the template, there's language in there that says subgroup metrics may be included, so it's permissive.
There are three-year plans, which is not
in a well-aligned with a seven-year timeline, so we just need to figure that out.
Even when there's note of achievement gap issues, it talks about being two colors below the average student.
Again, that's not well-aligned with the state or the federal law.
And we think it's important that counties clearly articulate that they're going to be reviewing the plans for this type of data and the actions and services associated with it.
Thanks so much.
Good afternoon, John Affeldt from Public Advocates and the Equity Coalition.
I want to, for Public Advocates' sake, we want to be clear that we're in agreement with the notion that the state LCFF system should be driving the boat here and the federal system should be supporting it.
That said, we appreciate
I remember Ortiz-Lacon comments and Valdez's comments that we ought to amend the LCAP
to put in there the long-term goals around the seven-year time frame and have the local districts explain how they're going to meet those goals.
We think that a minimum transparency requires that.
That's not becoming the federal system that you can still have and will have many other goals.
in in the plan, but we think that that's a minimum kind of alignment that's called for here.
Thanks.
That concludes the public comment.
So are we ready for a motion at this point or not?
I'm looking.
No.
Well, that could be included in a motion if we had a motion.
All right.
I can make an attempt.
Yeah, make an attempt.
So I will make an attempt.
All right.
So I move that the department's recommendation to approve the revisions to the ESSA plan with the following revision.
I believe this is attachment 2, page 64-65.
and attachment three, page 62.
So we currently have language about identifying with the different colors and replacing that paragraph, those two paragraphs with the state board will consider a proposed plan supplement at its March 2018 meeting for submission to the Federal Department of Education that further describes the approach for identifying the lowest performing Title I schools.
So if we have just a very broad
we're going to look at in March 2018 for that methodology.
So it takes away the attempt to try to find the different codular combinations.
Okay, is there a second?
Okay, Board Member Rucker seconds the motion.
Can I just maybe restate to clarify just so everyone has the same understanding that the motion that was just framed would essentially strike the last two paragraphs of what is section little v. i. a. on the pages 64 to 65 of attachment 3.
Is it 62 of it?
Sorry.
64 to 65 of Attachment 2, 62 of Attachment 3, and replace it with the language that Board Member Sun just read.
So striking the last two paragraphs of that section, substituting the replacement language.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
It would replace, but also it's a motion to approve the revised SSA plan.
Yes.
Okay, any further board discussion on this item?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Opposed?
OK, carries 10 to 1.
OK, well, let's take a break.
Pardon?
Oh, go ahead.
Before we take a break, just saying, appreciate all the public input, appreciate the board's keen focus and debate.
And we'll work as we work as part of additional public input
vetting the draft that and the work we've done today.
We'll work very closely with Carrick and his unit and our department work very closely with the State Board staff to address feedback to the public comments as well as your particular comments.
Thank you.
Okay, let's come back at 20 of 3.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
And we're ready for item six.
And this will be in three parts.
Carrick will first present some things.
It's an update on the CAS program, our student assessment.
And Carrick will present something on the smarter balanced assessment to open it up.
Then we'll also be dealing with the science assessment.
and the apportionments to local educational agencies for their implementation of our state assessment system called CASP.
So Carrick will begin and we'll start.
Thank you so much, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
I'm presenting the last two items for the day are both assessment items.
Michelle Center, who is our director for our assessment division, is not available.
And so you get me.
But I have brought staff with me, our Assistant Director of the Assessment Division, Mal Vang will be coming up in a minute to present the bulk of this item.
As you know, CASP covers multiple assessments, Smarter Balance, English Language Arts and Math, of which is the greatest of that contract.
But it also is made up of science as part of CASP, the upcoming Spanish test is part of CASP, and our alternate assessments are part of CASP.
So just leading up to this item, I asked if I could do a little introduction to this item.
You did receive a handout during the break, so you might have to look for it in your basket.
It will say in large, pretty large letters, item six in the upper right-hand corner and in the left-hand corner is the Smarter Balanced logo.
So as you recall, in November I was before you and I gave you an oral update at that time about what Smarter Balanced was doing in result of a news article that brought into question the flatness of the Smarter Balanced scores in English language arts and math in multiple Smarter Balanced states.
So at that time, I talked to you about what the Executive Committee was doing about it, and I am a member of the Executive Committee as well as other states.
Just as a reminder, Smarter Balance is us, is the states.
Unlike most test vendors who are basically just under contract and they have their employees, Smarter Balance states actually as part of the Executive Committee and the governing body of those states vote on many things.
Our California teachers are very involved in the development of test items and the testing of those items and in the scoring of those items as part of the interim assessments.
So we have quite a bit of say into the consortium and the assessment itself.
So, the Executive Committee very involved multiple conversations about the flatness of the test scores and what it meant and what it didn't mean and what would Smarter Balanced do in result of this.
So, at that time in November, I gave you an update about an AIR report that was done, a special report that they did in which they looked at the test item bank from 2016, they looked at it
compared it to 2017 because one of the speculations of that article was that there was something wrong with the test bank, that there was a difference in the test items.
AAR determined AAR is not part of our test administration here in California.
So as an outside independent looking at this, they said no, there's no difference, at least no significant difference in the test items from one year to the next, and no reason to believe that anything in the test caused a deflation of the scores.
But that wasn't all that Smarter Balanced was going to do.
That was just one part of that special report that was done by AAR.
Smarter Balance also agreed under the guidance of their Technical Advisory Committee to do an additional, an extension of that AIR report and to do more than just their technical review that they do annually.
They do an annual technical review and they provide a written report back to the states of the test administration for each year and any technical issues that come up as part of the administration of that assessment.
So they are doing that technical report, but in addition,
again, under the guidance of our Technical Advisory Committee, answering some specific questions about this last year's administration to see if, in fact, there is anything that we should be concerned about in not only the test item bank but in the delivery of the assessment or in the way the algorithm works for the computer-adaptive portion of the test.
So all of that is being done by Smarter Balanced.
They are scheduled to give us a report in early
an early March, a preliminary report, with the final full technical report being available to us, I believe, in July.
I want to say one thing about the Technical Advisory Committee.
You can go on the Smarter Balanced website and see who they are.
They are an amazing group of 17 Ph.D.s
expert psychometricians that come out of testing companies and researchers.
They're not employees of Smarter Balanced, so they have no specific conflict here of wanting to overlook any issues.
In fact, being on the board, they want to make sure that that test is as good as we want it to be because their name is connected with it as being part of the Technical Advisory Committee.
These are experts from all over the state, and so they're a highly
knowledgeable group as well as well known in the assessment arena.
So I gave you that oral update in November and I've just given it to you again and now you have it in writing.
So Smarter Balanced did provide to us a written notification through this memo, not just to California, but to all of their Smarter Balanced states in response to looking at those test items.
So when that report becomes available, we'll of course bring it to you as a board and if there are any specific issues, we'll address those at that time.
So now it is my pleasure, unless you have questions on that.
Yeah, I think we do have some questions on that, yeah.
Board member Schwartz.
So, Erica, I really appreciate you bringing this up.
I think as people get into looking at the test scores and seeing the flatness in some areas and the concern of not seeing growth, I think a lot of people have their own interpretation.
I think some of us think we need to actually align our teaching.
to the standards we've adopted and that the frameworks guide, and that if students were getting consistent instruction on the standards that we assess, we might really begin to see growth.
But I think there are other people who say, well, I think there's a problem with the tests, and I think the AIR was
an effort to address that issue but it seems like from the field and from some key leaders we're feeling like we need some more independent validation to the field that this is as solid and as reliable as it can be and that we're addressing any
any changes or issues that we need to.
And I think we're doing it differently.
It's a different kind of test than kids have been exposed to or teachers.
And I just think I represent many people who feel like we do need a broader independent analysis to validate the system that we're using.
Could you respond to that?
I appreciate that.
You have my commitment that I will bring that to the Executive Committee and to Smarter Balanced as a recommendation.
I will say I think one of your points is exactly right.
We knew going in that these are higher standards, they are harder standards, which means the test is harder.
And so it shouldn't have come as a surprise to us, but I think there was so much growth experience between the first two years that the flatness kind of took us off guard.
This is not an assessment like the old CST or the STAR assessment where you could do some test prep, which of course we told people not to do, and then experience a couple of points of gains.
And I think we've gotten so used to kind of that mindset that people haven't fully made the shift.
These are harder standards to teach and harder to learn and harder assessment to go along with it.
And we shouldn't shy away from that challenge.
We should embrace it and see what we can do to actually change our instruction.
not just for the end-of-the-year assessments.
We bought into a system that provides us the digital library and the interim assessments to help teachers keep track along the way of how kids are doing because that's where growth is going to come, not just assessments at the end of the year, not just a summative.
Yes, that's part of the system because that's a requirement of the system.
But we bought into a system, and we need to embrace that system and make it truly a part of instruction.
One of the things that we are trying to do when I say we, it sounds like I'm taking credit.
Our assessment division is working with our contractor, ETS, and is using people like WestEd and Sacramento County Office and some others.
to put together professional development experiences, especially we've got these CASP institutes that you may have heard about, and we also have some trainings being done in science, because if you think English language arts and math are different, the science standards are right along there with them.
And so we're putting together some academies, and maybe more, putting together some academies or institutes so that people realize how to go about teaching these new standards and how to use ongoing formative assessment as well as interim assessments.
to measure progress along the way.
For those that didn't know, our test administration for this year has opened.
It opened, I think, last week.
I don't know how many are testing this early in the season, but it is open and it's possible.
I do want to say, because we talked about it a lot previously, and that was our interim assessment changes that we made over last year,
I think we provided to you a report and a demo about the reporting system back to teachers that makes the information much more usable and user-friendly.
It ties it to standards.
There was a Patrick O'Donnell bill from last year, and the smarter balance adjustments that were made meet all those requirements from that bill.
And the reporting system, well, I can report to you that before Thanksgiving, we'd already had a million interim assessments given.
So last year, we had seven million total for the year.
So people are using the system, and even using it, if they stay on this track, it will be more than what was used previously, which is a very good sign.
So anything more before we move on to?
Yeah, no, I wanted to get your thoughts on an independent analysis and how you would define independent.
Well, yeah, that's a good question.
I'm not sure I'm the best one to answer it, but I'm going to give you my best answer.
So as you know,
Like in the curriculum world, in the assessment world, a lot of people know each other, right?
So a lot of these companies contract with each other across the country.
A lot of states, a lot of different contracts, different vendors, but these vendors do subcontract with each other.
So when I have that discussion with Smarter Balanced and the Executive Committee, we are going to have to talk about what it means to be independent, and especially if Smarter Balanced then pays for the assessment.
There are some critics that will say, well, of course they got a good assessment, a good evaluation, because they paid for it.
So we're going to have to struggle and come up with a solution of what it means to be independent.
But it does need to be somebody who has a thorough understanding of psychometric principles, as well as these new standards and these new assessments.
Not the same as CST.
So, it's got to be somebody who is recent and current in these issues of computer-based assessment and a computer-adaptive assessment environment, and to understand what the test item banks look like and how they look different from previous assessments.
So, I don't have an exact answer for you, but I know what the issues are that we need to talk about and come up with a solution.
Yes, I think those are good issues.
As you pointed out, we have many subcontracts with people that would be qualified to do an analysis of what is going on, so we have to be careful on that.
Like I said, we have 17 Ph.D.s, some of the most expert psychometricians on the Technical Advisory Committee.
Many of them would be perfect for this, though I don't know if that would be viewed as independent.
Yeah, so you have some of the best people in the state that are, you know, not, not quote independent under some definitions.
Board member, oh, board member Ruckers first.
Well, this is something I have been saying from the time that we started implementing this assessment system.
In adopting and implementing the Common Core, there was a call and a needed requirement to have and understand this instructional shift.
What has not happened with the adoption and implementation of our new assessment system in CAST is there really has not been an assessment shift.
People are very focused across the state on the end-of-year assessment, but practices in most districts concerning this assessment shift has not occurred.
So, part of the, some of the
Contributory factors to these flat scores is that there has not been this philosophical assessment shift.
AB 1035 by Assemblymember O'Donnell is an attempt to try to guide LEAs in practices to create those local norms to implement an assessment shift concerning the use of the interim assessments.
So while the data is good that shows we have a million interim assessments,
How were they used?
What was the role of stakeholders in having discussions about the use and implementation of those interim assessments?
What do teachers do with them?
And how do students interact with and participate in using and understanding what the interim assessments teach them about not just assessment, but understanding the standards themselves?
Those are the things that are not truly being discussed, and that was part of the reason why AB 1035 became important.
And let's not forget the campaign we had about the digital library.
At one point in time, we had a list longer than your legs, because you're taller than me, of districts that hadn't even bothered to enroll their teachers in the digital library.
When the digital library started, there were about 300 entries of instructional support materials.
Now there are thousands of entries, but those develop more in isolation, not because of feedback in the learning community that there was an assumption
the digital library would be built from.
We still have a lot of work to do, first of all, to make sure that the entire assessment system that was implemented is being used fully and well accessed by teachers, that folks understand what the digital library is for,
how it grows and how it contributes to and supports their professional learning, and what are the purposes of the interim assessments in creating these assessment shifts in their districts.
If we are only fully implementing or implementing really well one part of the assessment system, that is a contributory factor behind why we are seeing some of this plateauing in the test scores.
The test scores are not going to go up by themselves just because we keep testing.
It goes back to something I have always said, weighing the pig doesn't make it any fatter.
Don't look at me when you say that.
So I appreciate you bringing up the example of the digital library because that's a perfect example of Smarter Balance being run by the states.
We took that to Smarter Balance and said, we have districts not signing up teachers.
Now maybe they're overworked, whatever the reason, they're not being signed up.
So Smarter Balance said,
Well, at your permission, we'll cut out the middleman and let teachers sign up themselves.
And they did.
So that's the kind of responsiveness we get when we're part of a system in which we have a say.
Just commenting on that, isn't HMRU doing some of those kinds of studies?
We're really talking about an independent analysis of the test score, summative trends.
We have a big implementation contract out there by HOMRU.
In fact, everyone on my list is an independent analyst of it, but they are contracted to us.
So, can you explain there what we've done and what we've already committed to do through them?
I really wish Michelle Sonner were here.
But I'm going to do my best, and Mal can correct me if I don't get it quite right.
So we do have an independent evaluator.
You approved that contract, and it is HMRO.
They can look at things.
I jotted that note about use of interims to see if that can be part of that evaluation.
They do an evaluation of the test administration themselves.
So it's really more about ETS
and their delivery of the system than about the test itself.
So what we're looking for in this discussion is something to look at the test itself, not so much the delivery and how it's being used and how often and that sort of thing.
So that's sort of the distinction of what HMRO does.
Could HMRO do the other one?
Well, would they be independent?
That's the question.
You're taking our money.
Can you be independent?
That's the question.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yeah, I do want to echo the concern and the push to really have an independent reviewer because I know that there is this false narrative out there that there is something flawed with the assessment and therefore let's not pay too much attention to what the data dashboard is telling us about student performance.
And so once that becomes a narrative, then there is also less of an incentive to really try to align practice and PD to make sure that teachers are prepped to teach to the standards and then hopefully that would then lead to outcomes or improve outcomes in the assessment.
And this is, I used to teach first grade a million years ago and this is so different.
Thank God I'm married to a school teacher.
That is able to help my kids with homework because I look at some of this and I'm like, and then it's Spanish, right?
So we have to do the dual language plus common core.
It's a different ballgame.
It's, we're all, and they're learning too, right?
And I think he's lucky that he's in a district that they really are emphasizing the training.
But again, we really need to make sure that we dispel the false narrative.
If there is nothing wrong with the assessment itself and we're having flat outcomes because it is harder and the standards are more rigorous, then that also needs to be very publicly known so that people are not looking at our data dashboard and saying, doesn't really matter because there's something flawed with the assessment.
Thank you for that.
So let me be real clear on this, though.
There's nothing wrong with raising the question.
Right?
Nothing wrong with raising the question.
The only thing wrong is drawing conclusions without doing a technical review and finding out what the conclusions ought to, are.
Right?
So that's what we're trying to answer.
And that's what Smarter Balanced is willing to do.
They're not hiding from this issue.
They've been looking at it since it was first raised, and they will continue until we have an answer.
OK, other questions on this?
All right, I think we can move on to science.
Yeah, so it's my pleasure to introduce to you our assistant division director for our assessment division, Mao Vang.
Mao came to us out of a school district probably less than a year ago?
Yes.
Less than a year ago, Mao Vang.
Thank you.
Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst and board members, as Carrick mentioned, I'm Mao Vang, Administrator for the Assessment Development and Administration Division.
As Carrick mentioned also earlier, I'm presenting on behalf of Michelle Senter, who cannot be here today, who is the Director for our division.
This item requires action from the board.
The CDE asked the board to approve the following draft California alternate assessment for science related test development documents.
The blueprint, the general achievement level descriptors, and the score reporting structure.
Your approval will authorize the CDE to make technical edits as necessary to these documents.
Furthermore, the CDE asks that the board approve the projected apportionment amounts for the 2017-18 CASP test administration.
I will begin with an overview of the CAA or the California Alternate Assessment for Science documents.
If you have any technical questions during my presentation, I may ask or invite representatives from Educational Testing Service to come up and help address those questions.
As a reminder, the California Alternate Assessment for Science is designed for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
As you know, the SBE did approve the California Alternate Assessment for Science high-level test design in July of 2016, which outlined the embedded performance task model of assessment.
The embedded performance task model allows teachers to test their students on specific content shortly after they've provided or completed instruction on that content with the student, no matter when during the school year or in what order.
The California Alternate Assessment for Science will measure student achievement on the California Next Generation Science Standards, similar to the CAST or the California Science Test that was brought to you in November.
But these are specifically designed or developed core content connectors, or simply called connectors, that act as a bridge to the California Next Generation Science Standards.
So these science connectors were developed in a multi-year collaborative effort with California educators, educational testing services, test developers, and EdCount.
They are designed to be developmentally appropriate for the tested population.
So I'm bringing up this blue, I'm gonna address the blueprint first.
This blueprint document provides the specifications for how test forms will be developed for the new California Alternate Assessment for Science in grades five, eight, and high school.
Specifically, the blueprint documents the connectors to be assessed, the number of items, test items, as well as the level of complexity by a next-generation science standard domain.
The blueprint supports the California Alternate Assessment for Science measuring one overall claim.
And I have the blueprint here, so I'm just gonna take a moment here, if I could go down to the claim.
To have this in front of you, I'm not sure why it has the highlights.
Okay, well I'll just address that.
So I will read the claim out loud for you.
Students can demonstrate performance associated with the expectations described by the core content connectors linked to the California Next Generation Science Standards across the domains of earth and space sciences, life sciences, physical sciences, and engineering technology and application of science, end quote.
A subset of those connectors were identified for assessment purposes.
This strikes a balance between maximizing the coverage of the science standards and minimizing that testing burden on students and educators.
The test design rotates through all assessed connectors over a five-year period, further reducing that burden on any one student while covering more standards overall.
A student is assessed on six connectors per year.
There are 72 connectors total that are included in this blueprint, and each one is covered at least once over this five-year period.
There are 20 connectors for grade five, 24 for grade eight, and 28 for high school.
The embedded performance tasks will each focus on two connectors from one science domain.
So by taking three embedded performance tasks, a student will cover this annual blueprint on this table.
The connectors, again, that are listed in the appendix.
So through this period, CDE and ETS worked closely with California stakeholders and with experts in the field of science, as well as an alternate assessment in developing this blueprint.
So this blueprint and the plans for implementation have been revised and refined based on the input of the following groups and individuals.
We did meet with multiple groups of science educators with extensive experience working with the target population, target student population, also researchers as well as CASP administrators.
We reached out to the California Science Teachers Association for input and the CASP technical advisory group.
And Dr. Martha Thurlow, who is the director for the National Center on Educational Outcomes, who reviewed this blueprint and stated that we did take a well-reasoned approach, I quote, and I quote, and that our blueprint and standards should positively impact science education for these students.
and she recommended that we continue to closely monitor implementation well into the operational rollout of the assessment so that we can gauge impact on individual student instruction.
We also reached out to Dr. James Pellegrino, who is a professor and co-director of the Learning Sciences Research Institute,
And he also endorsed the embedded performance task assessment model and agrees that the California alternate assessment for science design and blueprint will support teaching for the student population.
So at this time, the CDE recommends the approval of the draft blueprint as written in attachment one.
the general achievement level descriptors as written in attachment two, which provide description of student performance.
They will be used to develop reporting achievement level descriptors that describe levels of performance to educators, students, and parents.
And also the score reporting structure as written on page four of the board item, which will report an overall score that includes three achievement levels.
Would you like me to go on to the next item for approval?
The next item is, no, let's stop on the science, if that's your presentation on science.
That's my presentation.
Okay, questions on science?
No, no questions from our liaison.
Okay.
Well, no, she has another item, the apportionments, right?
Yes, I have another item.
Yeah, so before we have public comment, you go to apportionments.
Okay.
Separately?
Do we need item action on this item separately or the two together?
Okay.
You can combine them.
Okay, I can, I can continue.
So I'll go to the second action item for your approval.
Remember, California Education Code requires that the State Superintendent of Public Instruction apportion funds to LEAs or local educational agencies to enable them to administer assessments within the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress, or CAS, system.
and that the state board to annually establish the amount of funding to be apportioned to LEAs for each test administered.
Remember the apportionments are provided at a per pupil rate, not per individual subject tested.
So the apportionment rates are the same as that the state board approved in January of 2017, last year.
The CDE recommends the apportionment rates as written on page two of the board item.
So at this time, I am happy to answer or address any questions you may have.
Seeing no questions on apportionment, I guess we're ready for public comment.
We have two speakers, Doug McCray and Michael Flores-Casameda.
Please line up.
Good afternoon.
I'm a retired test publisher, Doug McRae, a retired test publisher from Monterey.
In response to the Smarter Balanced memo on integrity of scores, I had two quick reactions seeing it this morning, both involving the timing for relevant data.
First, on the second to last bullet, page 1, the work in advance was of testing that they mentioned.
The simulations, indeed, were in advance.
But there was no realtime data whether the new items in the bank were performing as anticipated.
The items were not performing as anticipated.
No one knew there were problems until the consortium-wide results were released.
The technical report released a full year after test administration is woefully untimely.
Six months should be the maximum period of time for release of full technical information.
Timing suggested in the memo does not permit corrections before the next cycle.
Quickly, experienced folks with corrections for test scores know that errors are quickly after results are released.
Having mechanisms to correct should be part of a publisher's toolkit.
Finally, I do have recommendations for an independent evaluation that specializes in comparability of large-scale assessments from year to year.
I'd be happy to give that access in my November 22 memo to you.
Good afternoon.
Michael Flores-Castaneda with CTA once again.
And I can't tell you how thrilled I am to talk to you all, especially this audience, on this topic.
So I'm supposed to tell you that CTA has some concerns about the blueprint for the science assessment.
What I'm really curious to know is if any of the board members have ever seen the CAA being administered.
Because if you have, then you know, like I do, that there are serious flaws with this assessment.
Where the CAPA had a level one option for our more profound students, they could be level one through their entire career, the CAA does not.
So my third grade students functioning at 24 months are taking the CAA with third grade content.
From the pilot, I can remember a question on cumulus clouds, which wasn't even a science, it was language arts.
How does this make sense?
How is this benefiting my students' functional and life skills?
It's disheartening, and it's cruel to see them, because they know that they're not getting it.
They know they're not performing.
For Monday, I have a planning meeting with my special ed department.
We were asked to bring the blueprints for the math and language arts.
So never mind what my students need functionally.
We're once again teaching to the test.
I'm just happy I only teach kindergarten through third grade and won't be administering science.
On behalf of CTA, we would like for the state board to send the blueprints back to the appropriate advisory group for further review.
Thank you.
That concludes the public comment.
I guess I'm ready for a motion.
Pardon?
Board members.
I heard a question.
I just thought maybe the.
So I just wondered if the special advisory at all
Yeah, the assessment division routinely, in fact, every meeting that we have, there's an update.
So the commissioners are very much aware of the progress of this.
OK, ready for a motion.
OK, I will move the department's recommendation on the alternative science assessment blueprints and then also the apportionment rates for LEA.
No further comment.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that carries unanimously.
Item 7 on the ETS contract renewal.
Eric Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
I get the pleasure of presenting to you Item 7, which asks for movement on our recommendation to extend the contract for ETS.
from 2018 to 2020.
As some of you may remember, back in July, you took action and approved CDE to begin the process of negotiations.
For those of you who don't know, the negotiations of this contract are quite extensive.
They usually take two or three full days of work, and it's not just CDE staff, but we work in coordination with State Board staff who are present, Department of Finance staff are present, as well as the contractor, in this case, ETS, present in the contract negotiations.
So, you direct us in July, gave us approval to go and renegotiate that process, which we've done.
In that, we were also to bring back to you a scope of work and a budget, which is what is attached in this item.
The attachments are first, an executive summary, second, a very long, I apologize, over 300-page scope of work having to do with this contract, and then lastly, a budget that goes along with it.
So this contract is due to expire at the end of December.
So what we are requesting is to approve the scope of work and renew this contract through 2019 administration and 2020 administration.
In that negotiation process, it always opens up the possibilities of getting new things, always within budget, though, which takes some negotiation and some
some level of cooperation from our vendor to agree to do some of these things.
And in fact, there are a few things that I'll just highlight in the scope of work so you don't have to wade through the 300 pages to find it.
One of the things is we asked in this contract to extend the concurrent users on the system.
As you remember, when we first had this, we had a concurrent user
500,000 users at the same time.
That was the initial contract to do that.
As the testing went along last year, we realized how close we were getting to 500,000 users.
Those are 500,000 students sitting down at a computer at the same time accessing this assessment
either the summative or the interim because both access the same system.
And as we were getting very close, we went back to ETS and they agreed to extend that concurrent use up to 750,000 students.
And we needed most of that because we almost hit 600,000.
And what you don't want to do is get so close to where the system starts slowing down or kicking students off the system.
And so they made that adjustment for us mid-year.
So in this contract, we said we need more concurrent users.
So in this contract, 2 million.
We now have the capacity to have two million students on the assessment system at the same time.
Although it's a very large number, we think that this is necessary, not only because of the increased use of the interim assessments,
But we now have a science assessment coming online.
And any other assessments in the future we want to add to this system, because to the extent possible, we want to make it easier for school districts so that they're accessing a single system versus, oh, here's my science system to access, and here's my English language arts system to access.
And so by extending this to 2 million concurrent users,
We think it allows for that building out of capacity of other assessments.
ETS will also be working on student score reports in electronic formats, so going beyond paper and pencil and seeing and trying out some electronic formats for student reports that would even be available on a mobile device, always thinking
You don't wait for the future to plan for the future.
And so this is what we've done is negotiate for them to do some student score reports in electronic format, as well as provide translations for those reports in Spanish, Mandarin, Vietnamese, and Filipino to start.
There's always more.
And then lastly, we also asked ETS in this contract
to assist the department in doing the work toward growth models having to do with our assessment results and wanting to use growth models to help inform schools and districts of how their students are doing and the possibility of
using it in the accountability system depending on what kind of models they come up with.
So those are just some of the highlights of this contract renewal.
So the motion, of course, is asking for approval to authorize this contract renewal through 2020.
Board member comments.
Questions, I should say.
Board member Valdez.
Just a clarification on those electronic reports.
Are districts going to receive paper copies anymore?
Are they going to be responsible for printing them or how is that going to work?
Right.
So this is, and I don't know quite the right word to use if I use the word pilot or, you know, so this is a test of these electronic, right?
So we are, I think we're looking for districts that are willing to kind of pilot this.
So, it's not a full-scale switch.
We want to try this out a little bit and see how it works before trying to go wide-scale with it.
Okay.
Other comment, questions at this point?
Public comment?
We have two public commenters, Doug McCray and Katharina Gregana.
Please line up.
Hi, I'm Doug McCray, a retired test publisher from Monterey.
I'm okay with the two-year extension for ETS, but I would like to note quickly, I was pleased to see that the standard setting for the science, the main science test, as well as the Spanish test will be done using operational data in August of 2019.
rather than field test data this summer of 2018.
For pages 113, 120 in that scope of work, that's a far better design than has been used for the past three tests that have come.
Also, I'd like to express a concern on the timing of the release of technical reports for CASP tests needed for interpreting the things.
ETS provides a final, according to the scope, approximately six months after, yet the CDE has not released them for another six months.
And I would hope somebody would look into that delay.
Thank you.
Okay, there's no more further board comments.
I think we're ready for a motion.
Okay, I'll make the motion to approve the contract renewal with the Education Testing Service for the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress.
And I appreciate CDE's negotiation.
I see that a lot of the new changes in the contract is going to improve the system itself, so thank you.
OK, no further discussion.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that is carried.
OK, we're now ready for the waivers.
And we'll do this in three buckets.
We have waiver one and waiver three through five.
and Waiver 7 through Waiver 19.
So we're excluding from this Waiver number 2 where we need Board Member Rucker to recuse and Waiver 6 which has been pulled off proposed consent.
So what we need to do then is vote on the ones that are on consent.
Waiver 1, Waiver 3 through 5, Waiver 7 through 19.
So can I get a motion on those?
So moved.
Second.
OK.
Moved and seconded.
Any public comment on these waivers?
Yes.
Michael Flores-Castaneda.
OK.
Before we start, board member Strauss.
So I just believe that waiver nine is Oxnard Elementary School District, not Unified School District.
I just want to clarify that.
Waiver nine.
Go ahead.
Good afternoon.
Here for Internave School Facilities and Transportation Services Division, President Kirst, State Superintendent Tom Torlakson, and esteemed members of the board.
We just need to make a minor, make the board aware of a minor and non-substantive change to Waiver Number 9.
The name of the school district should have been listed as Oxnard School District, not Oxnard Unified.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Do we have any other comment on these waiver consent items?
Yeah, OK.
Not waiver six.
That is not in this motion.
OK, that concludes the public comment.
All of those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that was carried.
Now we have to do waiver two and wait for board member Rucker to recuse.
That is on consent.
So is there any public comment on waiver two?
No.
All right, a motion?
Move approval of waiver number two.
Second on waiver two.
Second.
OK.
Any public comment on waiver two?
No.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, now let's ask board member Rucker to come back.
And we will hear waiver six, and the department will present first.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division here at the CDE.
Today, I'm presenting to you Waiver 6, which is a physical education waiver.
Los Angeles Unified School District has requested to waive portions of California Ed Code Section 51222A related to the statutory minimum requirement of 400 minutes
of physical education each 10 school days for students in grades 9 through 12 in order to implement a block schedule at four of their high schools.
California Education Code Section 51222A requires a minimum of 400 minutes each 10 school days for the entire school year.
But because students at the four Los Angeles Unified School District high schools only take PE for one semester, they're seeking a waiver of this section of code.
Specifically, East Valley High School, John Francis Polytechnic High School, Reseda High School, and Verduga Hills High School are on four by four block schedules where students receive from 804 to 854 minutes of physical education instruction each 10 school days for 18 weeks.
As background, schools began implementing block schedules in the 1980s.
Several types of these block schedules incorporate PE instruction on a limited basis and don't meet the statutory requirement of 400 minutes each 10 school days.
To address this issue, a committee of PE experts, district staff, board members, and CDE staff developed a recommendation for board PE waiver policy, which was adopted in 1984.
This policy, SBE waiver policy number 99-03, was updated in 1990, 1999, and most recently in July of 2006.
The board considers waivers for high schools that operate on a block schedule and meet the seven criteria, which are listed on pages three and four of the waiver request.
CDE staff has worked very closely with the district and each of the four schools to ensure that they have met the criteria as outlined in the policy.
The district is requesting a temporary waiver, two years minus one day, and will need to apply for a permanent waiver before January 13, 2020.
The CDE recommends that the waiver be approved with the following conditions.
That the district must renew the waiver before January 13, 2020, consistent with the conditions in SBE policy 99-03.
And in addition, the district must create a uniform way
for each school site to document and report to the district evidence of compliance.
The district will collect documentation that provides evidence of compliance for each waiver criteria applicable to SBE Waiver Policy 99-03 annually.
So that's what I have for you today.
Do you have questions or discussion or how you want to proceed?
Questions?
Yeah, Board Member Rucker.
I have a concern that this would become a permanent waiver because they're asking for this waiver for two years less one day and then for the purpose of doing this evaluation and when they come back what they really want is a way to have this practice implemented permanently.
And I have a concern about, given the intent, I'm sitting here across the dais from the superintendent who, when he was in the legislature, made health and PE instruction a cornerstone of his legislative policies.
And the legislature, in creating this weekly minimum requirement for instruction in PE minutes, intended for this to be weekly for all students.
Not just a number in the aggregate, but as a way of making sure
that students have a well-rounded education that addresses all of the elements of what it means to help these students develop.
So while it creates a wonderful bureaucratic way to implement a block schedule and do other types of instructional innovations,
I think we are shortchanging students by creating a school year schedule where for about half the school year they receive no physical education instruction at all.
So even though this is a short-term temporary waiver the district made clear in their application for this waiver their intent for this to become permanent and I have great concerns that even though we have the authority
to waive this and create this temporary waiver, I have great concerns about the long term and sustained policy that this is going to lead to, because when they do come back, the board will be asked to make this a permanent waiver.
OK, is there any public comment on this?
Yes, Michael Flores Castaneda.
Last time today, I promise.
CTA strongly opposes the proposed waiver before you.
The problem being that this waiver would not meet the main intent of the statute or even the policy which requires PE to be an ongoing and consistent basis.
It's essentially like hitting the gym really hard January, then not going back for the rest of the year, wondering what happened.
Thank you.
Okay, is there any further board discussion on this item?
Not.
Can I have a motion?
Your board member, Ortiz-Lacombe.
So my guess is that they're having a really hard time with the master schedule to get this block, the block schedule and they're teaching AP courses or honor courses during that block schedule and therefore they probably see it as more of a benefit to the students and not.
If we deny this or what does that mean?
The waiver, we deny it.
They applied for the waiver because they had a finding around meeting the minimum requirements.
Right, they were out of compliance.
And my understanding is that is often the case.
It comes to our attention that they are not meeting the minimum requirements.
CDE staff has worked really closely with the district and the schools to pursue this waiver option consistent with SBE waiver policy.
I'm not sure exactly what happens if you deny it.
I think typically these go on consent, and this is a little bit new.
Board Member Burr.
We might need Nick here, but I think potentially they can lose apportionment funding if they're not in compliance with instructional minutes.
So it's not just a kind of casual action.
But consistent with our policy, one of the criteria is that it's in the best interest of the students.
I just don't see how this is.
Board member Strauss and then who's next?
Board member Holiday.
Well I'm just saying as a block schedule my understanding is instead of taking some class both semesters you take more in one so it's combined so the dilemma around PE is you might have more minutes in one semester because you're on block so if we were to deny it and direct them they'd have to have everything on block and PE not on block which it doesn't kind of
mesh with block schedule, my sense is we could give them a waiver but look at other options of what other block, there are other places that do block schedules and still manage to meet PE minutes.
So maybe during the time we ask them to research other and come back with options,
rather than the issue.
I mean, I think the issue is ongoing physical fitness.
I just think that's the contrast to having blocked schedules, which other high schools besides this one have done as well.
So I'd be interested in seeing what other options there are, but not stopping their block schedule.
Board Member Holiday.
That's what I was going to say.
I agree.
I think they're taking a step here.
to create a master schedule, a block schedule, which has so many advantages for so many kids and so many schools.
I'm a pretty big fan of block schedules for all sorts of reasons, but they always come up with these problems, whether it's foreign language or whether it's PE or one of these others.
But there are block schedules that work.
and meet the statute.
I say, my opinion would be that we would go ahead and provide this waiver, but not as a precedent setting, not as a way of saying it's going to be permanent, not giving that indication at all, and instead saying, okay, we don't want to stop your progress, but we want you to figure this out.
Because I go to the gym four days a week, and if I miss one day, look out, I'm going to miss three or four after that.
Okay, any other comments by the board members on this?
Listening to the good debate on this and recognizing Patricia's history with working on the standard and again trying to have our students as fit as possible, which does have academic consequences too.
So one option is the one that Bruce just laid out and really make sure, and I mean laid out, make sure that there is a different proposal that accommodates PE after the two years of this waiver.
Another possible, and this is where it's a question to Barbara, is there a time clock on this waiver?
Could this be tabled while alternatives are looked at over the next month and a half, two months?
Or is there a time clock either that the district must have this address within or is there any other time clock for consideration?
I'd want to consult with legal around ed code because I know many things, but state requirements regarding PE minutes is something new.
There's always something else to learn.
But my understanding is if we have a complete submission of things that are required for the waiver and we don't approve them within a certain amount of time, they're somewhere in education code.
There's a rule that you will have to consider it at the next meeting.
And if you fail to consider it at the next meeting, then it would become a permanent waiver.
So you have granted these waivers in the past, as Barb said, consistent with the policy.
In fact, I believe there were some from on the agenda in November.
Folsom-Cordova is the one that's popping in my brain.
I might be not permanent.
This one's not permanent either.
But as schools that are operating on a block schedule, I believe as...
Lisa said, because, you know, they have AP classes and they're trying to work out the schedules.
So this isn't unusual.
Permanent would be unusual.
But the issue here is they want a permanent waiver.
That's not what this is.
Not giving it to them.
So I will move the staff recommendation.
I'll second.
Can you consider some kind of amendment or language indicating they need to work on addressing the issue like you outlined Eileen?
but couldn't staff share that with them and we could ask staff as a follow-up to say we want you to look at other options we support your block scheduling but try to will you explore with other schools that do this and come back with it it's not permanent but we want to give you time to do it I mean do we have to communicate that with them?
Well I'll work if you prefer not I can work directly with our staff and maybe consult you along along the way Eileen.
Great.
OK, so it's been moved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, there's one no vote.
Yeah, those opposed, raise your hand.
You're right.
OK, passes then with one no vote.
And so thank you for that.
And now we're on to the proposed consent calendar.
These are items 9 through 17.
18 has been withdrawn, so we're on 9 through 17.
Is there any public comment on these proposed consent items?
Yes.
Monique Ramos for item 16.
OK.
Please come forward.
No?
Nobody here.
OK.
So any board member comments on these items?
If not, do I need a motion before we can go?
I move approval of the consent.
Second.
OK.
Moved and seconded.
All in favor, raise your hands.
OK, we're moving along.
We're down to item 19, the State Board Projects and Priorities.
So we have three parts of this.
We need to approve the minutes.
We need to approve the screening committee recommendations, and then we need to report on the various activities of the board members.
So let's have a motion to approve our minutes.
Board member Burr.
Move approval of the minutes.
Second.
Second, Holladay.
No public comment.
All in favor, raise your hand for the motion.
Okay, that's the minutes.
Now we have our screening committee liaisons report on the recommended appointments, of which there are a number for our committees.
Thank you.
You have a blue addendum in your basket and first I just want to say thank you to Board Member Williams who assisted with this and Carolyn Pfister.
We had two vacancies to fill on the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
Thank you for folks who were interested and applied.
Based on our review of the applications and our interviews we're recommending
the following people, Gail Garbolino-Mohica, who's the superintendent of schools in Placer County.
She would be representing the county superintendents.
And Jamoke Hinton-Hodge, who is a director of the Board of Education for Oakland Unified School District, and she would be representing school district governing boards.
So I make the motion to approve those individuals to appointment to ACCS for a two-year term.
And I would second that and just add that we had, I think it was six candidates for the board, district board.
I think that's right.
And they were all well qualified beyond just being a district board member and did well in their phone interview.
And any of them would have been an asset.
But this was the one that we thought could make some unique contributions to the board.
So I'm really pleased with both of the recommendations.
OK.
Any public comment on these recommendations?
Motion to proceed?
Okay, motion and seconded by motion by Burr, seconded by Williams.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, we're down to the SBE priorities.
Now we're doing these in order by name because we used to do it by these various organizations and
We are going to have member Burr start.
She is first in the order.
I will just report on CCEE.
You heard a little bit about that this morning.
We met in December.
Executive Director Carl Cohn announced his retirement officially.
His term or his contract is up in August, which he gave us a three-year commitment when we appointed him to that position.
So the board is in the process of selecting a recruitment firm.
We will be making a recommendation to the full board at our February 1st meeting.
And then we will be kicking off an official recruitment.
So as you might imagine, we are really scouring everywhere we can for the best talent we can possibly get for the successor to Dr. Cohn.
So if you have folks that you think would be good fit, send them our way.
We will have a presentation at our next meeting talking about the pilot projects that you've heard a lot about, the professional learning networks, and then the conversation that we heard this morning about the special education collective.
So if you're interested in any of those items, tune in on February 1st.
When are you advertising for the next head of CCEE?
We expect to select the recruitment from February 1st and we'll get them going right away.
I should have said that our target date to make the appointment is our June meeting.
So we're on a pretty fast track here because we'd like to select the next person so that there's overlap between Carl and his successor.
And so that's our timeline.
And members who are interested in nominating people should send it to you?
Yes.
Okay.
All right, next is board member Holliday.
Of course, tomorrow Member Williams and I will be helping assist with the charter items, but I just mentioned briefly the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee and the effort once again to embed environmental literacy throughout the curriculum and the state.
The ELC's major initiative over 2018 is to ramp up the district partnerships with whom they are working.
Right now, the ELSC is working with nine school districts to embed environmental literacy into the district priorities, plans, and budgets.
These projects are being managed by three non-profit organizations with guidance and input from the ELSC.
Change Scale is managing the partnerships in the Bay Area with four districts, Petaluma, Pajaro Valley, Alameda, and Campbell.
Tree People is managing three school district partnerships in the Los Angeles area, Glendale, Montebello, and Paramount.
And Inside the Outdoors is managing the partnerships in the Inland Empire with Rialto and Fontana.
So there are many opportunities this spring to learn more about the work of the ELSC.
At ACSIS Superintendent's Symposium in January, there'll be a presentation, Green California Summit in February, California Subject Matter Project Lead Learn Conference in February, the California Charter Schools Association Conference in March, and the California Council for the Social Studies Conference in March as well.
Okay, Board Member Gray.
I'm going to talk a little bit about, I know that CASC, the organization, had a conference called Sable this past week actually, and what they did there is the proposals that they presented for you guys in November, they basically
extrapolated on them and basically talked to the legislation or sorry the Committee on Education in the legislature to you know kind of further the proposal that you guys heard and you know and try to make impact in legislation essentially so yeah.
Okay now we're up to me and the order.
I spent a lot of time on the federal liaison.
I wanted to give a heads up on two meetings that are upcoming that I will attend with no other board members.
Tony Alpert and Kerrick and myself will meet with the Faculty Senate of the UC, University of California System.
And we're talking about the university accepting the Smarter Balanced Assessment as one of, in addition to SAT and ACT.
And then in February, the same group is going down to California State University Long Beach headquarters to confer with people down there about this same movement.
So that's in the offing.
So we'll move on to Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you, and let me know when you're in Long Beach.
We'll be happy to welcome you to my city.
So for the health framework, the Health Education Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee will be meeting next week, January 25th and the 26th.
We'll be reviewing all chapters.
This is the final meeting and I will be attending.
So it'll be great to put some faces to some of the committee members that have been working so hard with this framework.
On my page six activities, I co-hosted the majority report, and I believe that all of you received a copy.
If not, I'm happy to give you a copy.
This was published by the Education Trust West.
I co-hosted with Assemblywoman Limon and Assemblyman Santiago in LA.
It focuses on the history of Latino students in the public school system in California.
We have been the majority, because I'm Latina, we have been the majority for the last 20 years.
And there was a couple of things that were celebrated, like the fact that we've increased our high school graduation rate and we've had some improvements along different indicators.
But also there was an opportunity for us to consider how some of the areas of need of improvement and what we're seeing with our Latino population.
Once you look at the Latino population by generation, we're not homogeneous.
There's 16 countries that comprise this student group.
And so we're very diverse in language, in generation, legal status, and other things.
So how we could best serve the majority of the state of California, considering that the economic future of California really relies on educating Latinos well.
And that's all.
I will be speaking to fellows from Teach Plus on Saturday.
They wanna learn a little bit more about the function of the State Board of Education.
Yeah, thanks.
Okay, then member Rucker.
Okay, so it's been a busy couple of months since we last met in November.
Board member Strauss and I worked together as the liaisons for the Instructional Quality Commission, and we, in November, at the end of the IQC meetings in November,
We said goodbye to some of the original appointed members of the IQC including Dr. Bill Honig who was its first chair and first vice chair and really created the structure and the functionality and the good work that the Instructional Quality Commission has done in January last week as a matter of fact.
had the orientation, the annual orientation for new members who were added to the IQC, including the swearing in.
Part of the orientation was very interactive.
I want to commend department staff for their creativity in putting together an excellent day.
It was well-participated, well-attended by all but one member of the legislature who could not be there, but it was well-attended.
Members had a chance to get to know one another.
There was a marriage proposal.
Yeah, well, that's a long story I could share with you over coffee, but the important part of that story is it wasn't for me.
I will let Dr. Strauss give more details about the work and the actions that were taken.
I just focused on the orientation.
The Significant Disproportionality Workgroup also met this month in January.
Their meeting was last week.
I could not attend that meeting because I did have a conflict.
but you heard earlier the work that they are doing and the work that they are looking at.
I want to add as it relates to both the work of the Significant Disproportionality Work Group and the IQC, one of the last things Dr. Honig did while he was chair of the IQC was create an ad hoc committee on accountability, not so much to overlap and monitor the work and advising that the CPAC does for the board,
but to look at how accountability issues and how some of the accountability decisions and the work that is beginning to blossom and go forward has an impact on the quality of instructional activities that are being conducted.
They still haven't really figured out
what that means, but their intent is to support the board in the conversations that we saw germinate today and to be able to provide some advice and give you another frame or another way to look at instructional quality as it relates to some of the work that's going on with accountability.
On January 23rd, I'll be attending another meeting here at the department with the military compact, with the compact on educational opportunity for military children.
California is one of the member states.
Part of the work of that committee is to look at the ways that instructional and legislative decisions for students who are military dependents and how that impacts them as they move from state to state to make sure and that we assure they have full access and all the opportunities that should be provided to them.
to help them matriculate through our K-12 system but also make the necessary transitions from middle school to high school and from high school to their post-secondary options.
The committee is looking at and continuing to work with and provide input as the state looks at how to implement the federal requirement to have a unique identifier for military students added to the database.
And then finally on Monday, I wanna remind the board that I visited on behalf of the board Luther Burbank High School back in the fall, and it was to look at the implementation of social emotional learning in their curriculum as part of their work to implement the Common Core.
So the social emotional learning state team is having a meeting in the Bay Area on January 22nd, and I'll be attending that meeting on behalf of the board.
I just want to point out the Instructional Quality Commission in the legislation have this role of sort of seeing how the pieces fit together.
And so this was evidenced in the statute and I guess they're getting around to the point now that they've done so much work on the curriculum that they're trying to look at the interaction effects.
Okay.
Board Member Sandoval.
First the California State Summer School for the Arts.
The application is open to all high school students throughout the state and the deadline is February 28th.
It's an online submission.
Go to www.csssa.ca.gov and there are just more than 500 slots available for this summer's intensive pre-professional training program at CalArts.
history, social science framework, a few updates there.
First, the final publication for the framework is now posted on the CDE website, and final versions and the price list for the state board adopted materials will be available in early April, and the executive summary will soon be available for download, and parent brochures are also going to be available for download.
And the framework rollout activities continue through the year, through 2018, and you can see dates and locations on the CDE website.
And also wanted to mention that CCESA will be publishing and training their Instructional Materials Adoption Toolkit for History, Social Science at the end of the month.
And there was also a CDE held an input webinar for the ethnic studies model curriculum with more than 50 participants across the state.
And this model curriculum will come to the state board in 2020.
The Advisory Commission on Special Education meets next month, February 21st and 22nd.
And I just, again, want to applaud the work of each and every commissioner.
They really are involved in between meetings.
They're out in the field doing good work, really engaged in the work that's happening.
So many moving parts, and they really have their finger on the pulse.
So I'm really grateful for their counsel and their wisdom and their good work.
Thank you.
Board member Strauss.
So I have several reports.
First, the Credentialing Commission met in December, and beyond their regular procedural reviews, including updates on scores for the Cal TPA, the Teaching Performance Assessment,
They spent a lot of time talking about general ed and special ed.
There's been a lot of talk about whether you need a general ed credential before you need a special ed credential, whether you need both.
And there's obviously opinions on both sides.
So they had a study session.
It was really important and I think significant of what the outcome was, which is a belief that basically there's a common trunk for credentials that will include all general ed and special ed training for new teachers.
And then from that, general ed teachers would go into specialized
training for multiple subject or single sub, but that, and then special ed would go into early childhood, special ed, visual impairment, what they need for their special training.
But that, I think they've worked really hard on understanding what multiple subject teachers need, but the issue has always been about special ed teaching our most challenged students who still need a good core instruction.
So there's a real movement, and I think we're gonna hear a lot more about it.
coming out of a lot of work we're hearing about special ed and the special ed task force.
and needing, if we want different results, we really need to look at better training so teachers are equipped.
So I think that was really significant.
I was really fortunate to attend the Education Commission of the States in Denver, Colorado.
Glenn Price and I went, and Assemblywoman Weber, three of the members of the California team.
It's a smaller meeting in the winter, a bigger summit in D.C.
at the end of June.
We're just pretty new in joining again.
So it was interesting because we talked about issues about
K-12, funding, equity and access, and I'll share a couple others.
And then we sat at tables with representatives from different states.
So we could talk about what's California doing on funding, what are you doing on equity and access, what are you doing for higher ed.
So there were facilitated talks, lots of early learning.
discussions, which I know we're hearing a lot in all of our educational arenas.
And so really an opportunity.
The Educational Commission of the States is really intended to be a policy group that will give us neutral research that we identify what areas we need, and they're coming out to meet with the state team on February 1st.
President Kirsten and I and some of the state board staff are just going to meet with them and talk about some of the areas that we could use research and support on.
But it's a neat, nice opportunity.
And Glenn Price and I got to sit at lunch with Assemblywoman Weber and talk with her, which was a really good opportunity, I think, to do that.
So that is coming up with the state team.
Then the concurrent, last week was a busy week.
And just before IQC, we had the Concurrence Commission, which is the subject matter projects.
So member Holiday, you'll be happy to know that the first presentation was on environmental literacy.
And we're talking a lot about how to integrate it.
They involved all the subject matter leads in the activity.
It was really exciting.
And then we had updates from all the partners, CDE, State Board, CSUUC did updates.
But at the Lead Learn Conference, which is gonna be at UC Davis on the 27th and 28th, member Rucker is going to be, I believe, on the panel, facilitated by Tom Adams, talking about equity and excellence in the age of ESSA.
So I look forward to hearing.
It'll be a panel, so I think
OK, all right.
So IQC last week, very exciting.
And actually, Senator Anthony Portantino, who's part of IQC, actually came for part of it.
Yeah, and he talked a lot about needing late start.
We had some wonderful additions to our new IQC members, and in addition to procedures, the CDE did some really nice things about, okay, is this a Bagley-Keene violation?
Is this the right Roberts rule of order?
And some simulations to help people understand how motions are introduced, what the process is.
And for those of us who took a little while to see, like, how does a framework get, so first you do standards, then you do frameworks.
How long does it take to do a framework?
Then it goes out for public comment.
It was really, I think, informative because really the original members, as Member Reker said, have gone off now and there's a core that is trying to hold on to the culture of collaboration.
work that the team has developed.
So Dean Reese is our new chair, and he's going to help us a lot in our science materials adoption.
He's been really important in that.
And Suman Chow is our vice chair, and so those are our new chairs.
We have a new executive committee, and then each subcommittee established their goals and their priorities for the year.
So it was really a pretty much organizational meeting, but actually really thoughtful and
They have a lot of work ahead of them, so we'll hear continued reports on that.
And then we have a standards implementation steering committee.
That's a collaboration between CDE, State Board, and CCESA.
And the idea is to say, once we've done all these standards and frameworks and materials, so how do we implement it?
And it's a collaboration.
On February 8th, but there are what the success has done with some grant money is they have a small committee of 30 people or so that considered the collaboration committee, and then they have about 100 people.
that come together three times a year from regions around the state, those are called communities of practice, to try to build regional capacity so they can go back and train people in the regions of this giant state and diverse state we have.
So last week the ELA-ELD committee met and CD did a really nice job of presenting dyslexia guidelines and reading and what that means for
Children with dyslexia.
It was very helpful.
And then Tom Adams did an update.
They don't have grant funding now, so they're smaller.
They don't have a collaboration committee yet.
But the community of practice.
The science collaboration was so exciting to be at on Friday after IQC.
These are people, leaders around the state are so committed to next generation science.
They're involved in early implementers.
They're part of the California Science Teacher Association.
And they're planning the community practice that's coming up on February 1st and 2nd.
And it's gonna be out in Rancho Cordova at the Marriott.
It is energetic about the tools and how they're gonna train people and what lessons.
And really this is the hope as the new materials come up.
So I just think we are so fortunate and it's so inspiring to hear what our
regional leads are doing that are actually gonna impact classroom practice, because we all know in science it's not just a new book, it's a complete shift in organization.
So that was actually really inspiring and hopeful to think that what we're doing policy-wise, the implementation process.
They're dealing with regional grants, the early implementers, and taking a look at tools.
And they're also doing a lot of talk about connecting math and science and not leaving them separate.
So I think you'll hear some more about that, but I think we're just, this is the inspiring part.
Then next week, I know we have the county superintendents are meeting the beginning of the week in Monterey, and then ACSA superintendents are meeting, and CDE will be doing a presentation on all the data and the dashboards, and they've asked me to come and talk about our system of support, which I'll build on from our wonderful presentations this week as well.
And Monday, I will be with Member Recker in Oakland.
So I'm the liaison to the state, the social emotional learning group.
And we have Glenn Price presenting on the school climate report.
And also, they're going to look at the guiding principles and some dissemination about materials that they have and resources they can share.
And then we have a wonderful luncheon speaker from USC who we're going to hear on why emotions are integral to learning.
So we'll have more to share as Member Recker and I
hear this.
So it's a one-day meeting and it's part of a national network that we're involved in so lots of exciting things.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
Well I don't have as many committees as Board Member Strauss so but I got a really good one.
So the Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee is made up of the representatives from the community colleges and state board member representatives.
And so we are making some good progress.
We reviewed some draft principles at our last meeting.
Very interesting.
And so we will be refining those at our March meeting, March 16th, and hope to present that to this board pretty soon in the very near future for your review and for you to look at.
And then last meeting was focused on a lot of credentialing issues, CTE credentials and dual credentials.
So that's very interesting.
And I will say it's been a pleasure actually serving,
serving with member Feliz Ortiz Lacone and member Patricia Rucker on that because we've been doing a bit of a show-and-tell with the community our community part college partners so they show us things that they're doing and we show them things that we're doing and the last time we showed them the CCI career and college indicator and we've learned a few things about that
It's very different when we look at our items here.
When we look at CCI, we look at it through the accountability lens.
But when we look at it through a career pathways lens, we say, oh, that needs some little work.
So I really appreciate the collaboration we're having, the conversations we're having, and the lens that we're taking a lot of, not just the work of community colleges, but also our own work.
through that lens of developing workforce pathways and preparing our students for careers.
Okay, so a few things in end of November, beginning of December, I took Eileen's place at the CSBA conference, and so that was really fun to present with Nancy Burnell, the queen of, you know, the single phrase, one single coherent accountability system.
And so that was really good to be able to talk to that audience and have conversations.
And then I was invited to be one of the keynote speakers from CDE's Annual Accountability Leadership Institute for English Learner, Immigrant, and Migrant Student Programs, and so that was a really good opportunity to
spent some time with some really great leaders on behalf of English learners and immigrant and migrant students.
And I also attended a portion of the CPAG meeting and heard their report on the conditions of climate as we continue to do that work.
And next week, the World Language Committee will be meeting for the first time on the 25th and the 26th.
Board Member Williams.
I'll start by congratulating Dean Reese for the IQC chair.
I worked so closely with Dean on NGSS, all through NGSS, and was delighted and not surprised that he became the computer science person as well.
So we've shared those two roles basically throughout the time I've been on the board.
And he's just a perfect choice for the chair role.
So Member Holliday and I attended the ACCS meeting in the hearing in December.
It was a little frustrating because we didn't have a quorum.
It was a little frustrating because the technical equipment, the AV equipment did not work and every presenter was interrupted multiple times, which I apologize for because when you're trying to make a case for your school,
and they keep changing microphones and you can't see it.
It was embarrassing.
But it's all fixed now.
So when they come tomorrow, they'll be okay as far as the AV equipment goes.
So that ACCS attendance by member Holiday and I just want to remind you that that's not required.
That's not in our job description as a state board member, but I started doing it from the very beginning that I started on the board because
I felt like the charter items were so complex, and they are both emotionally demanding if they are renewals, and complex in terms of everybody's perspective on which laws apply and which don't, that it was helpful for me to go through like a dress rehearsal, to go through the ACCS hearing and hear what was said and asked, and then I was better prepared.
to go through the State Board hearing.
And as soon as Member Holliday got on the Board and also was my co-liaison, he also committed to doing that, and he has a full-time job.
So I really appreciate your commitment to doing that.
So, we did that.
I also was on the screening committee, as Member Burr indicated, and we got three good candidates.
So, in February, we are planning to have a full slate.
And we reinforced several times how important it was that every member come, every commissioner attend.
It makes a huge difference.
The CS standards Advisory committee started meeting in September in two day meetings.
They had four scheduled September October November and January So their last meeting is this Monday and Tuesday.
I will be there on Tuesday all day and
That will be their last meeting.
They will have a pretty complete draft, I understand, from the CDE staff, and that will go out for public comment, one 60-day public comment in April.
I'm going to say roughly this because I'm not sure of the dates it's going to go out, but basically in the April through early June period.
expecting to have something coming to the board in September for consideration of adoption.
We also have a Computer Science Strategic Implementation Advisory Panel, such a long name, and most of those appointments are by the governor, a couple by the superintendent, a couple by the legislature.
And during this time period in the fall, I supported Karen and the governor's staff with recommendations
For a variety of people multiple different people for multiple different slots and they've been doing that work and are expecting to have all the nomination all the appointees made
soon, since the law says that this committee will be convened on or before March 1st.
So they're moving as expeditiously as they can to finish those.
And I'll be the liaison to that group's work as well.
I've also organized a presentation on computer science.
I'm kind of like mostly about computer science these days.
I organized a presentation on computer science just recently for the California Charter School Association Conference in San Diego.
For those of you who go to those conferences, it will be on March 27th, and it will be how various charters are scaling up to implement computer science in their schools.
Granada Hills Public Charter High School in L.A.
will present, as well as Aspire will present.
This is not about the state board, but it's something I've been involved in on NGSS and computer science.
The UC system, UC Boers started a science and computer science faculty working group last fall to discuss the possibility of perhaps being able to count some high school computer science courses under Area D science.
and they were taking a look at how that would work.
As you can imagine, those two faculties, the science people are fairly protective of their department and their area and their criteria.
And so they've been discussing this.
They did end up with a recommendation to do so with certain kinds of other criteria that would have to go with it.
It would not be every computer science course in high school, it would be those that could meet the goals and criteria that are already in Area D, which are pretty much aligned with NGSS, pretty well aligned with NGSS.
They would do some tweaking on it, but not much tweaking.
The science people didn't want much tweaking done to it.
So that decision, a decision by the academic council will occur on January 31st.
and will then go to the, whether it's yay or nay, to do this, will go to the academic assembly after that.
And the reason I know about this is because I was asked last, a year ago, last August, by the new UC Board Chair, Henry Sanchez, to meet with him because he became aware that I was doing both NGSS and computer science.
and wanted to sit and talk about the rationale, a possible rationale for this.
So I am grateful to him and his staff, Monica Lynn, for keeping me informed on the progress of how this is going.
So that's the stuff I've been doing for the State Board.
Another thing I want to announce is that my younger son, Elliot,
who will turn 33 at the end of this month.
He's a fourth-year general surgery resident at UC San Diego.
He proposed to his girlfriend on December 20th, and so I now have a future daughter-in-law in my family.
and we absolutely love this young woman, so we are thrilled with that.
So that happened over Christmas, became part of our Christmas scene, and at the same time, we didn't plan any of this.
Well, we didn't plan that, obviously, but also, Stan and I, my husband and I, bought a townhome in Los Angeles that our older son and his longtime girlfriend will lease from us, and that closed on December 27th.
So there was just a whole lot happening over Christmas.
And it was kind of, yeah, it was all good, all good.
So anyway, we're thrilled, we're thrilled for all of them.
I was just going to talk about the ACCS, but now I've said my daughter got married this fall.
No, just to make sure the record is clear.
The ACCS did have a quorum for all of the agenda items at their meeting, except for the last item.
It was only the last item where we lost the quorum.
Okay, that concludes our report.
And now we're up to item 20, the general public comment.
Is there any?
Doug McCray.
I guess I get the last word.
I'm Doug McRae, retired test publisher.
I just got a couple quick comments on, I had a couple public records requests that I'm waiting for information on.
First, I had two requests for two sets of materials that were sent to the U.S.
Department of Education for assessment peer review.
That were supposed to come by the 5th of January haven't come yet, but I have been in communication with the department assessment division and I understand I'm going to get them tomorrow morning, which will be okay But secondly, I is a follow-up to the November state board meeting I request for the LPAC a standard setting validation timeline, which is one of the issues that
we had back in November.
And in January 5th, the CDE reply was they do not have a detailed timeline for the study validation study to begin in February.
And that's really not very credible response.
I just wanted to mention that.
Thank you.
OK, that's the end of general public comment.
So I want to announce that we're continuing this board meeting rather than adjourning.
because we want to start tomorrow with the executive session.
And therefore, we don't have to convene and clear the room and do all that.
So I will announce that tomorrow morning at 8.30, the state board will be going into closed session to discuss and or take action on the one issue of litigation, LAT versus state at all.
So we'll see you all tomorrow at 8.30, and we're continuing on.